BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE.
FIVE ON PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE
JUDICIARY THIS IS THE PROBLEM
WHEN YOU CARE TO COMMITTEES
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
NOW OPEN.
AND THE FIRST THING WE'LL DO IS
HAVE A ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER I'M HERE CENTER
MORE LOCK.
SENATOR BELL.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED QUORUM.
NOW WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR AGENDA --
SERVICE TO MANY AGENDAS HERE
OKAY.
WE HAVE A NUMBER VOTE ONLY ITEMS
WHICH YOU SEE BEFORE YOU BUT WE
ARE GOING.
TO PULL ISSUE.
TEN AND HAVE IT FOR DISCUSSION.
SO WILL.
DISCUSS THAT ITEM FIRST ISSUE --
TEN AND THEN THE OTHER ITEMS ARE
AS LISTED.
AND FOR THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS --
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO BECAUSE SOME
OF THE MORE -- SOME ARE --
APPROVED AS BUDGETED AND OTHERS
HAVE DIFFERENT LANGUAGE I LIKE
TO TAKE AN INDIVIDUAL.
MOTION.
ON ON EACH OF THEM.
AND SO FOR FILE ITEM.
ONE OUR RECOMMENDATION IS
APPROVED IS BUDGETED IS THERE A
MOTION.
ISSUE ONE THAT'S FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS IN VARIOUS.
WE DO SO WITHIN THE BECAUSE ONE
NINE I'M.
GONNA I'M DOING IT ONE QUE QUE
PART.
SO.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON ONE
EXCELLENT OF VOTE [inaudible]
BROKAW.
CENTER SKINNER BY CENTER MORE
LOCK.
CENTER ABOUT.
OKAY THEN FOR ITEMS TWO THREE
FOUR AND FIVE THEY'RE ALL
APPROVED BUDGETED SO IF YOU
DON'T MIND ALL TAKE A MOTION ON
ONE I MEAN SKEWS ME ON ITEM. TWO
THREE FOUR AND FIVE GREAT SORTS
ALL THOSE APPROVALS BUDGETED --
ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER I CENTER MORE
LOCK.
CENTER ABOUT.
OKAY GREAT AND THEN WE HAVE --
ITEMS. SIX AND SEVEN ARE ALSO
APPROVED AS BUDGETED.
DO I HAVE A MOTION ON SIX AND
SEVEN TO PROVE HIS PREJUDICE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
CENTER SKINNER I CENTER MORE
LOCK.
SENATOR BELL.
NOW ITEM.
EIGHT IS A TO MODIFY.
THE PROPOSAL.
AND IT HAS -- DIFFERENT ACTIONS
FOR EACH BILL SEVEN SB SEVEN
FORTY SIX TO APPROVE THE
PROPOSED RESOURCES SB. ELEVEN
HUNDRED TO APPROVE THE THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND AS
OUR SENATOR PROBES -- ANALYSIS
INDICATED.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO IS TO
REJECT THE IN EFFECT THE B. C.
P. AND A. B..
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT IS AGAIN --
AUTHORIZING AN AUGMENTATION
BASED ON THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS ANALYSIS UP THE
BILL.
SO -- IF I COULD GET A MOTION ON
THAT ONE ITEM [inaudible]
EIGHT GREAT.
ROLL CALL.
CENTERS SKINNER BY SENATOR
MORLOCK [inaudible]
SENATOR BELL.
EXCELLENT AN ITEM -- NINE IS TO
REJECT THE ITEM IS PROPOSED WE
HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER I CENTER MORE
LOCK.
SENATOR BELL.
GREAT AND WE'RE GOING TO DISCUSS.
TEN AND THEN ITEMS.
ELEVEN AND WELL LEVIN IS
APPROVED IS BUDGETED DO WE HAVE
A MOTION.
SO WITH.
GREAT BROKE OFF.
CENTER SKINNER HI CENTER MORE
LOCK [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL.
GREAT AND THEN FOR ITEM.
TWELVE WE HAVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION [inaudible]
WE'VE.
GREAT WE HAVE A MOTION -- BROKAW.
CENTER SKINNER I CENTER MORE
LOCK.
CENTER BELL.
EXCELLENT SO WITH THROUGH THE
VOTE ONLY ITEMS -- WILL NOW GO
TO ISSUE.
TEN THE INVESTIGATIONS RELATED
TO THE APPS.
AND AS FOLKS COME.
WE'VE HAD.
A GOOD DISCUSSION -- ON THE APPS
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF APPS
WHEN OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL -- WAS
HERE OF COURSE THAT'S WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND THERE'S BEEN -- CONCERNS
REGARDING BACKLOG THERE WE DID
GET A GOOD DISCUSSION THAT BUT
THERE IS ALSO -- WE HAD A GOOD --
I WILL CALL IT A DEBATE BUT THE
DISCUSSION AROUND HOW WE
OPTIMIZE -- I THINK -- FIVE
EIGHT I THINK THE LEGISLATURE AS
A WHOLE.
IS VERY COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE
THAT OUR WERE.
APPS PROGRAM WHICH IS OUR ARMS
PROHIBITED PERSONS LIST IS.
REALLY ENFORCED AND SO WE HAD A
GOOD DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW DO WE
ACHIEVE THAT FULL ENFORCEMENT.
AND WE IN THAT DISCUSSION
RECOGNIZED THAT WELL WE HAVE A
GREAT DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
LIVE IT LEGITIMATE LEAD BECAUSE
IT'S A STATEWIDE AGENCY IT HAS
PRESENTS OUR OFFICES IN OUR THE
THE NUMBER OF BOXES IN THE
PRESENCE ACROSS STATE IS LIMITED.
AND SO THE ABILITY FOR THE
OFFICERS WHO ARE IN THAT
ENFORCEMENT UNIT WHO ARE JUST DO
J.. TO FULLY DO THE ARM.
THE ENFORCEMENT IS OF COURSE
IT'S PUT TAXES THEM.
AND SO THERE WAS DISCUSSION THAT
ALREADY IT IS IN OUR CODE THAT --
THAT OUR OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ENFORCE APPS ADDITIONALLY.
AND OF COURSE WE ALWAYS WANT TO
ENSURE AND WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THAT THEIR
SOMETIMES A LAG TIME.
BEFORE THE HERE FROM OUR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY SAFE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
DID -- GO TO A A PERSON ON THE
APPS LIST AND REMOVE.
WEAPONS FROM THEM -- THAT THEI
SOMETIMES A LACK TIME SO WE WANT
TO OBVIOUSLY MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
BUT THE FEELING WAS THAT IF OUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
CAN ASSIST US.
IN.
MAKING SURE THAT OUR APPS --
THAT IT IS FULLY ENFORCED THE
NASA BENEFIT AND SO THERE HAVE
BEEN.
VARIOUS PROPOSALS AND
DISCUSSIONS FROM THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND OTHERS THAT THEY
COULD PLAY A LARGER ROLE.
SO THE RECOMMENDATION WAS THAT
WE WOULD PROVIDE SOME FUNDING TO
THE LOCAL AGENCIES.
TO BETTER PARTNER WITH OUR
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IN ORDER
TO ACHIEVE THIS SO THAT WAS THE
WHAT THE PROPOSAL WAS BUT
CERTAINLY -- CENTER MORE LIKE
YOU OF COURSE CAN -- RAISE ANY
ISSUES OR ASKING QUESTIONS AND
IF WE DO YES PLEASE COME TO THE
TABLE [inaudible]
DOJ.
PERHAPS AND YOU WANT TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES SO IF ANY
OF US DO YOU HAVE QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS WE CAN -- RAISE THEM TO
YOU -- MANAGER CHRIS RYAN
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND MARTIN
WHO RAN FROM THE BUREAU FIREARMS
AND JUST FOR POINT OF
CLARIFICATION ON OUR AGENDA ITEM
TEN HAD BEEN THE FORENSIC
LABORATORY EQUIPMENT PROPOSAL.
AND ITEM EIGHT WAS THE APPS
PROGRAMS I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE APPS PROGRAM AND WE'RE READY
TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS WE
ALSO HAVE -- VERY HERE WHO CAN
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
DNA LAB AS WELL. EIGHT MY
APOLOGIES SO I NEED TO SEE THE
GENDER THAT THE REST THE PUBLIC
AS BECAUSE I IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
TO HAVE THE FIRST TWO PAGES THAT
HAVE THE YES THAT'S WHAT I'M.
GETTING
.
I DON'T HAVE THE UPDATED BECAUSE
THIS IS THE ONE THAT THE PUBLIC
HAS IT DOES SHOW ISSUE TEN ARMED
PROHIBITED PERSON SYSTEMS
INVESTIGATION OKAY PERFECT WE WE
HAVE AN EARLIER VERSION OKAY.
BUT I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION BECAUSE SINCE THE
MOTIONS THAT I TOOK EARLIER WERE
ALL BASED ON ISSUE ITEM IF IT
WAS THE WRONG ATTENDED IT WE
WOULD HAVE TO RE VOTE.
BUT I'M GLAD WE CLARIFIED THAT
SO -- AND APOLOGIES THAT ON THE
AGENDA WAS OF COURSE CHANGED
SINCE YOU RECEIVE THAT ONE BUT
AT LEAST IT'S THE SAME ITEM BUT
GO AHEAD I MEAN IT WHETHER IT'S
NUMBERED.
IT'S AT LEAST THE SAME ISSUE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
WE SO YES YOU'RE VERY THREE GUYS
I THINK WE WERE THERE WAS A
QUESTION BOUT WHETHER OR NOT WE
WOULD -- BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROPOSAL I TINK AS AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE ACTION IS
TO REJECT.
THE APPS ROSAL THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APPS PROPOSAL.
AND THE GENERAL FUND PROPOSAL
AND THAT THERE WAS AN ITEM IN
HERE ADDING TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO LOCAL.
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO CONDUCT APPS
AND AND THAT WAS THE EXTENT OF
THE PROPOSAL [inaudible]
CORRECT.
SO IS THE QUESTION HOW WOULD
THAT FILM WITH HONOR
[inaudible] FIVE I'M GONNA CALL
ON SENATOR MORE LIKE FIRST
[inaudible]
MISTER RYAN.
I DON'T AGREE WITH THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION.
SO CAN HAVE SOME FUN.
ABSOLUTELY CENTER MORE LOCAL --
YOU KNOW HAVING MET WITH YOUR
BOSS -- IT STRIKES ME THAT HIS
REQUESTS ARE [inaudible]
CREDIBLE -- I'M -- LEANING
TOWARDS WHAT YOU PROPOSED AND
NOT.
THE COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION --
BUT IT IT DOES SEEM TO ME THAT
YOUR YOUR BOSS IS NEW TO A THE%
ROLE OF A DEPARTMENT HEAD WHICH
IS UNDERSTANDABLE -- BUT I'VE
BEEN A DEPARTMENT HEAD SO I CAN
APPRECIATE ALL THE FUN.
WHEN YOU STEP INTO SOMETHING A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN BEING A
LEGISLATOR NOW YOU'RE AN
EXECUTIVE SO -- HE NEEDS HELP
BUDGET WISE HE NEEDS HELP
STAFFING WISE YOU CERTAINLY
COULD WORK A LITTLE MORE WITH HR.
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
OPERATING THE A. P. P. S. ARE
COMPENSATED.
APPROPRIATELY AND I THINK THAT I
KNOW THAT'S A BUDGET.
TERRY KIND OF THING THAT'S MORE
ABOUT [inaudible]
MINISTERIAL OPPORTUNITY.
AND I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IS IT
CONCERNS AS WELL SO ON AND NONE
OF THOSE WERE DRESSED IN THE
STAFF [inaudible]
RECOMMENDATION [inaudible]
SO.
I WILL BE OPPOSED.
BUT MY CONCERN IS IS THAT WE GET
THESE FIREARMS OUT OF THE HANDS
OF INDIVIDUALS THAT SHOULD NOT
BE HAVING THEM.
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT MAY BE
MENTALLY ILL.
AND WE CERTAINLY HAD THE
BORDERLINE.
INCIDENT THOUSAND OAKS IN
NOVEMBER YOU KNOW SEEM DESERVE
SOMEONE SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN.
POSSESSING FIREARMS SO I THOUGHT
MAN I'M SURE I DON'T KNOW IF IF
IF I'M ACTION A QUESTION I'M
MAKING A STATEMENT ON ON ON
HIGHER I RESPECT YOUR PROPOSAL
BUT I DISAGREE.
WITH IT AND MISTER RYAN IF YOU
WOULD DARE RESPOND I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT.
WELL AB MASSA DIRECTOR HER AND
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE FIRES
PROGRAM SURE -- WELL I I
APPRECIATE AND AND OF COURSE
RESPECT YOUR YOUR DECISIONS IN
YOUR OPINIONS ON THIS MATTER --
I THINK WE'RE ALL AFTER THE SAME
GOAL HERE AND THAT IS TO HAVE
FIREARMS REMOVED FROM THE
POSSESSION OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
PROHIBITED AND THAT IS THE MAIN
FOCUS OF OUR APPS PROGRAM ON THE
ENFORCEMENT SIDE -- IT'S A VERY
COMPLEX SYSTEM AS YOU ALL ARE
AWARE.
AND THE NUMBERS JUST CONTINUE TO
GROW EVEN THOUGH WE CONTINUE TO
CHIP AWAY AT THOSE NUMBERS BUT
SOME SOME IMPORTANT NUMBERS TO
TO NOTE AND THEY WERE IN THE
ANNUAL REPORT.
WERE WE WENT FROM IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN AND ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION KNOWN ARMED
INDIVIDUALS TO NOW TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION MORE THAN TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION -- ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF US WORKING WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IT HAS THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF ARMS AND
PROHIBITED PEOPLE.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN WE HAD OVER SIX
THOUSAND ACTIVE ARMED FOLKS --
AND PROHIBITED FOLKS IN
ACCOUNTING WE CURRENTLY HAVE --
ONE I WANT I WANT TO SAY IT'S
FIFTEEN HUNDRED ROUGHLY.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH LA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT ON A DAILY BASIS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THEM TO
NINE MONTHS STRAIGHT.
SO YOU CAN SEE THE NUMBERS ARE
COMING DOWN BUT IT'S A SLOW AND
GRADUAL PROCESS BECAUSE AGAIN AS
WE TALKED BEFORE AND IT'S IN THE
REPORT.
IS ROUGHLY A THOUSAND NEW
PROHIBITED PERSONS ARE ADDED TO
THAT LIST SO EVEN THOUGH WERE
ATTACKING IT WE'RE DOING THE
BEST WE CAN WE'RE BEING SAFE --
WAR WAR REDUCING THOSE NUMBERS
BY ABOUT SIX HUNDRED TO SEVEN
HUNDRED A MONTH.
SO WERE WERE TRYING TO PLAY
CATCH UP BAY AND THE AND THAT'S
AGAIN WHY WE HAVE THE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL THERE. FOR THIS
THE STAFFING AND THE FUNDING AND
A LOT OF THESE POSITIONS ARE
POSITIONS THAT WE DID HAVE AFTER
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN BUT THEY
WENT AWAY.
AFTER THE FUNDING SO WE'RE
HAVING A HARDER AND HARDER TIME
KEEPING UP WITH THE NUMBERS THAT
WE USED TO JUST A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO BECAUSE OF THAT AS
WELL -- IT'S A VERY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- I KNOW YOU GUYS
KNOW THAT WE KNOW THAT WE FEEL
THAT WAY -- WEEK WE ARE DOING
THE BEST WE CAN WITH THE
RESOURCES WE HAVE THERE'S A LOT
OF FOLKS WORKING -- OVERTIME AND
ON WEEKENDS TO TRYING CONTINUE
TO PUT THE NUMBERS UP.
BETTER EXPECTED.
IT'S JUST BECOMING MORE MORE
CHALLENGING AND I THINK IT'S A
WORTHWHILE INVESTMENT I
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S REVIEW
OPINION OF EVERYTHING -- WE WE
DO WORK WITH THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WE WOULD
LOVE TO WORK WITH THEM EVEN MORE
SO.
SO IF THERE'S SOMETHING THAT YOU
ARE -- ENTERTAINING THAT WOULD
HELP THAT THAT WOULD BE
FANTASTIC -- BUT EVEN WITH US
WORKING WITH THE LOCALS THE
NUMBERS JUST SLOWLY COME DOWN --
SO ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO GET
HELP WE APPRECIATE IT -- OUR OUR
JUSTIFICATION RBC P. STANDS IT'S
IT'S REALLY BEEN A MATTER OF
TRYING TO HELP YOU GUYS
UNDERSTAND AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
EVERYTHING WE'RE GOING THROUGH
AND HOPEFULLY IT MAKES SENSE --
BUT IT IS A VERY WORTHWHILE
IMPORTANT PROGRAM IT IS VERY
SUCCESSFUL MAYBE JUST NOT TO THE
EXPEDIENCY THAT WE ALL WANT BUT
IT'S THE IT'S THE UP HILL BATTLE
THAT WERE.
WERE FACING.
WELL I DID NOT BRING THE REPORT
THAT YOU HAD DONE.
YOUR YOUR DRESSING THE NUMBER OF
NEW REQUEST COMING IN EVERY YEAR
BUT WE'RE STILL AT WHAT.
TEN THOUSAND ROUGHLY THAT WE
STILL.
HAVEN'T TO TO TRY AND DRILL THAT
DOWN YES SIR OF AN A AND IF I
CAN ADDRESS THAT AND IT'S IN THE
REPORT AS WELL WE TRIED TO BE
MORE SPECIFIC IN CLARIFYING WHAT
THAT.
BACKLOG WAS SO THAT IT WAS NOT
JUST THE RECURRING NUMBER OF
CASES THAT WERE WORKING AS FAR
AS A BACK WHAT WE WANTED TO
CLARIFY.
THAT BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN THERE WERE TWENTY
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE ACTIVE.
CASES THAT HAD NOT BEEN TOUCHED
BOWS OF ALL BEEN WORKS NOW THAT
SO THAT ORIGINAL BACKLOG IS NOW
GONE SO THE THE CURRENCY NINE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED CASES THAT
WE HAD JANUARY FIRST OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THAT'S OUR
CURRENT ACTIVE NUMBER BUT THOSE
ARE ALL NEW CASES THAT HAVE.
DEVELOPED OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS -- AND AND CONTINUALLY
GETTING ADDED SO AGAIN I THINK
IF YOU LOOK AT THE SUCCESS FROM
THAT ASPECT IT IS SUCCESSFUL.
AND ANOTHER THING NOTED IN THE
REPORT IS THAT IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS.
THERE HAVE BEEN. FIFTY SIX
THOUSAND NEW PEOPLE ADDED TO THE
ARMS AND PROHIBITED FILE WE HAVE
REMOVED.
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND WE'RE STILL
BEHIND THAT NUMBER THAT
CONTINUES TO INCREASE -- SO I
HOPE THAT BETTER EXPLAINS THE
THE BACKLOG THAT'S GREAT I OKAY
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT YOU OKAY --
I THINK THE AG HAS [inaudible]
ONE AREA OF EXPOSURE THAT'S A
LITTLE FRUSTRATING IN THAT IS.
IF SOMEONE.
IN THAT LIST OF TEN THOUSAND
WHATEVER THE NUMBER IS.
ACTUALLY MURDER SOMEBODY.
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T GET THAT
FIREARM -- IT IS THAT IS A
LITTLE TOO DIFFICULT TO EXPLAIN
TO THE FAMILY.
AND IT'S WE'VE HAD ANOTHER
INCIDENT POWER AWAY THIS PAST
WEEKEND I DON'T KNOW THAT
INDIVIDUAL WAS ON THE LIST
[inaudible]
BUT I WANTED TO HELP AS MUCH AS
I CAN AS RECENTLY AS I CAN.
AND IF YOU COULD CONVINCE
SENATOR BELL. TO ALSO POSES THAT
WOULD MAKE THIS A VERY FINE.
IF I MAKE COMMENTS -- EVERY.
RESPOND TO YOUR COMMENT -- I CAN
TELL YOU AS BEING THE DIRECTOR
OF THE BUREAU FIREARMS ANYTIME
THERE IS A SHOOTING IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA -- ESPECIALLY IF
IT INVOLVES A DEATH OF SOMEBODY.
I SEE THAT IMMEDIATELY I SEE
THAT ON THE NEWS MY PHONE IS
GOING OFF PHONE CALLS COMING IN
EMAILS COMING IN.
AND USUALLY THE FIRST RESPONSES
OF THE QUESTIONS ARE BEING ASKED
ARE IS THAT SOMEBODY WE KNEW
ABOUT IS THAT PERSON ON THE APPS
LIST IF SO HOW COME WE DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT AND WHEN DID WE LAST
VISIT THEM.
AND I CAN HONESTLY TELL YOU IT
IT IT IT'S 95% IF NOT HIGHER.
THE MAJORITY OF THOSE INCIDENTS
THAT HAPPENED ARE NOT
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ON ALL OUR
ARMED AND PROHIBITED LIST.
AGAIN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ARM
FOR A BIT OF LIST THOSE ARE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE KNOWN.
ARMED INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA
AND THEY BECOME PROHIBITED.
A LOT OF THESE INCIDENTS THAT
OCCUR ARE PEOPLE THAT HAVE FARMS
THAT WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT.
AND THEREFORE THEY'RE NOT
HITTING OUR RADAR.
BUT A YOU KNOW A IT'S NOT A GOOD
THING BUT IT GIVES ME PEACE AT
LEAST FOR MY JOB AS A MANAGER
OVER THAT PROGRAM.
THAT THAT PERSON THAT COMMITTED
THIS HIDEOUS OF AND IS NOT
SOMEBODY THAT WE HAVE MISSED --
SO I CAN SAY THAT THAT THAT
THAT'S MORE THE COMMONALITY OF
WHAT HAPPENS IN THESE INSTANCES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR GUESTS WERE.
PRECIADO THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER RIGHT THANK YOU JUST A
QUICK QUESTION AND I AND I
NOTICED THE RECOMMENDATION IS --
TO REJECT THE GENERAL FUND
PROPOSAL AND AND THE LAST
HEARING WE HAD TALKED ABOUT THE
REQUIREMENT -- OF WHAT FUND
SOURCE WOULD COVER THIS PROGRAM
IN THE FUTURE RIGHT -- SO I
WANTED TO GET SOME CLARIFICATION
ON WHAT THE ACTION INCLUDES AS
AS A RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
DRESS -- I APPRECIATE THE ISSUES
THAT YOU HAVE STAFF OF REASON
ALSO WHAT MY FIRST HERE'S RAISED
[inaudible]
AND IN OUR DISCUSSION WHEN EIJI
WAS HERE.
AND IN THE B. C. P. IT SHOWS
THAT WHAT'S BEING ASKED FOR IS
GENERAL FUND VERSUS THE SPECIAL
FUND AND PARTLY IS BECAUSE WE
ARE.
SO VERY COMMONLY THIS ONE OF
THESE THINGS WHERE AT LEAST THIS
IS MORE TRANSPARENT AND ITS
TECHNOLOGY.
THAT ARE SPECIAL FUND BALANCE IS
GOING DOWN IN WHICH IT IS
INADEQUATE. TO AT LEAST IN TERMS
OF HOW THE AG FEELS THAT HOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FEELS THAT.
THIS -- WORK SHOULD BE STAFFED
IT'S IN ADEQUATE COVERAGE.
SO IT'S THAN ASKING ON THE
GENERAL FUND SO [inaudible]
PART OF THE IT'S NOT ARTICULATED
IN THE STAFF ITEM BUT PART OF
THE MOTIVATION IS.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO? TO LOOK AT
HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT IF WE IF
WE EXPECTED THAT OUR ENFORCEMENT.
OF OUR RULES AROUND APPS WOULD
BE FUNDED.
BY A SPECIAL FIND.
HOW HOW CAN WE?
WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO?
THE FIRST IT KNOWLEDGE THAT IT
MAY NOT BE ADEQUATE AND WHAT WE
NEED TO DO TO ADJUST IT.
AND RATHER THAN.
WE MAY HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO GO
TO GENERAL FUND BUT RATHER THAN
JUST JUMPING TO GENERAL FUND.
WHICH OF COURSE IS WE ALL KNOW
HAS.
THE MOST COST PRESSURES.
SO PART OF IT WAS JUST SORT OF
PUT IT BACK IN.
YOU KNOW HOW WE GOING TO TO TO
DOJ THAT.
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO ACCOMPLISH
THE FULL ENFORCEMENT?
AND BRING BACK TO US IN THAT
REPORT HOW TO DO THAT WITHIN.
THE SPECIAL FIND AND IF IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TEND TO BE UP FRONT
NOTE IN A WAY.
YOU ARE AFRAID BECAUSE YOU'RE
SAYING YOU NEED GENERAL FUND BUT
THERE'S NOT A REAL.
DISCUSSION AS TO WHY.
ADDITIONALLY SO IN JUST
HISTORICALLY.
THE DEPARTMENT WAS GIVEN
TEMPORARY FUNDING IN TEMPORARY
POSITIONS FOR THEIR BACKLOG
STARTING IN [inaudible]
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND THAT FINDING
RAN OUT OR EXPIRED AS OF APRIL
OF TWENTY SIXTEEN AND THERE WAS
A LOT OF GOOD WORK DONE.
IN THE BACKLOG DID GET REDUCED.
BUT THERE WAS RECOGNITION AT
THAT TIME NOW I WAS NOT IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
BUT THERE WAS RECORD RECOGNITION
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT.
BECAUSE OF THE NUMBER OF NEW
PEOPLE ON APPS AND THE TYPE OF
WORKLOAD.
IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO MAKE
THOSE POSITIONS PERMANENT SO
TWENTY TWO PERMANENT POSITIONS
WERE APPROVED.
IN DATA BUDGET YEAR AND THEY ARE
STILL THERE WE'RE NOT TOUCHING
THOSE THEIR CONTINUING.
NOW IN THE REPORT THAT DOJ
PROVIDED US SOMETIME AGO IT
SHOWED THAT.
THERE'S BEEN DIFFICULTY IN
RETENTION.
AND THAT ALL OF THOSE POSITIONS
ARE NOT FELT.
SO PART OF AT LEAST MY
MOTIVATION WAS ALL RIGHT IF
WE'VE ALREADY GIVEN PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND THEY'RE NOT FILLED.
WHY?
I DON'T QUITE A QUITE SAY WHY.
BUT IT'S HARDER TO JUSTIFY
GIVING MORE POSITIONS WHEN
THERE'S NO CLEAR DE THAT WE CAN
EVEN FILL THEM.
AND GIVEN THAT WE KNOW THAT
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
HAS THE HAS THE ABILITY AND
WILLINGNESS THEN USING MORSE
PARTNERS THAT WAS PART OF THE
THINKING.
NOW.
I AM MORE THAN WILLING TO HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN.
AND TO GIVE IT A RE LOOK. TO SEE
WHAT THE APPROPRIATE WAY TO MOVE
FORWARD.
BUT AT LEAST.
WE'VE HEARD FROM MY VICE CHAIR
ABOUT THE IT HIS PERSPECTIVE ON
IT AND YOU'VE HEARD.
THAT AT LEAST IN MY THINKING IT
WAS TRYING TO GET AT HOW TO
REDUCE OUR GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES.
AND AND HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN ACCOMPLISH THIS KNOWING THAT
WE HAVE VACANCIES IN GIVING MORE
POSITIONS DOESN'T NECESSARILY.
FILL THE F. T.'S SO.
BUT WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN.
SO THAT WE CAN GIVE SOME MORE
THINKING TO THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MANAGER OKAY.
RIGHT.
YES SENATOR BREAUX.
I'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS WITH THE
STAFF.
FOR LONGER THAN.
BOTH MY COLLEAGUES HERE -- I
THINK THE PROBLEM I HAVE IS WE
KEEP COMING IN AND ASKING FOR
MORE MONEY.
AND TO MAKE THE STAFF'S
PERMANENT.
IN MY BLOW AWAY PUT IN AS WE
DON'T GET ANY [inaudible]
RESULTS.
OR WE WE WE ARE TOLD WE'RE GOING
TO GET SOME RESULTS THAT WE
DON'T ACHIEVE THOSE.
SO SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO SEE IF
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD IT.
IS OKAY WE'RE LOOKING AT
ALLOCATE SOME MONEY HERE.
HOW WHAT KIND OF RESULTS WE
GOTTA GET?
WE'RE GOING TO PRODUCE FOR US
ARE HOW HOW IS THIS.
OF GOING TO ACTUALLY --
ACCOMPLISH SOMETHING WHAT'S
PERFORMANCE.
WHAT PERFORMANCE YOU GONNA GIVE
AND I I DON'T I DON'T WANT JUST
A BUNCH OF?
MADE UP STUFF I WON A REALITY
CHECK YOUR HOW MANY HOW MANY
VACANCIES YOU HAVE NOW ARE YOU
ARE YOU.
UNDERSTAFFED NOW ARE YOU NOT
PERFORMED BECAUSE OF THAT.
AND I THINK WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
PASSES WE GAVE MONEY FOR THIS.
THE THIS YOU WERE ABLE TO ROUTE
TO HIRE PEOPLE YOU HAVE DELAYED
DELAYS AND SOME OF THE HIRING
AND SO WHEN WHEN THAT HAPPENED
THE DELAY HAPPEN.
YOU FOR YOU YOU FELL FURTHER
BEHIND AND THE NUMBER STARTED
GETTING BIGGER AND BIGGER
BECAUSE THEY COME IN EVERY YEAR.
HE STARTED FALLING BEHIND YOU
WERE KEEPING UP WITH THE WITH
THE THE NUMBERS OF INDIVIDUALS.
THAT SO SO LIKE IF IF -- IF WE
ALLOCATE MORE MONEY TO TO YOU.
IS -- IT GOING TO HAVE A
SUBSTANTIVE IMPACT.
ON REDUCTION.
OF THE NUMBERS IF NOT.
I WANNA I WANNA I WANT HONEST
TRUTH SO I'M I'M LESS WHEN
LOOKING FOR MANAGER.
PERFORMANCE MAY I COMMENT YES
ABSOLUTELY GERMAN NHI<c.cyan> YOU</c>
WILL SEE RESULTS.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN RESULTS AND
AND IT MAY NOT BE TO THE
EXPECTATION THAT YOU YOU HAD.
AND MAYBE THERE WAS A MAYBE
THERE WAS A IN IN ACCURACY OR
YOU WERE LED TO BELIEVE
DIFFERENTLY THAN I THINK MAYBE
THAT WAS INTENDED.
IF THERE WAS EVER A FONT THAT
THIS THIS PROGRAMWAS GOING TO
BE ABLE TO GET THESE NUMBERS
DOWN.
TO ZERO THAT MAY BE IT MAY HAVE
BEEN IN THEORY IF ALL THE
NUMBERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA STAYED THE SAME BUT
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN INCREASING --
WE HAD LIMITED TERM POSITIONS I
KNOW YOU'RE AWARE OF ALL THE
PROBLEMS WITH TRYING TO FILL
THOSE -- I CAN I CAN DEFINITELY
ARRANGE TO HAVE A A MEETING WITH
YOU TO SHOW YOU THE NUMBERS AND
SORTS STATISTICS HELP YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE HAD A A
POSITIVE INC IMPACT AND HAVING
THOSE NUMBERS REDUCE -- THE THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND STAFF
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WILL
DEFINITELY CONTINUE TO HAVE A
POSITIVE IMPACT IN REDUCING
THOSE NUMBERS.
WHAT I THINK ONE THING WE HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND IS I DON'T THINK
THAT NUMBER WILL EVER BE AT ZERO
IN THE REASON I SAY THAT IS WE
HAVE THIRTY PEOPLE A DAY OR MORE
BEING ADDED TO IT?
ROUGHLY A THOUSAND A MONTH.
WE DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT TO GET
A GLASS SO WE'RE FIGHTING THAT
BATTLE -- I THINK WHAT WOULD
HELP US ALL UNDERSTAND
REALISTICALLY IS WHAT IS A
MAINTENANCE LEVEL THAT THAT
NUMBER COULD BE AT THAT WE'RE
ALL.
SOMEWHAT ACCEPTABLE WITH I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT NUMBER IS BUT I'M
ESTIMATING SOMEWHERE IN A FOUR
THOUSAND RANGE SO RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE ROUGHLY.
NINE THOUSAND ACTIVE ARMED AND
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT WERE STILL
TRYING TO CHIP AWAY AT
EVENTUALLY HOPEFULLY WITH THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND PERMANENT
POSITIONS WERE TALKING ABOUT WE
CAN GET THESE NUMBERS DOWN
CLOSER TO SOMETHING MORE
MAINTAINABLE.
LIKE FOUR THOUSAND ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS WITH US WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE LOCALS.
THAT I THINK IS MORE REALISTIC
AND UNDERSTANDABLE TO ALL OF US --
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WE CAN'T CONTROL IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT WHETHER IT'S NEW
LAWS THAT ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED
NEW FIREARMS THAT ARE.
BEING CONSIDERED -- ILLEGAL
WHATEVER'S HAPPENING THAT CAUSES
THE NUMBERS INCREASE WERE ALWAYS
FIGHTING THAT BATTLE -- SO I I
CAN I CAN TELL YOU THAT YES I
THINK IT WILL HAVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON A THINK WE CAN SHOW
THAT.
YEAH I THINK -- JUST.
HISTORY.
ON US. ONE OF THE ONE OF THE ONE
OF THE THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT
THE PASS WAS.
OKAY OF THIS MODEL OF HIRING
MORE STAFF IN DOING THIS.
DOESN'T WORK.
MAY WE OUGHT TO DO SOME --
RETHINKING OF HOW WE IMPLEMENT
THIS PROGRAM MAYBE HAVE.
MORE LOCAL PARTNERS ENGAGED IN A
FIND OUT WHERE YOUR HOT SPOTS
ARE YOU KNOW LIKE WHERE THE THE
WORST AREAS ARE MAYBE.
HAVE SPECIAL -- I REPROACH IS
FOR THOSE AREAS I MEAN YOU YOU
YOU YOU YOU SEE WHAT I'M SAYING.
I MEAN PERFORMANCE MAJOR LOOK AT
ALL THE OPTIONS YOU KNOW JUST
KIND OF COME IN.
AND SAY WE NEED SHOULD WE JUST
NEED MORE STAFF THAT DOESN'T.
THAT'S WHEN WHEN PEOPLE DO THAT
THAT'S A SIGN YOU'RE NOT LOOKING
AT PERFORMANCE. TO BE HONEST
ABOUT IT IT'S NOT IT'S NOT A
GOOD SIGN.
WHAT I WANT TO SEE IS I WANT TO
SEE WHAT THE OPTIONS ARE?
ARE YOU ARE YOU ARE YOU TRYING
TO BE CREATIVE IN TERMS OF
CREATING AN OPTION THAT WILL.
WILL WILL CUT DOWN THOSE NUMBERS
AND AND HELP FOR FOR SO WE DON'T
HAVE PEOPLE.
RUNNING AROUND SHOOTING --
PEOPLE THAT ARE.
NOT SUPPOSED TO BE HAVING
FIREARMS IN THEIR POSSESSION SO.
AND AND AGAIN WE DO WORK WITH
THE LOCALS.
ALL THE TIME IF THERE'S A WAY
THAT WE CAN -- FURTHER CONVINCED
THEM TO HAVE A AN INTEREST OR
DESIRE TO WORK WITH US.
AND IF THIS -- THIS INITIATIVE
THAT YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT AS FAR
AS HAVING GRANT FUNDING WILL
HELP THAT IN A WAY I THINK
THAT'S FANTASTIC -- KEEPING IN
MIND NEED A LOT OF LOCAL AW LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE ALSO
FIGHTING FOR FUNDING AND
RESOURCES AND EVERYTHING ELSE SO
WHEN WE GO OUT AND WORK WITH
THEM OFTENTIMES IT WILL BE.
THEY ARE REASSIGNING PEOPLE ON
OVERTIME TO BE OUT WITH US IT'S
NOT THAT THEY CAN PULL SOMEBODY
OFF PATROL AND ASSIGNED TO US
AND A AND A FULL TIME POSITION.
SO JUST LIKE WE ARE SPREAD THIN
AND WORKING PEOPLE -- ON
OVERTIME AND ON WEEKENDS IT
WEARS FOLKS OUT AT THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE NOT TO
DO SOMETHING SIMILAR WHERE THEY
ASSIGN PEOPLE ON OVERTIME TO TO
WORK.
ON THESE ON THESE PROGRAMS AND
THAT'S BEEN SOME OF THE PROBLEM
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT -- HIRING
IN FILLING SOME OF THESE
POSITIONS BECAUSE WE'RE SPREAD
SO THIN.
I THINK OUR AGENTS OR SOME OF
THE HARDEST WORKING INDIVIDUALS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE BUREAU
FIREARMS BECAUSE THEY'RE
AVERAGING ANYWHERE FROM FIFTY TO
A HUNDRED HOURS OF OVERTIME.
IN A MONTH THAT WORST PEOPLE OUT
AND SOME OTHER AGENTS ARE OUT
THERE IN THE CURRENT BUREAUS AT
THE RAN DON'T HAVE AN
INTERESTING COMING OVER WORKING
THAT HARD EVERY MONTH AND BEING
AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILIES AS MUCH
AS OUR FOLKS ARE.
THAT'S THE REALITY OF A LOT OF
THIS.
SO WE WE WILL -- HOLD IT OPEN --
AND I THINK ON YOUR THE
REFERENCE YOU MADE TO YOU KNOW
THE DIFFICULTY FOR THE SOMETIMES
FOR THE LOCAL AGENCIES TO ASSIST
IF THEY'RE UNDERFUNDED.
THAT'S ONE BENEFIT OF TRYING TO
PROVIDE THEM SOME RESOURCES TO
ASSIST -- BUT WHAT WE LOW COUPLE%
POINTS ONE IS VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF THE CLARIFICATION WHICH I
THINK WE ALL DO NEED TO ACCEPT
IS THAT.
WILL NEVER BE AT ZERO AND WHAT
IT IS A GOOD IDEA TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT WE THINK IS A REALISTIC
TARGET.
THAT WE'D WANT TO GET TO SO THAT
AS WE LOOK AT HOW TO ACHIEVE IT.
THEN WHAT'S THE APPROPRIATE THAT
WHAT'S THE WORKLOAD THAT WOULD
BE REQUIRED AND WHAT IS THEN THE
THE BEST -- ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES AND I THINK WHEN THE
AG WAS HERE THERE WAS HE
EXPLAINED A LOT OF REASONS WHY
IT'S PRETTY HARD TO ACHIEVE ZERO
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE AREN'T FOUND
THEY'RE NOT AT THE ADDRESS THAT
YOU HAVE VARIOUS THINGS LIKE
THAT.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT IS THE DO
YOU KNOW WHAT IS BOTH NOT ONLY
THE REALISTIC.
BUT RATHER WHAT IS THE NUMBER
THAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO GET
OUT SO WE CAN FEEL.
WHEN WE GET A REPORT THAT REAL
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE NO I
THINK THAT?
IN ALL THE HEARINGS WE'VE HAD SO
FAR I THINK THERE HAS BEEN AN A.
EXPRESSION AND RECOGNITION THAT
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE -- IT OF
COURSE WE'D LIKE IT TO BE BETTER.
SO.
YOU KNOW THAT'S PART OF THIS IS
WHAT WHAT KIND OF TARGETS ARE WE
REALLY HOPING TO ACHIEVE.
BUT THEN ADDITIONALLY D. AG
RAISED WHEN HE WAS HERE THAT.
PART OF THE WHEN YOU FILLED THE
POSITIONS THAT HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS
ENFORCEMENT.
THAT THEY OFTEN IN.
AS ANYONE WOULD IF THERE'S AN
OPENING IN A POSITION THAT.
GIVES THEM A A BETTER PAY OR A
DIFFERENT CLASSIFICATION THAT
THE MOVE ON AND THAT THIS IS
BEEN ONE OF THE ISSUES REGARDING
THE VACANCIES [inaudible]
NOW.
THE B. C. P. DOES NOT INCLUDE RE
CLASSIFICATION SO BUT THAT'S
CLEARLY SOMETHING THAT THE
DIVISION ITSELF THE DEPARTMENT
ITSELF CAN THINK ABOUT WHETHER
IS THE PROBLEM.
WITH.
FEELING THE POSITIONS A
CLASSIFICATION PROBLEM.
SO BUT THAT'S ON YOU KNOW RATHER
THAN US.
DICTATING THAT THAT'S ON THE
DEPARTMENT TO LOOK AT AND COME
BACK BUT THAT'S REALLY WHERE.
AT LEAST I WAS COMING FROM IN
TERMS OF TO TO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR NEW F. T. E..
WHEN WE'VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO EVEN
MAINTAIN THE F. T. E. THAT WE
HAVE GRANTED YOU?
pTO ACHIEVING THE OUTCOME WE
WANTED BUT WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN.
AND LOOK AT WHAT TWEAKS MAY BE
NECESSARY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THEN
JUST ON YOUR POINT OF
CLARIFICATION ON THE LAST ISSUE
REGARDING -- WITH THE BARGAINING
ISSUE AND THE DEPARTMENT IS
WORKING WITH CAL H. R. -- ON
THESE ISSUES THROUGH THE PROCESS
THAT IS ESTABLISHED SO JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT OKAY GREAT BUT
DID YOU IT YOU SEE MY POINT
THOUGH THAT WHILE.
WELL YOU ALL HAVE LIMITATIONS.
IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT
CLASSIFICATION LEVEL IS AND IT'S
A BARGAINING.
AND FIVE TOTALLY RESPECT THAT
ARE ADDING NEW F. T. E. STILL
DOESN'T SOLVE THAT.
CORRECTED AYE ANDERSON WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THIS OPEN CIVIL FOR
THE DISCUSSION BUT I THEIR NEW
HAVE TV'S WERE TO ADDRESS THE
NEW WORKLOAD THAT WAS -- SPELLED
OUT AND SOME OF THE LEGISLATION
YES YEAH I GUESS THAT WORK BUT
IF THEY DON'T GET FILLED.
WITH UNDERSTAFFED.
I'M SURE I CAN ADD AS WELL OF
THE A NUMBER OF VACANCIES WE
HAVE HELD AND NOT BEENABLE TO
FEEL RECENTLY BECAUSE THE
INSOLVENCY OF THE BUDGET.
IN OUR INTERNAL BUDGET WITH THE
BUREAU FIREARMS.
SO THIS THIS WHOLE PROCESS
HOPEFULLY HOPEFULLY HELPING TO
RESOLVE AT THOUGH I THINK SOME
OF THE PAST PERMANENT.
FTP WAS NOT DISTRUST BUT WILL
LOOK AT THE US CHECK US MY LOOK
AT IT [inaudible]
ART.
HOLDING IT THANK YOU THANK YOU --
LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY OF GO
AHEAD CENTER MORE LIKE.
FINISHERS THANK YOU I WAS GOING
TO SEE IF THERE IS PUBLIC
COMMENT YES.
IS THERE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
YES SOME THANK YOU.
SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS
COMMITTEE CAPULETS REPRESENTING
THE NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION FIRST OF ALL I THINK
I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED TODAY I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT DISCUSSION --
AND I DO WANT TO SAY SOMETHING I
HAVEN'T SAID BEFORE WHICH IS I
THINK THIS ATTORNEY GNERAL AND
THIS VERY COMPETENT STAFF IS
TRYING VERY HARD TO KIND OF
CLEAN THIS WHOLE PROCESS UP AND
DEAL WITH THE BACKLOG AND
THEY'RE DEALING IN A TRANSPARENT
WAY WHICH IS REFRESHING --
HAVING SAID THAT -- DOHAVE A
LOT OF CONCERNS AS WE ALWAYS
HAVE WITH THE USE OF THE DRUGS
ACCOUNT. FOR THE APP PROGRAM
AGAIN THESE ARE FOLKS THAT
AREN'T SUPPOSED TO BE IN
POSSESSION OF FIREARMS.
THE DEAL RECORD OF SALE IS A
BACKGROUND CHECK FOR LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS WHO ARE PURCHASING A
FIREARM SO IT FEELS TO US LIKE
THIS IS A GENERAL FUND.
THERE'S ALSO LEGISLATION PENDING
IN THE ASSEMBLY WITH MR BONTA TO
INCREASE THE DROZ ON A LAW%
ABIDING CITIZENS WHO ARE
PURCHASING A FIREARM TIP TO PAY.
FOR THE APP PROGRAM WE THINK
THAT'S KIND OF AN UPSIDE DOWN.
I DO AGREE WITH CENTER BELL THAT
I THINK THERE'S A A BROADER
CONVERSATION AND THERE'S A LOT
OF PROBLEMS HERE.
THAT THEY CAN'T JUST FIX BY.
THE PROCESS THERE IN IT FEELS TO
US LIKE THERE'S A JUDICIAL
PROCEEDING ISSUE THAT COULD
MAYBE BE ADDRESSED AND PUBLIC
POLICY AT SOME FUTURE DATE WHEN
SOMEONE LOSES OUR FIREARMS
RIGHTS IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S AT
THAT POINT THAT WE COULD MAKE A
DENT.
ON MAYBE THE BACKLOG NOT
INCREASING -- AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE WE WANT TO STAND IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU AND WORK ON
THIS BUT AGAIN WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE USE OF THE
DRUGS ACCOUNT.
THERE ARE LAWSUITS PENDING ON
THIS BECAUSE AGAIN THIS IS A A
BACKGROUND CHECK FOR LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE APPS AND THEN I
WILL OPEN FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE ITEMS THAT WE DID IS VOTE
ONLY.
IF THERE'S ANY. ONE HERE WHO
WANTED TO COMMENT ON ANY OF
THOSE ITEMS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU OKAY.
AND WE WILL GO TO OUR NEXT.
ISSUE WHICH IS
.
OKAY SO WE'LL NOW GO TO ISSUE.
THIRTEEN WHICH IS -- UNDER CDC
AREBUT ITS DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE REORGANIZATION
[inaudible]
THE SPEAKER [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND PRESENTING ON THAT ITEM WE
HAVE A CHECK SUPPLE WHO'S THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE.
AND CHRISTOPHER CAN WHO IS THE
ASSISTANT SECRETARY AT THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
AND THE REASON WE HAVE -- EIGHTY
PRESENTER FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES IS
BECAUSE THE ISSUE THAT WILL BE
HEARING.
IS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL -- TO
MOVE THE OUR DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE INTO THE
DIVISION THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY.
SO MR SUPPLE DID YOU WANT TO
BEGIN AND YOU ALL CAN INTRODUCE
REINTRODUCE YOURSELVES.
ADDITIONALLY AS YOU START.
OKAY -- MADAM CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU -- MY NAME IS CHUCK
SUPPLE AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
AND IT'S A PLEASURE AND HONOR TO
BE HERE TODAY -- TO TALK ABOUT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO MOVE
THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
INTO A NEW DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
AT CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY.
FEEL THIS IS A CRITICAL STEP ON
THE JOURNEY OF STRENGTHENING DJS
ABILITY TO FULFILL OUR VISION
AND MISSION.
AND UTILIZING SOME NEW KEY
STRATEGIES TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
A LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY -- THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH AUTHORITY THAT
VISION JUVENILE JUSTICE HAS BEEN --
ON A JOURNEY FOR QUITE SOME TIME
WITH REGARD TO BOTH HOME AND
SERVES AS WELL AS OUR APPROACH
TO SERVING THAT POPULATION BACK
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES -- AT
ITS HEIGHT -- SOME THIRTEEN
THOUSAND YOUTH WERE IN EIGHT
FACILITIES AND FIVE FIRE CAMPS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- TODAY
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY -- SEVEN
HUNDRED YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS
IN THREE FACILITIES AND ONE FIRE
CAMP -- AND THAT WAS THE RESULT
OF A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT FACTORS
BOTH IN TERMS OF A DECLINED
SIGNIFICANTLY AND JUVENILE --
JUVENILES INVOLVED IN -- THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM JUVENILE
ARRESTS AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF
POLICY CHANGES OVER THE YEARS --
THAT HAVE DIMINISH THE NUMBER OF
YOUTH COMING TO DJJ AND
REALIGNED THE POPULATION THAT
DOES COME TO DJJ.
AND ALONG THE LINES ALL ALONG
THAT JOURNEY OF COURSE WAS THE
FEDERAL LAWSUIT WHERE MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS WERE INVESTED -- IN
IMPROVING - THESERVICES
PROVIDED BY THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE -- IN
PRACTICALLY ALL QUARTERS -- OF
THE DIVISION FROM EDUCATION --
TO THE SAFETY AND WELFARE --
MENTAL HEALTH -- AND A NUMBER OF
OTHER AREAS.
AND WHERE WE ARE AT NOW -- 201-6
HAVING -- BEEN RELEASED FROM THE
FEDERAL LAWSUIT -- IT THE
JOURNEY IS NOT OVER IN TERMS OF
IMPROVING AND REFORMING -- THE
DIVISION TO BEST SERVE THE
POPULATION -- WHO WE ARE?
SET UP TO SERVE -- WHAT IS
HAPPENED OVER THE YEARS IS THAT
WE NOW HAVE OBVIOUSLY A MUCH
MUCH SMALLER PERCENTAGE OF THE
YOUTH WHO ARE INVOLVED IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM --
HOWEVER THAT POPULATION
REPRESENTS PERHAPS THE MOST
SERIOUSLY BEHAVIOR LEE AND
MENTALLY CHALLENGED USE THAT WE
ARE ENTRUSTED WITH.
AND MOVING FORWARD -- I SIXTY
THREE IS A AREAS THAT WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO BUILD UPON THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT AS WELL AS THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE.
THE FIRST IS TO SUSTAIN IN
ADVANCE THE GAME THE SISTINE AND
ADVANCE THE GAINS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE IN THE FEDERAL LAWSUIT.
IN IN PARTICULAR -- THIS IS IN
THE AREA THE INTEGRATED BEHAVIOR
TREATMENT MODEL WE NOW HAVE THE
MEANS TO BE ABLE TO ASSESS --
THE RISKS AND UNDERLYING FOR
MANAGING NEEDS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO COME TO US
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE --
TO PROVIDE THEM WITH EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMS TO REDUCE THAT
RISK TARGETED SPECIFICALLY -- TO
THEIR INDIVIDUAL CRIMINAL GENIC
NEEDS THE REASONS THAT THEY CAME
TO THE DJ DAVE IN THE FIRST
PLACE THAT.
NEEDS BEHIND THEIR DANGEROUS
BEHAVIOR THAT BROUGHT THEM TO
DJJ.
AND THE MEANS TO BE ABLE -- TO
PROVIDE THE PROPER CASE
MANAGEMENT AS WELL AS A
BEHAVIORAL MANAGEMENT SYSTEM TO
REINFORCE THE POSITIVE BEHAVIORS
AND SANCTIONS THANKS IN THE THE
NEGATIVE BEHAVIORS.
AND WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
SUSTAIN AN ADVANCE THOSE GAMES
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE FIDELITY
IN THE QUALITY THE DELIVERY OF
THOSE SERVICES BUT WE HAVE
EVERYTHING WE NEED IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO HELP THE YOUTH REDUCE
THE REST THAT THEY CAME TO DJJ.
FOUR AND SECONDLY WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO CONSULT CULTIVATE A
CULTURE A CULTURE THAT SUPPORTS
THE MISSION -- I REFER TO THIS
REALLY A A CULTURE OF SUCCESS
AND THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THIS IS
CHERYL IS ACHIEVED THROUGH A A
LAWSUIT BUT IT'S REALLY AN
ORGANIZATIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS TO TO CHANGE THE CULTURE.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE WORKED ON CONTINUALLY TO BE
ONE THAT IS SUPPORTIVE OF A
YOUTH SUCCESS AND AND WHOLLY
EMBRACES THAT AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIRD IS TO BUILD UP
THE STRENGTH BASS BASS AS I CALL
IT.
WE IN THE EVIDENCE BASED TOOLS
THAT I WAS TALKING ABOUT THAT WE
HAVE EVERYTHING WE NEED TO HELP
YOU TO BE ABLE TO LEARN IN A
SENSE HOW NOT TO FIGHT.
BUT THERE'S MUCH MORE TO THAT IN
HELPING TO USE RETURN SAFELY TO
THE COMMUNITY AND HAVE TO GIVE
THAT YOUNG MAN AND WOMAN A
REASON WHY NOT TO FIGHT AND
EMOTIONAL.
MOTIVATION AS TO WHY THEY WANT
TO BE ABLE TO USE THESE TOOLS
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WAS
NOT A LARGE PART OF THE FEDERAL
LAWSUIT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM TO BUILD
ON THEIR STRENGTHS -- VOCATIONAL
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMMING --
COMMUNITY -- PROGRAMS COMING IN --
MENTORS COMING IN TO BE ABLE TO
MOTIVATE INSPIRE AND AND SUPPORT
THEM -- IN PURSUING IT INITIALLY
AND MATCHING IN THE POSSIBILITY
OF A DIFFERENT IDENTITY THAN THE
ONES THAT THEY BELIEVED IN
THEMSELVES WALKING IN.
AND TO BE ABLE TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM TO NOT
JUST THINK ABOUT THE LIFE THAT
THEY WANT TO BEGIN LIVING WHEN
THEY LEAVE BUT TO BEGIN LIVING
THAT WHILE THEY ARE WITH US AND
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE -- HAVE
ASPIRATIONS AND ATTACHMENTS THE
CONTINUE ON INTO THE COMMUNITY
TO BE ABLE TOLIVE THAT LIFE
WHEN THEY LEAVE -- IT WHEN THEY
LEAVE DJJ AND WE WE BELIEVE VERY
STRONGLY -- THAT AT THIS
PARTICULAR POINT IN DJS DAY'S
JOURNEY OF REFORM AND GROWTH --
THAT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSAL TO
MOVE US OUT OF THE ADULT PRISON
SYSTEM INTO THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCY IS RIGHT ON TRACK
AND A MILESTONE THAT WILL BE
VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO FULFILL.
THOSE THREE TARGETS THAT I JUST
REFERRED TO AND I'LL LEAVE IT AT
THAT AND BECAUSE I'M SURE
THEY'LL BE QUESTIONS AND MORE
DISCUSSION THANK YOU.
THE MANAGER CENTERS -- ALSO SAID
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE EXCITED AT
THE AGENCY TO WELCOME CHUCK AND
HIS TEAM -- I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO BE A GREAT FIT TO HELP
THEM IMPROVE ON THE PROGRESS
THEY'VE MADE THROUGH THE FOR A
LAWSUIT AND HE TO BUILD THAT
THERAPEUTIC REHABILITATED
MISSION OF THE DEPARTMENT THE
NEW DEPARTMENT -- YOU KNOW OUR
AGENCY IS FOCUSED ON THE PERSON
IT'S FOCUSED ON REINTEGRATION
AND THAT'S FOR THE DEPARTMENT
JUVENILE JUSTICE IS HEADING IN
THE DEPARTMENT.
SO WITH THAT WE THINK WERE A YOU
CAN DECISION SUPPORT THEM IN
THAT AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HELPING FOSTER THAT CULTURE
CHANGE AS WELL AS HELPING TO
CONNECT THEM TO LOCALS.
IN CITY IN OUR DIVERSE
DEPARTMENTS TO HELP WITH
INTEGRATION THANK YOU.
AND WE DID NOT BRING THE CHOIR
BUT IT WAS.
I KNOW THAT ARE AT LEAST HAVE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AND I
KNOW THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
PUBLIC COMMENT AND CERTAINLY ON
MY COLLEAGUES IF THEY HAVE.
BUT I WANT TO HEAR FROM THE LA --
FIRST AND THEN WE'LL SEE IF THE
PART IN FINANCE WANTS
[inaudible]
TO ADD.
MORNING LUCAS MORROW WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE IN
CONCERT IN THIS PROPOSAL WE
IDENTIFIED A FEW QUESTIONS FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION.
THE FIRST IS WHETHER DJ NEEDS TO
BE REORGANIZED TO IMPROVE
REHABILITATION.
WILL NOTE THAT THE MOST RECENT
DATA ON RECIDIVISM COMES FROM
THE COURT THAT WAS RELEASED IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE FELLOW
LAWSUIT DID NOT END UNTIL.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND AS A
RESULT IT'S UNCLEAR HOW THE DJ
IS CURRENTLY PERFORMING AT
REHABILITATING YOUTH -- OUR NEXT
QUESTION IS WHAT WHAT ARE THE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS OF THE
PROPOSED REORGANIZATION.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
IDENTIFIED.
MULTIPLE OUTCOMES AND TARGET TO
THEY WOULD HOPE TO ACHIEVE WITH
THIS REORGANIZATION HOWEVER IT'S
NOT CLEAR OR HOW THIS WE
ORGANIZATION WOULD ACCOMPLISH
THESE.
OUTCOMES OR WHY THEY CANNOT BE
PERFORMED WITHIN THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE UNDERSEA DC ARE.
OUR NEXT QUESTION IS WHAT ARE
THE POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES OF
THE REORGANIZATION.
WITHOUT UNDER KNOWING HOW
THEY'LL OPERATIONALIZE THESE.
THIS REORGANIZATION AND HOW THEY
WILL ACCOMPLISH THESE OUTCOMES
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT IT WOULD
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH.
THEY COULD ALSO INCREASED COSTS --
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE SOME
SERVICES A COMPANY SHARED
BETWEEN D. J. J. M. C. C. R.
THESE ARE POTENTIALLY TO BE
DUPLICATED ON THE REALIZATION.
IN ADDITION THERE COULD BE OTHER
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SUCH AS
COMPLICATING.
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE NEW
DEPARTMENT AND CDC ARE.
OUR NEXT QUESTION IS ALL THE
ALTERNATIVE ORGANIZATIONAL
STRUCTURES THAT COULD BE --
LOOKED AT WE LOOKED AT HOW OTHER
STATES HAVE ORGANIZED OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEMS AND
HAVE IDENTIFIED THAT WHILE MANY
SIX TO HAVE THEIR JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEMS UNDER HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY THREE
ABOUT HALF THE STATE TO THAT
STRUCTURE HAVE MOVED AWAY FROM
THAT MODEL TO A DIFFERENT MODEL --
MOST COMMONLY AUTO TO BECOME AN
INDEPENDENT DEPARTMENT THAT'S
NOT UNDER AN AGENCY OR PUT IT
INTO AN AGENCY THAT SPECIFICALLY.
FOR FOCUSED ON CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES.
WE ALSO CONSIDER WHETHER OR NOT
IT WOULD MAKE SENSE TO FULLY WE
ALIGN.
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
COUNTIES CURRENTLY ABOUT 30% OF
INCARCERATED YOUTH ARE HELD IN
DJJ WITH THE REMAINDER AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL.
AND BOTH COUNTY FACILITIES AND
STATE FACILITIES ARE AT ABOUT
ONE THIRD OF THE TOTAL CAPACITY.
SO IT COULD POTENTIALLY MAKE
SENSE FROM A PHYSICAL STANDPOINT
TO REORGANIZE THE WE LINE TO THE
GYM -- COUNTIES AND ALSO IT
COULD POTENTIALLY BRING THOSE
HE'S CLOSER TO THE SUPPORT
STRUCTURE SUCH AS FAMILIES.
ANOTHER OPTION WOULD BE TO KEEP
DJ WITH N. C. C. R. AND FOCUS ON
ELIMINATING ANY BARRIERS IF THEY
ARE IDENTIFIED TO REHABILITATION
WITHIN CDC ARE FACED WITH
POTENTIALLY ALSO HAVE A BENEFIT
TO THE ADULT SYSTEM.
WHICH HOUSES A HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS IN
PRISON AND ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE ON FOR COMPETITIVE AT
ABOUT 700-100-0700 PEOPLE IN.
THE DJJ [inaudible]
FINALLY WE ASKED WHETHER THIS IS
AN APPROPRIATE USE OF TRAILER
BILL LEGISLATION.
THE WE KNOW THAT THE PREVIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE GONE TO AN
EXECUTIVE BRANCH REALIZATION
PROCESS ESTABLISHED IN STATUTE.
SINCE THE TIME OF THIS ANALYSIS
DJ HAS PUT FORWARD A TRAILER
BILL AND WE HAVE ALSO SENT
QUESTIONS THE MINISTRATION TO
GET ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ABOUT
THESE CHANGES.
NOTABLY WHAT PERSONAL
ADJUSTMENTS IN RESOURCES WILL BE
NECESSARY TO CARRY OUT THE
TRAILER BILL.
WHAT A NEW TRAINING PROGRAM THAT
INCLUDING THE LANGUAGE WOULDN'T
TAIL AND WHETHER TO APPLY TO ALL
PERSONNEL OR JUST NEW PERSONAL --
WHY THE TRAILER BILL NEEDS
LANGUAGE TO ACCEPT THE NEW
DEPARTMENT FROM THE REGULATORY
PROCESS SEES?
AS WELL AS A NEW PROGRAM. TWO
WAY THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
BERMAN FINANCE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ERIN
ANDREWS WITH PART IN FINANCE --
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT WE ARE
STRONG.
SKILL.
THAT ALLERGIES.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL CERTAINLY AGREE WITH
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MISTER
SUPPLE -- AND HIS VISION FOR
WHERE THE SYSTEM SHOULD BE
HEADING -- I ALSO AGREE WITH
COMMENTS MADE BY MISTER COUNT
THAT THE HHSAA IS THE RIGHT
PLACE FOR US FOR DJ TO BE
LOCATED.
IN ORDER -- TO CONTINUE MAKING
IMPROVEMENTS AND REHABILITATION --
AND BEYOND THAT I THINK THE THE
THEY HAVE WELL SUMMARIZE THE THE
REASONS WHY WE'RE DOING THIS IN
SEPARATE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE [inaudible]
CERTAINLY -- THANK YOU.
SO. FIVE NINE AM I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS IN A COUPLE COMMENTS.
MY FIRST COMMENT IS.
I APPRECIATE THE LA OWES RAISING
THOSE ISSUES -- BECAUSE IT IS
COMPLETELY LEGITIMATE FOR US.
TO HAVE SOME LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE
THAT THIS MOVE [inaudible]
WILL [inaudible]
IMPROVE REHABILITATION.
BECAUSE IT WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT
THAT'S OUR PRIMARY OBJECTIVE AND
IF WE LOOK.
MEAN SOME SOME OF THE CHANGES
WE'VE MADE OBVIOUSLY OVERTIME
WERE DUE TO LAWSUITS BUT IF WE
LOOK AT OUR TRAJECTORY AND HOW
WE ARE DEALING WITH ALL OF OUR
INCARCERATED POPULATION WHETHER
YOUTH OR ADULTS [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
OVER A CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME
BEEN MOVING MUCH MORE TOWARDS.
WELL FIRST AND FOREMOST
ACCEPTING THAT THE PEOPLE WE
HOLD WILL RETURN TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND SO IF PUBLIC
SAFETY IS OUR FIRST AND FOREMOST
OBJECTIVE.
WHAT DO WE DO WHILE THEY ARE IN
OUR -- WELL AT THE POINT THAT
DURING THE TIME.
THAT WE HOLD HIM IN CUSTODY.
WHAT IS OUR ROLE TO HELP INSURE
THAT WHEN THEY ARE RETURNED HOME?
THAT WE HAVE MAXIMIZED THE
OBJECTIVE OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND I THINK THAT -- THE
LEGISLATURE OVER TIME HAS COME
TO EMBRACE THAT [inaudible]
THAT.
THAT IN THE PAST.
DEAR THE WHAT I MIGHT CALL THE
MORE PUNITIVE MODEL WELL
CERTAINLY INCARCERATION WILL
REMAIN TO BE SOME LEVEL OF AT
BEING PUNITIVE BECAUSE IT IS.
WITHDRAWING SOMEONE'S FREEDOM.
BUT I THINK THAT THERE'S BEEN A
RECOGNITION THAT.
IF WE ACCEPT AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THE VAST MAJORITY WILL BE
RETURNING TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND OUR FIRST AND FOREMOST
OBJECTIVE IS A STATE IS PUBLIC
SAFETY THEN WE THAT PUNISHMENT
ALONE WOULD NOT BE ADEQUATE TO
ASSURE PUBLIC SAFETY AND THAT WE
HAVE.
TO UTILIZE THE TIME THAT WE ARE
HOLDING PEOPLE IN CUSTODY IN A
WAY TO EQUIP THEM. TO AND MAKE
AND HELP US FEEL ASSURED THAT
WHEN THEY RETURN THAT OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY IS BEING -- INSURED ALSO.
SO IN WE KNOW THAT.
JUVENILES ARE VERY UNIQUE
POPULATION AND OF COURSE IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS ESPECIALES.
NINETY SIX SEVEN THE AMOUNT OF
RESEARCH THAT IS SHOWN THE BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
WELL WE ALWAYS HAD QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE ABILITY OF JUVENILES
TO EXHIBIT THE SAME JUDGMENT AS
ADULTS.
I THINK WE MAY NOT HAVE
UNDERSTOOD SO FULLY HOW MUCH
THEY REALLY ARE NOT ADULTS THAT
REALLY THESE A WHOLE LOT OF
CAPACITIES. FOR DECISIONS FOR
RESPONSIBLE BEHAVIOR AND SUCH
ARE REALLY NOT DEVELOPED.
UNTIL A AN AGE PASSED
[inaudible]
ADOLESCENCE.
SO I THINK ALL OF THOSE THINGS
COME INTO PLAY IN THIS NOW.
I AM GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS MOVE.
BECAUSE I FEEL THAT PART OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE IS A
CULTURE CHANGE [inaudible]
AND BY.
WITH THIS UNIQUE POPULATION OF
JUVENILES [inaudible]
IF WE CONTINUE WITHIN A CULTURE
OF A MORE PUNITIVE CULTURE THAT
ARE CDC ARE IS IT.
YOU KNOW WHILE WE'RE IN THE
MIDST OF SOME TRANSITION IS
STILL ESSENTIALLY THAT'S ITS
FOCUS.
THAT TE AGENCY OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AT LEAST
COMMUNICATE THAT WITH THIS
POPULATION WE ARE REALLY MOVING
TO AN AGENCY.
ACHIEVE THAT AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE AT LEAST FOR SOME OF US
THOSE OF US WHO ARE.
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS WANT TO
BE ASSURED THAT THIS IS NOT JUST
A AGENCY CHANGE AND THAT IN FACT
WE ARE PREPARED AND EQUIPPED. TO
DO THE TYPE OF CULTURE CHANGE SO
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE HE
OUTCOMES THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS IDENTIFIED.
BUT MY QUESTION IS WHAT KIND OF
SUCCESS MARKERS ARE WE UTILIZING
TO GUIDE THISTRANSITION.
AND ARE THERE STATES THAT WE
MIGHT LOOK TO AS MODELS THAT YOU
YOU MAY BE LOOKING AT AS A MODEL.
IF YOU COULD ANSWER THAT
WHICHEVER VIEW.
SURE I THINK THAT.
REALLY WITHIN BOTH THE JUVENILE
AS WELL AS ADULTS SYSTEMS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY THERE ARE
EXAMPLES THAT WE'VE LOOKED AT
AND ARE PULLING FROM.
I WANTED TO SHARE WITH REGARD TO
THE THE CULTURE PIECE IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THERE'S
ACTUALLY SPECIFIC.
LANGUAGE WITH REGARD TO MISSION --
AND THE MISSION THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION
IS THE YOUTH.
WHO HAVE HURT PEOPLE?
AND HAD BEEN HURT THEMSELVES.
RETURN SAFELY TO THE COMMUNITY
AND BECOME RESPONSIBLE AND
SUCCESSFUL ADULTS.
I THINK THAT SPEAKS ON ON A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT LEVELS IN
TERMS OF THE ELEMENTS THAT WE'VE
PULLED FROM.
OTHER MODELS AS WELL AS OUR OWN
EXPERIENCE.
WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD HERE ONE
JUST.
RIGHT OFF THE BAT SAYING THAT
THE YOUTH WHO COME TO US.
ALL OF THEM HAVE HURT SOMEBODY.
AND THAT'S THE REASON IS THAT
THEY ARE [inaudible]
WITH US.
AND THAT THERE'S A VICTIM
ASSOCIATED WITH EVERYBODY WHO IS
COMING [inaudible]
TO DJJ.
AND ALONG WITH THAT THE WE NEED
TO ACCEPT THE FACT THAT THAT IS
OUR ROLE REGARDLESS OF THE FACT
THAT THIS YOUNG PERSON HIS HURT
SOMEBODY OUR ROLE IS TO HELP
THEM.
IT'S NOT TO SEEK RETRIBUTION
PUNISHMENT.
BUT IT IS TO HELP THEM AND
THAT'S A FUNDAMENTAL VALUE. FOR
THE ORGANIZATION THAT EVERYBODY
IN THE ORGANIZATION NEEDS TO
EXCEPT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
FULFILL THAT MISSION.
AND THAT THEY FOR THEMSELVES.
THEY HAVE BEEN HURT THEMSELVES
AND THAT SPEAKS TO THE TRAUMAIS
SPEAKS TO THIS LIFE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND EXPERIENCES.
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
THAT CONTRIBUTED AND PLAYED A
ROLE AND WE'RE A PART OF
ALTERNATELY THEM COMING TO DJJ.
IN THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT AND TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DELIVER THE
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE THE
SERVICES TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS.
MANY OF THOSE UNDERLYING
CIRCUMSTANCES THE CONTRIBUTED
ALL THE WAY TO THE BEHAVIORS
THAT BROUGHT THEM TO DJJ.
AND THEN TO RETURN SAFELY TO THE
COMMUNITY.
PRACTICALLY EVERYBODY IN DJJ.
IS GOING TO RETURN TO THE
COMMUNITY EITHER THE DATE AGES
TWENTY THREE OR TWENTY FIVE AND
THAT OUR JOB EVERY INTERACTION
EVERY SERVICE THAT WE PROVIDE
THAT WE HAVE FOR THAT YOU HE'S
GOT TO BE GEARED TOWARDS HELPING
THEM TO BE ABLE TO CHANGE.
AND THAT YOU ARE NOT YEAH WE ARE
NOT BEING GENUINE IN TERMS OF
OUR FUNDAMENTAL MISSION.
OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
IF WE ARE NOT DOING EVERYTHING
WE POSSIBLY CAN TO HELP THANK
YOUNG PERSON CHANGE BECAUSE THEY
WILL BE RETURNING TO THE
COMMUNITY AND POSSIBLY LIVING.
YOU KNOW IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD AND
WE WANT TO FEEL GOOD ABOUT WHAT
WE WERE ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE TO
SUPPORTING THE DEVELOPMENT
POSITIVELY OF THAT YOUNG PERSON
UPON THEIR RETURN.
END.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THERE IS NOT
ENOUGH THAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO
NO HARM -- THEY NEED TO GO OUT
AND BECOME RESPONSIBLE
SUCCESSFUL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY IN THE VISION
STATEMENT THAT'S IN THERE WE
WANT TO SEE THEM IS THRIVING AND
ENGAGE MEMBERS THE COMMUNITY AND
THAT'S PART OF THE COMMUNITY
RESTORATION PIECE THAT'S
ASSOCIATED WITH -- THE NAME
CHANGE AS WELL.
AND SO TO BE ABLE TO GET A
FULFILL THAT MISSION THERE'S
SEVERAL STRATEGIES THAT WE HAVE
PULLED FROM -- BOTH OUR OWN
EXPERIENCE AS WELL AS OTHER
STATE AND AND EVEN
INTERNATIONALLY FUNDAMENTALLY WE
NEED TO BUILD STRONG SAFE AND
CARING COMMUNITIES WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
AND THAT WE NEED TO GET ENGAGED
ALL MEMBERS INCLUDING THE STAFF
USE FAMILIES VOLUNTEERS VISITORS
IN FULFILLING THIS MISSION.
THE IDEA IS KIND OF BORROWED
FROM NORWAY KIND OF BORROWED
FROM GERMANY THE IDEA OF THE
PRINCIPLE OF NORMALCY.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
REMOVE SOMEBODY FROM SOCIETY
BECAUSE IT'S NOT SAFE FOR THEM
TO BE IN SOCIETY YOU NEED TO
CREATE.
WITHIN YOUR INCARCERATED SETTING.
A A NORMAL SOCIETY FOR THEM TO
LEARN HOW TO OPERATE SAFELY
WITHIN SOCIETY AND SO WHAT WE'RE
ATTEMPTING TO DO AND RECOGNIZE
THE NEED TO DO IS TO BUILD SAY
STRONG CARING COMMUNITIES WITHIN
OUR FACILITIES.
THAT A YOUNG PERSON CAN LEARN
HOW TO BE ABLE TO OPERATE SAFELY
WITHIN A COMMUNITY THOSE ARE THE
SKILLS THEY'RE GONNA NEED WHEN
THEY RETURN.
TO COMMUNITY BEYOND OUR WALLS
AND THAT IT'S NOT JUST A MATTER
OF THE STAFF'S JOB BE THE SOLELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR HELPING TO
CHANGE THIS YOUNG PERSON THAT
IT'S GONNA TAKE A COMMUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT AND WE SEE
THAT COMMUNITY IN DJJ.
AS BEING THE STAFF EVERY SINGLE
STAFF MEMBER YOUTH THE FAMILIES
THE VOLUNTEERS AND THE VISITORS
AND IN THE FUTURE VISITORS
COMING TO US. TO OUR FACILITIES
WE WANT TO SEEAND HOLD UP THE
EXPECTATION THAT THEY WILL BE
ENGAGED IN HELPING US FULFILL
THAT MISSION I KNOW SENATOR BILL
WHEN YOU WERE OUT YOU ARE
ACTIVELY LOOKING AT OUR COMPUTER
PROGRAMMING ASKING ABOUT HOW YOU
COULD HELP -- TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THAT PROGRAM AND THAT'S
THE TYPE OF INVOLVEMENT THAT WE
WANT EVERYBODY TO HELP SHARE THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WITH REGARD
TO THE YOUTH IN DJJ ENSURE THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR FOR FILLING
THAT MISSION.
THE SECOND PART OF THE STRATEGY
IS TO DEVELOP A FULLY PREPARED
AND CONTINUALLY SUPPORT STAFF
THAT.
IS HEALTHY EDUCATED AND TRAINED
TO FULFILL THEIR THEIR UNIQUE
ROLE IN FOR THEIR UNIQUE AND
VITAL ROLES TO FULFIL FAT.
THAT MISSION AND A BIG PART OF
THIS TRANSITION IN AN INITIAL --
ACTIVITY OF THAT IS TO BUILD A
TRAINING AND DEVELOPMENT CENTER
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO TRAIN BOTH
ARE INCOMING STAFF AS WELL AS ON
ONGOING BASIS STAFF.
VOLUNTEERS FAMILIES ON HOW TO BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH THE YOUTH AND
HOW TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
SERVICES IN THE INTERVENTIONS
THAT WE HAVE THERE ARE SO THAT
EVERYBODY IS PART OF THAT
MISSION FORCE SO TO SPEAK TO BE
ABLE TO DELIVER ON THAT MISSION.
AND WE WANT TO OFFER TREATMENT
TO HELP YOU FEEL FROM PAST
EXPERIENCES AND CHANGE THEIR
THINKING BELIEVES.
THELEAD TO HURTING THEMSELVES
AND OTHERS WE HAVE AS I
MENTIONED AS A RESULT OF FERAL --
A NUMBER OF INTERVENTIONS THEIR
EVIDENCE BASED TO HELP USE BE
ABLE TO CHANGE THEIR THINKING
SOCIAL COGNITIVE --
INTERVENTIONS -- AS WELL AS THE
INTERVENTIONS RELATED TO
ADDRESSING UP PAST TRAUMAS AND
WE WANT TO BUILD UP ON THAT AS
WELL.
AND ALSO TO CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR YOU TO UNDERSTAND RESTORE
THE HARMS THAT THE THAT THEIR
ACTIONS COST AND THAT'S PART OF
THE DEVELOPING THERAPEUTIC
COMMUNITIES WITHIN DJ JACK.
PART OF THE SKILLS YOU LEARN IS
THE BEHAVIORS THAT BROKE
ROCKETED DJJ AS WELL AS ONGOING
BEHAVIORS IN THE IN THE FACILITY.
THAT IS NOT A MATTER OF JUST YOU
KNOW GETTING CAUGHT AND TAKING A
SANCTION IT'S UNDERSTANDING THE
HARMS ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE PRE
BEHAVIORS HOW TO REPAIR THE HARM
TO THE COMMUNITY.
THAT'S FUNDAMENTALLY A SKILL
THAT YOU WANT THEM TO CARRY WITH
THEM BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY SO
THAT THEY LEARN HOW TO BE ACTIVE
ENGAGE MEMBERS AND TO UNDERSTAND
ACTIONS THAT CREATE HARMON HOW
TO REPAIR THE SOMETHING WE ALL
NEED TO THINK ABOUT.
ON AN ONGOING BASIS AS AS
RESPONSIBLE COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
AND THEN TO PROVIDE EDUCATION
TRAINING AND LIFE XPERIENCES
FOR YOU TO IMAGINE A SPIRE AND
BUILD A PATHWAY TO A SUCCESSFUL
LIFE.
I KNOW BIRD SINGER SAID IN IN
HER HER BOOK BURNING DOWN THE
HOUSE THAT.
YOU KNOW A FUNDAMENTAL NEED A
YOUNG PERSON IS FOR ATTACHMENT
AN ASPIRATION AND WE NEED TO
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUTH
IN DJJ TO THINK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY MIGHT LIKE TO
DO A NEW FUTURE RIENTATION AND
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM
LIKE A COATING PROGRAM AND WHAT
HAVE YOU. TO NOT JUST THAT'S
WHAT I'M GONNA DO WHAT I GET OUT
BUT THEY START DOING IT AND
PRACTICING WEARING THAT NEW SET
OF CLOTHES WHILE THEY ARE WITH
US.
AND FINALLY WE WANT BRING PEOPLE
WITH RESOURCES RELATIONSHIPS
EXPERTISE AND PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE LIVED EXPERIENCE INTO
THE DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
THE CAN INSPIRE AND MOTIVATE
YOUTH AND TO BUILD A CARING
COMMUNITY THAT PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITIES AND SUPPORT FOR
THEIR RE ENTRY AN HONORABLE
DISCHARGE.
IN CLOSE PARTNERSHIP WITH --
PROBATION AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT MANY OF A
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS PARTNER
WITH.
AND IDENTIFY NEW PARTNERS BRING
THEM IN EARLY CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO BEGIN TO TO
TO LEARN HOW TO CODE TO
PARTICIPATE IN A LOW IN A IN A
CONSERVATION CORPS WHILE THEY'RE
WITH US INTO HAVE THAT
TRANSITION DIRECTLY INTO
OPPORTUNITY SEAMLESSLY IN THE
COMMUNITY.
OTHER WORDS THERE START TO LIVE
THEIR IFE WITH US IN THE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE IN PLACE FOR
THEM TO CONTINUE TO LIVE THAT
LIFE WHEN THE RE RETURNED TO THE
COMMUNITY.
AND ALSO CREDIBLE MESSENGER
MENTORING IS A BIG PART OF IT AS
WELL NO BETTER INDIVIDUALS TO
COME INTO OUR FACILITIES INSPIRE
AND MOTIVATE OUR YOUTH IN
INDIVIDUALS THEMSELVES WHO HAVE
BEEN -- IN THEIR SHOES HAVE SAT
IN THEIR SEATS AND BEEN ABLE TO
DO WHAT IT IS WE'RE ASKING THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE TO DO.
AN INDIVIDUALS THEMSELVES WHO
AND I SAID HAVE BEEN -- HAVE
HAVE LIVED X. SUCH EXPERIENCES
AND THE AMERICORPS PROGRAM THAT
WAS PART OF THE BUDGET AS WELL --
TO ESTABLISH -- CADRE IF YOU
WILL OF INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
BEEN -- A PART OF THE SYSTEM MY
BROTHER IN JUVENILE SIDE OR ON
THE ADULT SIDE HELPING YOUNG
PEOPLE TO NAVIGATE BOTH FIVE
THROUGH THE FACILITY AS WELL AS
MOST IMPORTANTLY WHEN THEY
RETURNED TO THE COMMUNITY.
HOW TO BE ABLE TO LINK TO
RESOURCES HOW TO BE ABLE TO HIT
THOSE CRITICAL MARKERS LIKE --
AND PROGRESS EMPLOYMENT
pADULTS IN THEIR LIFE BEING ABLE
TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF THEIR FAMILY
BEAN ENGAGE IN THE COMMUNITY.
IN ORDER FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
THEN APPLY FOR AND ACHIEVE AN
HONORABLE DISCHARGE THESE ARE
ALL PIECES THAT HAVE BEEN
BORROWED FROM OTHER -- EXAMPLES --
BOTH -- IN THE IN OTHER STATES
AND AND INTERNATIONALLY THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO INCORPORATE INTO
THIS MODEL THAT WE'RE GONNA
BETTER BE ABLE TO FULFILL THAT
THAT MISSION AND ACHIEVE BETTER
OUTCOMES OF HELPING YOU THREE
TURN.
BECOME RESPONSIBLE ENGAGE
MEMBERS THE COMMUNITY UPON THEIR
RETURN.
THANK YOU.
THE I APPRECIATE THE THAT MORE --
DETAILED EXPLANATION OF SOME OF
THE SPECIFICS THAT -- SOME OF
THE COMPONENTS THE TRAILER BILL
SOME OF THE SPECIFICS YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE AND AND THEN
THE REITERATION OF THE
OBJECTIVES AND HOW THEY'RE
CONNECTED TO DIFFERENT ITEMS OF
THE TRAILER BILL.
NOW I NOTE THAT THE TRAILER BILL.
THAT IF WE MOVE ON THIS THIS IS
A A BIG THE SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
IT'S COMPLICATED.
BUT I WONDER -- WHEN I LOOK AT
THE TRAILER BILL?
WHILE BUDGET ACTIONS GOING TO
PLACE IN GENERAL ON JULY ONE OF
NINETEEN THINGS LIKE THE NAME
CHANGE IN THIS CASE YOU DON'T
PROPOSED UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY AND THERE'S A
COUPLE OF OTHER.
WELL SO FIRST I WAS THINKING.
IF WE PROCEED WITH THIS.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE OBJECTIVES IS
THIS CULTURE CHANGE IT SEEMS TO
ME WE'D WANT TO WHY WOULD WE NOT
WANT TO CHANGE THE NAME RIGHT
AWAY WHY WOULDN'T WE HAVE THE
NAME CHANGE GOING TO AFFECT.
ON JULY.
ONE THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS.
GIVEN OUT WERE -- EVEN MORE
DIVERSE PART OF THE TRAILER BILL
AS YOU'RE GOING TO DEVELOP
TRAINING. FOR THE EXISTING STAFF
AND CLEARLY YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE -- MUCH OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE ISN'T GOING TO
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT BECAUSE YOU'RE
DOING.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE CREATING A
TRAINING COMPONENT AND AND THE
STAFF HAVE TO BE TRAINED TO THIS
NEW MISSION AND OBJECTIVE IN
SUCH.
SEOUL THE OTHER SIDE TO DATE
CHANGE.
WHAT -- MECHANISMS DO YOU HAVE
THAT WILL HELP US ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
GIVEN THE PACE OF THIS
TRANSITION.
AND HAVE YOU CONSIDERED.
A STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY GROUP SAY
OF OF EXPERTS IN.
IN THIS NEW MISSION DAY THAT WE
ARE IF WE ADOPT DISEMBARKING ON
I KNOW THAT THE SECRETARY VALLEY
AS WELL AS MYSELF -- ARE VERY
MUCH COMMITTED -- TO ONGOING
COMMUNICATION WITH AN
INVOLVEMENT OF CRITICAL
STAKEHOLDERS EXPERT TO THE LIKE --
IN THIS PROCESS -- AND
ABSOLUTELY WOULD BE SEEKING
THEIR ADVICE YOU KNOW THROUGHOUT --
THIS INITIAL STAGE WHICH IS --
SOME OF ITS BIG WITH REGARD TO
THE TRAINING -- IT PIECE OF IT
AS WELL A LOT OF IT IS.
RATHER MUNDANE IN TERMS OF BEING
ABLE TO DO ALL THE SIGNIFICANT
TASK OF JUST THE MOVING IT FROM
CDC ARE AND PUTTING AND
ESTABLISHING THE SYSTEMS OVER IN --
INTO THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
IN OBVIOUSLY OPEN TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE -- YOU KNOW REGULARLY
INFORMED.
THE GOOD CRITICAL STATE COLORS
OBVIOUSLY IN TERMS OF OF THE
PROGRESS AS WE MOVE ALONG
[inaudible]
SO.
BUT AND YOU HAVE AN ANTICIPATED
A FORMAL.
SOME OTHER WORDS THAT'S AN
INFORMAL STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
WHAT ABOUT THE NAME CHANGE --
WELL WE'RE CERTAINLY GOING TO
CONTINUE TO ACT AS IF UNTIL
OFFICIALLY -- IT IS AN HADN'T
ACTUALLY I THINK CONTEMPLATED
THE TIMING O THE THE NAME
CHANGED BEYOND JUST SORT OF THE
THE TRAJECTORY OF OF WHEN IT
COULD HAPPEN BUT IF THAT'S
SOMETHING WE COULD CONSIDER OKAY.
I I HAVE ANOTHER ISSUE ON BRING
A BUT I'M GONNA LEAVE IT AND AND
ASK MY COLLEAGUES IF THEY HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THEY'RE MORE LIKE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I I'M NEW TO THIS COMMITTEE
SOUGHT ALLOW ME TO HAVE SOME
VERY.
BASIC QUESTIONS BUT THE FIRST
VISIT IN IN OUR MATERIAL WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE.
AN EXECUTIVE SUMMARY OR A VISION
STATEMENT -- SO FOR ME IS THAT
SOMEONE CAN A NEW TO THIS
COMMITTEE IT WILL BE NICE TO SAY
WE ARE.
MAKING THE FOLLOWING.
RE ORGANIZATIONAL EFFORT TO
ACHIEVE THE FOLLOWING OUTCOMES.
TO BENEFIT FROM THE FOLLOWING
EFFICIENCIES ARE PROGRAM CHANGES.
AND YOU KNOW LIKE A LIKE A
SEVENTY FIVE WORDS.
ADDING CAPS LATER EVERYTHING
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH.
WHERE WOULD I FIND THAT WERE
COULD YOU GIVE IT TO ME AND
SEVENTY FIVE WORDS OR LESS WELL
I THINK THAT THE I MEAN ALL WE
WHAT WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO DO IS
TO REDUCE THE RISKS AND THE
UNDERLYING WHAT THEY CALL
COMMITTEE JETTING NEEDS
ASSOCIATED WITH?
A YOUNG PERSON'S BEHAVIOUR DAYS
BEHAVIOR THAT BROUGHT THEM TO
DJJ AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS BUILD UP UPON
THEIR STRENGTHS -- BUILD UP ON
THE PROTECTIVE FACTORS THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO REDUCE THOSE REST
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
THE LOWERED REST WHEN THEY
RETURNED TO THE COMMUNITY.
AND THAT ALL THE ONLY WHEN THEY
RETURNED TO THE COMMUNITY THAT
THEY'RE GOING -- TO BECOME
OBVIOUSLY REDUCE RECIDIVISM THAT
THEY'RE GONNA DESIST FROM THE
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR BUT THEY'RE
ALSO GOING TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO HAD POSITIVE
OUTCOMES RELATED.
TO A SUCCESSFUL LIFE EDUCATION
EMPLOYMENT COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND THE LIKE BUT YOU'RE ALREADY
DOING THAT.
CERTAINLY THAT'S WHAT WERE
ABSOLUTELY WORKING TOWARD DOING
IT DOWN SO HEALTHY HOWEVER THE A
NUMBER OF THOSE SERVICES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BOTH IN
TERMS OF REDUCING THOSE RISKS
THAT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES --
AND THE LIKE THE THE THE
EXPERTISE OF THE SERVICES THE
DEPARTMENTS AND THE LIKE.
THAT -- THAT THAT IS THEIR
DOMAIN SO TO SPEAK YOU KNOW
THEIR EXPERTISE ARE SITUATED
WITHIN HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AND SO BY BEING A PART OF THAT
DEPARTMENT WE WILL BE CLOSER TO
WORKING FAR MORE COLLABORATIVELY
WITH THE VERY AGENCIES
DEPARTMENTS SERVICES THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO THE POPULATION.
THAT WE READ THAT WE RECEIVE AND
AND ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR SERVING
IN ADDITION WITH REGARD TO THE
TRANSITION A NUMBER OF THOSE
SERVICES -- SUPPORTS AND AND
RESOURCES AND THE LIKE ARE ALSO
SITUATED WITHIN THAT APARTMENT
IN BEING ABLE TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH THEM EARLIER ON TO BE ABLE
TO PLAN FOR THAT TRANSITION SO
THAT THAT SUPPORT WILL BE OUT
THERE WHEN THE RETURN.
IS ANOTHER CRITICAL. TWENTY
WORDS SORRY.
YOU A FACTUAL SOONER WE CAN SEND
YOU A NEW.
ONE IT JUST YOU KNOW HOW HOW DO
WE JUST LIKE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
SAY THIS IS WHY.
THESE ARE THE OUTCOMES WERE
EXPECTING IT'S GONNA BE BETTER
CHEAPER WHAT YOU KNOW WHATEVER
IT IS SO THAT WE CAN.
KIND OF JUST MAKE IT REAL SIMPLE.
TO I UNDERSTAND AND I APOLOGIZE
IF I KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
SAID THAT IT DID IT JUST DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE THAT THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM SHOULD BE A PART
OF THE ADULT PRISON SYSTEM.
THAT THE WHOLE IDEA IS THAT THEY
SHOULD BE THE END OF THE LINE
THE LAST STOP IN A YOUNG
PERSON'S.
JOURNEY THROUGH THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND THAT THE NEXT
STOP IS NOT A PRISON CELL THE
NEXT STOP IS.
A NEW A NEW LIFE AND IN THE
COMMUNITY BECOMING A THRIVING
ENGAGE MEMBER OF THAT.
AND THEN -- YEAH I GUESS THAT IT
DID BECAUSE I'M I'M LOOKING FOR
OUTCOMES RESULTS WHAT DO I
MANAGE WHAT WHAT MEASURE.
AND THEN.
IS IT JUST A MERGER YOU KNOW
SIDE.
OUR TOP RESHAPE.
THE ANSWERS.
HI I JUST NEED.
TO BECOME A SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERT A LITTLE MORE SALT I'LL
KEEP THIS THING SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INPUT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
UNDER BILL -- NO I AGREE WITH --
MOSIS QUESTIONS BEEN GOOD AND
THIS IS IMPORTANT OF KIND OF
MOVIE YOU FROM A CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. TO A HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAM. TO ALLOW
FOR THE REHABILITATION.
TREATMENT.
THAT IS MORE APPROPRIATE TO THE
USER AND YOUNG ADULTS -- HOWEVER
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT SOME OF THE
KEY CONCERNS.
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP BY
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN THE ANSWERS WE
HAVE SOME UNKNOWNS HERE -- IN A
GIVEN THE SHIFT OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
I IMAGINE THEY'LL BE CHANGED
SERVICES AS YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE CULTURE CHANGER.
OF HOW WE DO THINGS -- SO THAT
BEING SAID -- DOES THE GOVERNOR
HAVE A FIVE YOU'RE KIND OF A
STEP BY STEP WHAT HE WANTS TO DO
ON THIS OR IS HAVE A VISION OF
HOW WE HOW WE'RE GOING TO GO
OVER THIS OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
WELL I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO THE
TASK BEFORE ME YOUR PRESENTED TO
ME IN THIS PROPOSAL -- TO TO TO
MOVE IT -- BUT I THINK THAT THE
TRANSITIONING.
I THINK THE VISION IS BETTER I
MEAN IN TERMS OF THE THE THE
OVERALL YOU KNOW REFOCUSING OF
IT AND DOUBLING DOWN ON YOU KNOW
A DELIVERY OF SERVICES IN THE
LIGHT.
IS IT YOU KNOW.
IT IS IT IS CERTAINLY A HANDFUL
HERE AND I THINK IT IS SPEAKS
DIVISION FOR THE STATE AS WELL.
AND SO -- OTHER STATES HAVE GONE --
TO DIFFERENT MODELS LIKE THE
MISSOURI MODEL HERE FROM OUR SO
OF WHAT WE HAVE IS WE HAVE --
THE FOR FOR FOR FACILITIES
CENTRAL -- TO THEIR TOGETHER --
THEY'RE DESIGNED TO HOLD MUCH
LARGER POPULATIONS AND WE HAVE
NOW.
WITH SO I'M KIND OF GOING OVER
THIS.
IF YOU HAD THE RIGHT IF YOU HAD
TO SET UP A MODEL.
THERE WAS APPROPRIATE TO BE
OPERATED BY THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
WHEN SHE TO LOOK AT -- SMALLER
FACILITIES LOCATED IN THE AREAS
WERE THE YOUNG PEOPLE LIVE --
THAT COULD FOCUS ON LIKE A
HEALTH CARE -- THERAPEUTIC
MENTAL HEALTH -- AS WELL AS THE
RELIGION.
VALUATIONS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
IF YOU HAVE MORE FACILITIES
WOULD YOU BE ABLE -- TO LIKE
RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE.
THESE FACILITIES AND AS THE
POPULATION GETS SMALLER YOUR
SERVICE OF MIXING TYPES OF YOUNG-PEOPLE YOU KNOW DIFFERENT KINDS
OF YOUNG PEOPLE WITH DIFFERENT
KINDS OF PROBLEMS OKAY.
THERE ARE TIMES OF OFFENDERS
DIFFERENT KINDS OF DIFFERENT
CLASSES OF YOUNG PEOPLE OKAY I
PUT THAT WAY -- IF YOU HAD MORE
FACILITIES YOU WOULD HAVE MORE
ABILITY.
TO MAYBE THE FLEXIBILITY TO BE
MORE SPECIALIZED IN EACH
FACILITY MAYBE OF SOLELY THIS
DESIGN FOR DIFFERENT THINGS AND
OF PROGRAMS ARE CLOSER TO THE
COMMUNITY WHERE THE YOUNG PEOPLE
LIVE -- ARE YOU LOOKING AT
CLOSING DOWN OUR FACILITIES
[inaudible]
EVENTUALLY.
A MOVING OUT OF THOSE FACILITIES
AND CREATING NEW FACILITIES THAT --
OR IN A MORE A MYSTERY MODEL
KIND OF APPROACH.
OR ARE YOU LOOKING TO JUST KEEP
IN THE SAME ALL FACILITIES THE
WAY THEY ARE JUST HAVING.
A DIFFERENT APARTMENT.
OPERATED.
SO WITH SO.
I THINK I THINK THE ANSWER THAT
QUESTION TO ME IS KIND OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS.
HE'S GOING TO KEEP THE SAME.
BUILDINGS FACILITIES BEFORE.
HAVE ALL THESE YOUNG PEOPLE IS.
SIX SIX SEVEN HUNDRED OF THEM.
IN FOR FACILITIES IN FACILITIES
THAT ARE.
GOING TO BE LIKE -- THIRD -- 25%
OCCUPIED IMPORTANCE WITH THE THE
OCCUPANCY OF ROOM YOU KNOW
THEY'RE NOT DESIGNED FOR TWENTY
IT IS THEY CAN HOLD A LOT OF LOT
MORE.
PEOPLE IF YOU WANTED -- TO AND
THEN IF YOU WENT TO A DIFFERENT
LOOK.
KIND OF MODEL WHETHER SMALLER.
FACILITY SHE MIGHT HAVE A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF STAFF YOU
MIGHT HAVE MORE.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO THE HEALTH
HEALTH THE HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
MIGHT HAVE.
A STAFF DOES SO MAYBE -- MORE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES TYPE
PEOPLE MENTAL HEALTH -- SOCIAL
WORKERS.
STE A PSYCHIATRIC SOCIAL WORKERS
SO.
SMALLER BET NUMBER BEDS IN EACH
UNIT -- IN ADDITION TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY STAFF SO.
ARE YOU LOOKING AT A MODEL LIKE
I'M TALKING ABOUT OR YOU LOOK
INTO A MODEL THAT JUST KEEPS THE
FACILITIES LIKE THEY ARE.
SEEMS TO BE THE WHICH WATER
WOULD PRESUME PRODUCE.
THE BEST RESULTS IS THE ONE WE
WANT TO GO WITH RIDE.
AND AND THEN THE OTHER QUESTION
ON ON FUNDING.
YOU'RE OUT OF WHERE THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE -- WE WENT TO THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
DEPARTMENT.
WE HAVE SERVICES THERE WERE.
HEALTH.
WITH.
THESE SERVICES BE ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL MEDICAID OF EPS D. T.
OTHER KINDS OF HEALTHCARE
DOLLARS.
THE YOUR DEPARTMENT DOESN'T GET
RIGHT NOW -- BECAUSE YOU'RE IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS.
IS THAT IS THAT I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT BE SOMETHING THE
STAFF COULD GIVE US AN ANSWER ON
YOU KNOW -- AND IF IF SO.
WHEN YOU DO YOUR -- CRIMINAL
ANGELIC VALUATIONS.
COULD THAT BE COMBINED WITH A
HEALTH EVALUATION LIKE -- THE
PST TO THE WHICH YOU KNOW OF A
TALKING ABOUT IT -- WHERE EVERY
OF YOUNG PERSON IS EVALUATED
FROM THE HEALTH STANDPOINT?
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
MENTAL HEALTH.
OVERALL HEALTH CARE LIKE WHAT'S
THERE [inaudible]
CURRENT.
CURRENT STATUS -- DO YOU KNOW
HOW MANY MENTALLY ILL CHILDREN
WHAT THEIR DIAGNOSIS IS OR DO
YOU KNOW HOW MANY -- PEOPLE IN
THE OF YOUR DEPARTMENT HAVE
DEVELOPMENTAL.
DISABILITIES THAT.
MAKE THEM UNDER THE AMERICANS
FOR DISABILITIES ACT ELIGIBLE.
FOR THE SERVICES -- FUNDED OUT
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
DISABLED PERSON.
IN HPESSSRI ALL THOSE OTHER
KINDS OF PROGRAMS. FOR EXAMPLE.
OF IS THAT.
WHERE WE'RE GOING WITH THIS OF?
COULD YOU MAYBE TALK ABOUT WHAT
I'M WHAT I'M SAYING BECAUSE I'M
I'M LOOKING. FOR TO GET INTO
BETTER CLEARER PICTURE.
OF WHAT YOUR APPROACH IS GOING
TO BE WHAT.
ALL ALSO OFFER A QUICK AND TO
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT FEDERAL
FUNDING I DON'T THINK IT WOULD
CHANGE THE SEVEN WILL DIFFER
LOOK INTO AND RESEARCH TO SEE IF
WE CAN GET MORE FEDERAL FUNDING
WE ALWAYS ON MAXIMIZE THAT
FEDERAL FUNDING.
THE MOST WE CAN -- OR NOT IN A
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY A MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IF YOU'RE NOT
IN A CORRECTIONAL FACILITY.
UNDER THE MEDICAID LAWYER YOU
COULD MAKE.
THE HEALTH CARE [inaudible]
PART ELIGIBLE [inaudible] FOR
MEDICAID MEDICARE ALL WOULD YOU
WANT TO CALL IT.
AND THEN THE THE ENTITLEMENT OF
A YOUNG ONCE A PERSON'S IN.
EL IS ELIGIBLE FOR MEDIC MEDIC
MEDICAID.
THEY BECOME ELIGIBLE.
AS AN ENTITLEMENT [inaudible]
FOR EPS D. G. VALUATIONS.
THAT COULD BE AN ONGOING
EVALUATION THAT'S A SEVEN TO ONE
RATIO YOU GETS. ONE DOLLAR WE
PUT UP WE GET SEVEN FEDERAL.
SO THAT'S NOT A BAD DEAL I'M I'M
TALKING LIKE AN OLD COUNTY
SUPERVISOR.
CENTER MORE LOCK IN A WE KNOW
THESE NUMBERS REAL WELL RIGHT IN
THE COUNTY.
SO SO.
IT'S AN IS STILL IS A SEVEN TO
ONE I CHECKED THIS WEEK.
SO SO -- I THINK I TAKE YOU KNOW
IF YOU KNOW LOOK AT THE IF YOU
LOOK AT JUST RUNNING THE SAME.
FACILITIES YOU MIGHT NOT BE ABLE
TO DO THIS.
BUT IF YOU START LOOKING AT
OTHER FACILITIES.
CREATING NEW FACILITIES.
IT MIGHT BE -- THEY COULD BE A
LOCKED FACILITY THEY COULD BE
SPECIALIZED THAT COULD BE YOU
KNOW WE COULD DO THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS TO YOU KNOW.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE -- WE'LL LOOK
AT SOME OF THOSE KIND OF ISSUES.
IN DECIDING WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AN INCH OR SO.
DIRECTIONS NEED TO BE GIVEN TO
YOU ON THIS.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR.
MORE YOUR THOUGHTS ON A YEAH
TOTALLY CENTER WILL WILL
DEFINITELY CAN TO IT IT MAY BE A
SITUATION LIKE STATE HOSPITALS
FOR LICENSURE DOESN'T ALLOW FOR
FEDERAL FUNDING AND COMPLETELY
BUT IT'S UNUSUAL CATHERINE'S WE
HAVE TO CHALLENGE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DON'T LIKE -- BUT I
DISLIKE DAD ENTERS YOUR QUESTION
OF CIVILITY IS I THINK A LOT OF
THE SORT OF TREATMENT YOU
DESCRIBE ARE ALREADY MOVING
TOWARDS AT OUR LARGE FACILITIES --
YOU KNOW ARE USED TO HAVE
TREATMENT TEAMS THAT HAVE THAT
THERAPEUTIC STAFF AND SO I THINK
THAT WORKS REALLY ALREADY
STARTING NOW.
THE CHECK IS A YOU WANTED TO AT
YEAH I THINK THAT THE YOU KNOW
QUESTIONS SUCH AS WHOM DO WE
SERVE -- WHAT CONTEXT OR
ENVIRONMENT OR THE BEST SERVED
IN AND WHAT SERVICES DO WHAT WE
PROVIDE TO THEM?
ARE IMPORTANT QUESTIONS AND THAT
THERE ARE.
SHORTER IN MID TERM TYPECAST
BEFORE US AND I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL IN TERMS OF THIS FIRST.
TRANSFERRING OVER TO THE BAR
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES PUTS A
LENS YOU KNOW ESTABLISHES US
WITH AN ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS
WILL PUT UP PUTS US IN A PLACE
TO TO HAVE THE SENATE GLASSES
FOR THE LENSES THROUGH WHICH WE
CAN LOOK AT THROUGH THE PROPER
CONTEXT OF BEING.
ABLE TO ANSWER -- YOU KNOW THOSE
QUESTIONS MOVING FORWARD --
THERE WAS A BILL -- THEIR DUES --
SB -- TWO EIGHTY FOUR IN SB TWO
FOUR CHANGED -- CHARGING RATE TO
COUNTIES [inaudible]
ON SENDING PEOPLE TO THE
FACILITY THE STATE FACILITY --
BUDGETARY STANDPOINT --
INCREASING THE COUNTY FEES SO
[inaudible]
IN -- OR DECREASING ACOSTA TO BE
A COMEDY APPROPRIATE COMBINATION
DECREASE THE COST OR INCREASED
THE IS ONE OF THE YOU'VE LOOKED
AT THIS BILL -- AND WE HAD WE
HAD THIRTY VOTES IN FAVOR EIGHT
PEOPLE AGAINST THE OKAY -- A WE
GOT A CONVERTIBLE.
THE THIRTY VOTES IN FAVOR TODAY.
JUST A FEW HOURS AGO -- I WANTED
TO FIND OUT -- IF THOSE KINDS OF
REVENUE SOURCES COULD PLAY -- A
STRONGER ROLE IN HELPING WITH
[inaudible]
TRANSITIONING.
OF THE SONG.
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS THAT WE
NEED TO PROVIDE THESE.
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE TRANSITION
PROCESS IS WHEN THE CAR WHEN I
ALWAYS HEAR TRANSITION I ALWAYS
THINK -- IT'S GONNA YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO SPEND SOME MONEY ON YEAH
I JUST KIND OF GOES STATUS
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE.
TO FIGURE OUT.
THE TRANSITION PLAN AND IT'S
GOING.
TO END UP COMING TO US.
FOR A BUDGETARY -- CHANGE EITHER
A CHANGE IN THE WAY YOU'RE
SPENDING MONEY OR A REQUEST TO
US.
SO WE PASSED A OF IT WAS SENT
OVER TO THIS THE OTHERS THE
GREEN CARPET ASSEMBLY -- THE
BILL YESTERDAY OR TODAY.
SO I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ARE ON THAT.
YEAH I'M NOT.
FAMILIAR ENOUGH WITH THE
SPECIFICS OF IT TO BE ABLE TO
OFFER AN OPINION ON AT THIS TIME
I KNOW IT'S GONNA GO TO FURTHER
DELIBERATIONS.
THIS IS A LOT OF MONEY COULD
GENERATE THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
OF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
NO YOU DON'T HAVE ANY COMMENTS
COMMON SIR THANK YOU OKAY WELL
THEN -- WHAT WE WANT TO SEE AS
YOU EXPLORE THAT BEFORE WE MAKE
DECISIONS SO MAYBE YOU CAN
[inaudible]
EXPLORE THAT.
BEFORE WE START FINALIZING THE
BUDGET AGREEMENT HERE.
ON THIS ISSUE.
THAT'S MY FEELING.
AND I THINK WE'RE WE'RE KIND OF
YOU KNOW THIS IS A NEW ITEM IN A
WE WANNA.
I I PERSONALLY WANT TO MAKE IT
WORK OKAY I'M I'M I'M REALLY.
IGGY EXCITED THAT YOU'RE.
ABLE TO COME TOGETHER AND KIND
OF WORK GET A GROUP OF PEOPLE
TOGETHER TO TRY.
TO MAKE THIS WORK BECAUSE I
THINK IF YOU DID IT RIGHT.
AND THAT'S A BIG CABBIE OUT A
COULD BENEFIT THE YOUNG PEOPLE
AS OF I KNOW YOU REALLY CARE
ABOUT.
THE PEOPLE THAT YOU'VE BEEN
SERVING FOR ALL THESE NUMBERS OF
YEARS TRUCKS SO.
I THINK IT WOULD HELP.
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE YOU SAY
HAVE SUCCESSFUL LIVES IN THE
FUTURE.
AND DIVERT HIM FROM.
OUR CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
AND SO SO I I I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
EXPLORED MANAGER -- AND GIVING --
TRANSITION YOU KNOW LIKE.
A TRANSITION CAR -- PROCESS
NEEDS TO BE ESTABLISHED OF FUN
SOME FUNDING. TO ROUTE OF
LOOKING AT ALTERNATIVE FUNDING
SOURCES -- SB OF TWO EIGHTY FOUR
JUST ONE FOR MEDI CAL.
THE PST T. OTHER KINDS OF
SOURCES.
SO I I I I HOPE THAT THAT COULD
BE PART OF OUR DISCUSSION HERE
IN OUR COMPANY.
THANK YOU SIR ROLAND -- THE
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN -- BUT FOLLOWING
EARNED SOME OF THIS COMMON
DISCUSSION SO FAR.
WE HAVE THIS INTERESTING
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE.
WE HAVE.
WELL ONE THING WE SHOULD BE VERY
PROUD OF IS THAT OVER TIME.
NOT ONLY DO THE LAWSUITS BUT DUE
TO OTHER ACTIONS THAT.
LEGISLATURE.
AND AT FOUR MINUTES TAKEN.
THE POPULATION OF JUVENILES THAT
WE HOLD IN THE STATE FACILITY
HAS GREATLY REDUCED.
AND AND I THINK THAT SIGNIFICANT.
BECAUSE MANY OF IF WE AGAIN
THINK ABOUT WHAT'S OUR OBJECTIVE
WITH.
IF ANY JUVENILES THAT ENCOUNTER.
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM OUR
OBJECTIVE OF OF COURSE IS OF
COURSE TO HAVE THAT BE THE LAST
STOP IN SO.
THE THE MORE WE CAN HANDLE THEM
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY SYSTEMS NOT
EVEN IN COUNTY.
JUVENILE FACILITIES PURCHASING
COMMUNITY BASED SYSTEMS AND SO
WE'VE SEEN BOTH THERE'S THIS
VERY SIGNIFICANT DROP IN THE
POPULATION OF WHO WE OLD WHEN I
WAS ELECTED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT IT WAS TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
I BELIEVE.
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED TO THREE
THOUSAND AND WE'RE NOW AT ABOUT.
SEVEN HUNDRED AND NOW IF WE LOOK.
AT THE SAME TIME WE LOOK AT OUR
POPULATION.
IN THE COUNTY FACILITIES IN THE
JUNE OKAY I MEAN CENTER BILLS
GOT CHARTS LIKE I MEAN IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE HOW MANY BEDS.
EACH.
COUNTY YOUR DIFFERENT COUNTIES
HAVE.
AND YET THE NUMBER OF JUVENILES
HELD IN THOSE COUNTY SO FOR
EXAMPLE -- THE LOS ANGELES IS
DOWN TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
JUVENILES IN THEIR OWN
FACILITIES.
OR FOR THESE ARE OUR FACILITIES
OKAY SORRY HIS OTHER.
SENATOR BILLS WHEN HE SAID
MINUTE WHICH HE PASSED OUT TWICE
LAST WEEK HAD THE NUMBERS OF
LA'S EVEN WITHIN THEIR OWN
FACILITIES IT'S DROPPED.
TO ITS THE IT'S A VERY SMALL
NUMBER AS AS COMPARED TO THE
NUMBER OF BEDS IT HAS.
ENDED AND THE CAPACITY AT HALAS
SO IN ALMOST ALL OF OUR COUNTIES
ARE IN THAT CIRCUMSTANCE AND WE
HAVE SOME COUNTIES THAT HAVE.
ZERO KIDS IN THERE.
I POINT THE IN THEIR JUVENILE
FACILITY COUNTY BASED NO I POINT
THAT OUT BECAUSE STATEWIDE BOTH
ARE LOCALS.
AND WE IS THE STATE HAVE BEEN
MOVING IN THE DIRECTION.
OF A DIFFERENT MODEL TO DEAL
WITH JUVENILES.
NOW I SEE THIS AS COMPLIMENTARY
TO IN PARALLEL TO THAT MOVEMENT.
THIS.
ADOPTION OF MOVING THE DIVISION
INTO MOVING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE INTO.
THE DIVISION OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND RENAMING IT THE
DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
NOW THIS QUESTION OF WHETHER.
THESE.
YOUNG PEOPLE SHOULD BE IN
SMALLER FACILITIES COMMUNITY
BASED.
IS DEFINITELY A LEGITIMATE ONE
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION IN THE
LOOP LEGISLATURE TO HAVE
OVERTIME.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FIRST
RECALL.
WHO THESE JUVENILES ARE THAT ARE
IN OUR STATE?
FACILITIES THEY ARE.
UNLESS OUR LOCALS ARE.
CHARGING THEM VERY INACCURATELY
THEY ARE.
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT HAVE.
EXHIBITED THE MOST HAVE.
COMMITTEDTHE MOST VIOLENT
CRIMES IN WHO.
WOULD THAT WOULD IF WE AGAIN
TRUSTS THE PROCESS FOR WHICH
THEY WERE CHARGED AND CONVICTED.
MIGHT BE THE GREATEST RISK TO US
IN TERMS OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND THAT'S SAID WELL THAT TO ME
DOES NOT NECESSARILY ARGUE
AGAINST A MODEL THAT WOULD.
ALLOW SMALLER FACILITIES AND
MORE COMMUNITY BASED.
IT'S CERTAINLY TELLS ME THAT.
AS WE TRANSITION.
AND GIVEN THAT.
THAT WE HAVE DISCO HORDE NOW.
WE NEED TO THINK THROUGH THOSE
TRANSITIONS VERY CAREFULLY.
AND WE NEED TO SEE WHETHER THE
TYPE OF CULTURE CHANGE IN
THERAPEUTIC MODEL THAT.
I BELIEVE THIS MISSION IS TRYING
TO ACHIEVE WILL WORK.
AND IN A WAY.
WE COULDDEBATE ABOUT WHETHER
IT'S BETTER TESTED.
IN THESE MORE CENTRALIZED
FACILITIES OR NOT I MEAN THERE'S
DOWNSIDES DEFINITELY BECAUSE
THOSE FACILITIES WERE MORE
DESIGNED. TO BE LIKE PRISONS.
AND THEY YOU KNOW SO THERE ARE
DEFINITE DOWNSIDES.
BUT I AM WILLING TO LOOK AT THIS
IN.
HELLO FIVE ONE USED INCREMENTAL
STEPS BUT I'M WILLING TO HAVE
THIS BE KIND OF OUR LABORATORY
FOR CASTING.
THESE NEW THINGS [inaudible]
AND WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IN
THIS TRANSITION IS I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THE NAME CHANGE SOONER SO
THAT IT'S REALLY CLEAR THAT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE EMBARKING ON I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
M. MAYBE A MORE FORMALIZED
STAKEHOLDER GROUP.
AGAIN I'M OPEN TO DISCUSSION
ABOUT THAT.
SO THAT WE REALLY ARE FORMALLY
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF EXPERTS IN
THIS FIELD.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
THE ARE POTENTIALLY WHETHER WE
PILOTED WHETHER WE DO IT FOR ALL
THE FACILITIES BUT WE KNOW THAT
OUR EXISTING STAFF.
WELL SOME OF THEM HAVE SOCIAL
WORK IN OTHER DEGREES STEP
PRIMARILY THE EXISTING STAFF.
YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT THE MODEL
THAT THEY WERE EITHER TRAIN FOR
HIRED FOR SO.
THERE'S IN THE TRAILER BILL
CLEARER -- AN ALLOCATION REQUEST
OF RESOURCES AND CLEARED
DESCRIPTION OF A WHOLE NEW
ACADEMY A WHOLE NEW TRAINING
COMPONENT WHICH I SUPPORT.
BUT AS WE'RE PREPARING AND
TRANSITIONING OUR EXISTING STAFF.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT IT WAS
USEFUL TO HAVE.
SOME OF THIS THERAPEUTIC
COMMUNITY MODEL.
ALREADY. TO TO IMPLEMENTED
WITHIN SOME OF THESE FACILITIES
SO THAT.
WE CAN IN A WAY TESTED AND SO
THAT ARE EXISTING STAFF CAN SEE
HOW IT WORKS.
AND IF WE LOOK AT THE ADULT SIDE
WE HAVE CREATED THESE
THERAPEUTIC COMMUNITIES IN A
COUPLE OF ADULT PRISONS IN RG
DONOVAN IN LANCASTER A COUPLE
OTHER PLACES WHERE WE WE USE
SMALLER COHORTS OF INDIVIDUALS --
AND WE HAVE -- WE ENGAGE A WHOLE
DIFFERENT KIND OF OF FAT
PROGRAMMING WITH THEM -- WHEN
WHILE THEY'RE STILL HOUSED IN
OUR CORRECTIONAL FACILITY THESE
ADULTS THE MOST OF THEIR
PROGRAMMING AND A GOOD PORTION
OF THEIR DAYS SPENT IN NEEDS
THERAPEUTIC COMMUNITY TYPE MODEL --
SO I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THAT
START SOONER THAN LATER AND THAT
MAY REQUIRE US HAVING TO DEVELOP
A NORTH P. IN USING AN EXTERNAL
ENTITY.
BUT IT COULD ALSO ALLOW US. TO
TO START ARTICULATING WHAT IS
WHERE CERTAINLY WE HAVE A
MISSION AND I DON'T MEAN I'M NOT
IN ANY WAY MINIMIZING THAT THE
TRAILER BILL HAS A MISSION BUT
IN OUR FEED COULD START
ARTICULATING.
TYPE OF THERAPEUTIC MANY WERE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
AND THE TYPE OF METRICS WE MAY
WANT TO BE TRYING TO ALSO
ACHIEVED SO THAT THEN IF WE
ENDED UP.
ENGAGING SOME EXTERNAL PARTNERS
TO PILOT THIS AS WE DO THIS
TRANSITION.
IT IT'S BENEFICIAL BOTH IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR TRAINING IN
IN MULTIPLE WAYS -- SO I I THINK
IT IS WORTH IT. TO TO ALSO
CONSIDER DOING THAT.
AND THAT'S NOT PART OF THE
TRAILER BILL RIGHT NOW BUT I
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
WITH.
THE DEPARTMENT AND DIVISION AND
THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT AN OVER
WHETHER THERE'S OPENNESS TO THAT --
YEAH AND THOSE ARE SOME OF MY
THOUGHTS RIGHT NOW. ONE HOW WE
MIGHT PROCEED IN ADDITION TO
WHAT YOU'VE PUT BEFORE US.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY WANTS TO
MAKE ANY COMMENT TO THAT OR THE
LA NUMBERS.
OKAY FOR YES SO IN LOS ANGELES
IS [inaudible]
ONE THERE ARE.
THIS IS FOR THEIR COUNTY
JUVENILE FACILITIES THERE ARE
THREE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT TOTAL BEDS.
AND THERE ARE ONLY EIGHT HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE USED IN THEM.
WHICH MEANS THAT IT'S ONLY 24%
FALL.
AND THERE'S A TWO THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE BEDS OF
VACANCY.
SOME OF THEM NOW REALLY KIDS
INTO AN AND LA COUNTY YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN OUR OWN STATE
FACILITIES IS A HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX NOW I SAY THAT.
NOT TO ARGUE.
THAT WE START FILLING UP THOSE
COUNTY BEDS I I'M NOT.
SO I DON'T WANT TO HAVE ANYONE
MISS UNDERSTAND ME I'M NOT
ADVOCATING THAT WE FILL UP THOSE
COUNTY BEDS -- BUT RATHER THAT.
IT'S A DEMONSTRATION THAT ARE.
THAT ARE IF IT TOO APPROACHING
JUVENILE JUSTICE FROM A MORE
LIKE HEY HERE'S A KID WITH A
PROBLEM LET'S TRY TO GIVEN THE
RESOURCES TO HELP HIM FIX IT
VERSUS JUST.
PUNISHING THEM IS SOMETHING THAT
IS CLEARLY BEEN BEING EMBRACED
ACROSS THE STATE IN ADDITION TO
THE STATISTICS THAT JUVENILE
CRIME.
IS OVERALL DOWN BOTH THINGS GOOD
ANYWAY YOU GO AHEAD [inaudible]
THE M..
WE CERTAINLY THE THE THE
POPULATIONS THAT WE DO RECEIVE
IT DJJ -- INCREASINGLY SO OUR
YOUTH WHO.
OTHERWISE WOULD BE CHARGED AS
ADULTS PROP FIFTY SEVEN YES --
IS HAD A IN IMPACT IN TERMS OF
WHO IT IS THIS COMING TO DJJ AND
PERHAPS WITHOUT THAT WHAT --
WHERE WHERE THEY WOULD BE HOUSED
AND THAT?
THE YOU KNOW.
THE IDEA THAT WE COULD BRING
THIS DIVERSITY OF YOUNG PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND HAVE OUTCOMES OTHER
THAN INTERGROUP CONFLICT.
REINFORCEMENT OF YOU KNOW
DIFFERENCES BE A GANG
AFFILIATION OR WHAT HAVE YOU.
CAN TO HELP THEM LEARN HOW TO BE
ABLE TO WORKACROSS PERCEIVED
DIFFERENCES AND CERTAINLY ITSELF
FUNDAMENTAL.
YOU KNOW NEED FOR A USED TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT GROUP THEY
BELONG TO ITS ITS EVOLUTIONARY
IT'S IT'S IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
A TASK OF A YOUNG PERSON TO
FIGURE OUT AN IDENTITY AND A
GROUP THAT THEY BELONG.
TO AND THE IDEA OF LEARNING HOW
TO BE ABLE TO WORK ACROSS
DIFFERENCES ACROSS GROUPS IN A
SMALL SETTING. TO BE ABLE TO
WORK TOWARDS SUPPORTING EACH
OTHER BEING SUCCESSFUL HAVING A
DIFFERENCE ARE ABOUT COME WITH
REGARD TO WHAT THEY THOUGHT THAT
THEIR LIFE IS GOING TO BE --
THAT THAT THOSE SMALL GROUPS ARE
REALLY REALLY CRITICAL BE A YOU
KNOW A SMALL FACILITY OR SMALL
GROUPS WITHIN A FACILITY
BUILDING THAT KIND OF A
THERAPEUTIC COMMUNITY WHERE
YOU'RE LEARNING THOSE.
REALLY SORT OF COMMUNITY
RESTORATION SKILLS ASSOCIATED
WITH HOW TO LIVE PEACEFULLY
WITHIN A COMMUNITY WITH PEOPLE
DIFFERENT FROM YOURSELVES IN THE
LIKE FIT INTO IT AND SO.
I THINK THE ON THE IDEA THAT YOU
CAN YOU TO ROUTE IT.
TERMS OF OPEN DISCUSSION OR WHAT
HAVE YOU -- BUT IT IT DOES
CORRESPOND WITH REGARD TO WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WAS TRYING
TO BUILD STRONG CARING
COMMUNITIES WITHIN DJJ AND
REGARDLESS OF YOU KNOW.
FUTURE DISCUSSIONS OR WHAT HAVE
YOU THAT THE THERAPEUTIC MODEL
THE MISSOURI MODEL SO TO SPEAK.
YOU KNOW IT CAN HAPPEN WITHIN
DJJ ON THE UNIT WITH THREE FOUR
SMALLER GROUPS ALL GOING THROUGH
THIS JOURNEY YOU KNOW.
TO TOGETHER AND I KNOW THAT YOU
NO LONGER TO CONVERSATION PEOPLE
THROWN OUT THERE IN TERMS OF THE
FUTURE DJJ WHERE BEST TO TREAT
THE THE YOUTH AND THE LIKE I
FEEL THAT MUCH OF WHAT IT IS WE
WANT.
TO ACCOMPLISH -- WE CAN MAKE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES TOWARD --
WITH REGARD TO JOB ONE AT HAND
N TERMS OF THE POPULATION THAT
WE HAVEN'T HOW BEST TO SERVE
THEM TODAY TOMORROW -- AND AND
MOVING FORWARD.
SO WHAT I'D LIKE IS THAT AS WE
HOLD THIS OPEN THAT WEEK.
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSIONS FOR HOW
WE IN COMPLETE RESPECTING THAT
BE WE'RE GOING THROUGH A
TRANSITION AND WE NEED.
TRAINING COMPONENTS WE NEED ALL
THAT THAT WE ALSO MIGHT.
HOW WE MIGHT INCORPORATE?
SOME PORTION OF THIS THERAPY TO
COMMUTING MODEL SOONER THAN
LATER SO THAT WE BEGIN TO YOU
KNOW NOT ONLY TESTED BUT HAVE.
ALL OF US TO INTERACT WITH THE
FACILITIES AND WITH THE
JUVENILES YOU DON'T SEE IT BEING
APPLIED IT'S THAT PRAXIS.
SOY SO WILL OBVIOUSLY CONTINUE
TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
WHETHER THAT IS SOMETHING WE CAN
ACHIEVE AND IN THIS -- IN.
THIS BILL.
THIS BUDGET YEAR IN IN
MODIFICATION TO THE TRAILER BILL.
NOW I KNOW THAT THERE ARE LOTS
OF COMMUNITY HERE THAT ONE OR
PUBLIC HERE THAT ONE AT TALK ON
THE PUBLIC MIKE SO LET ME JUST
SEE IF ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS THEY WANNA
MAKE IT SORRY.
YES GO AHEAD CENTER ABOUT JUST
ONE THOUGH IF THE COUNTY
FACILITY ABOUT A THIRD FULL.
THERE'S YOUR I KNOW IT'S TRUE IN
MY COUNTY.
OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY -- THERE
ARE SOME OF OUR FACILITIES
[inaudible]
THERE.
NOT THAT HAVE BEEN CLOSED OR NOT
THEIR VACATION AND OTHER.
STE THE SOME OF ARE FAIRLY SMALL.
AND OF IT SEEMS TO ME THE IT
WOULD WISE TO DO MAYBE -- A
SURVEY OF COUNTIES AND
FACILITIES.
TO MAYBE HAVE INITIATED
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM ABOUT
[inaudible]
POSSIBILITY -- YOU KNOW USING
SOME OF THOSE.
YOU KNOW NOT YOU NOT USEFACILITIES BUT ARE THE ONES THAT
ARE IN GOOD SHAPE AND ALL.
THAT WOULD FIT THE NEEDS OF YOUR
MODEL YOUR PROGRAM.
THAT THAT -- THAT'S A
POSSIBILITY JUST SO.
YOU DO A SURVEY THE COUNTY AND
WHAT KIND OF FACILITIES THEY
HAVE.
ADD AND MANAGE SURE -- WE'VE
SPENT IN THE BUDGET THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
GIVING TO COUNTY JUVENILE
PROBATION PROGRAMS. FOR GRANTS
TO HELP THEM OPERATOR BUILDER
FACILITIES.
SO WE HAVE GIVEN THEM A LOT OF
FUNDS. TO FUND THESE FACILITIES
SO -- I THINK IT'S WORTHY OF
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO PUBLIC COMMENT.
I'M HELEN ROTH DOWN FROM SEIU
LOCAL ONE THOUSAND FIRST OF ALL
WE SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL WHAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THOUGH IS IT
DOESN'T INTERFERE WITH THE
WONDERFUL PILOT THAT WAS AGREED
LAST YEAR.
WERE MORE PEOPLE FROM ADULT
PRISONS ARE BEING PUT IN DJJ AND
WE THINK THE DJJ COULD BE AN AND
THERAPEUTIC COMPUTE.
COMMUNITY A TO SENATOR BELLS
POINT WITHIN -- THE ADULT
FACILITIES ARE VERY FEW SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS I BELIEVE THE
A THAT.
YET THEY EXIST WITHIN THE USE
THE JUVENILE FACILITIES SO.
THE I. D. A. GOES UP TO AGE
TWENTY TWO THERE'S ALMOST
THIRTEEN THOUSAND PRISONERS WHO
BELOW ARE BELOW THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE IN THE ADULT
PRISONERS IN THE ADULT PRISONS
THAT COULD BE SERVED.
WITH IN THESE PRISONS SO AS WE
LOOK AT THIS WE SHOULD TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION MOVING SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE.
THAT COULD COME INTO A MUCH MORE
THERAPEUTIC ENVIRONMENT THAT ARE
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE
BECAUSE THEY TOO ARE GOING TO
RETURN TO THE COMMUNITY.
IT WOULD ALSO SOLVE OUR
OVERCROWDING PROBLEM WHICH IS
NOW HAS AS UNDER THE FEDERAL
GUIDANCE.
AND THAT'S THE REASON THAT WE
WOULD -- AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
WOULD ASK THAT YOU WOULD DO THIS
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIRMAN SKINNER.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS GEORGE VIA.
I AM -- PROGRAM ASSISTING WITH
MOTIVATED INDIVIDUAL LEADERSHIP
FOR PUBLIC ADVANCEMENT WERE AN
ADVOCACY GROUP IN IN SALINAS
COMPRISE OF OF RECIPIENTS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE IN THE C. Y. SYSTEM.
I'M ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF A
NONPROFIT JIM -- IN THE SALINAS
OUT CURRENTLY -- UC DAVIS
STUDENT.
AT MID TERM AT THREE O'CLOCK --
SKEWS ME PATIENT NISSEN WHAT BUT
I THINK I FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT TO
COMMON REPRESENT ALL MY FRIENDS
AND FAMILIES OUR INSIDE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE --
I CURRENTLY GO INSIDE THERE
EVERY WEDNESDAY -- AND I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS AT THE
JOKES DOING IN THE STAFF TO
ALLOW ME COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO GO
IN HERE I'M ALSO THE FULL
SUPPORT.
OF OF UNAPOLOGETICALLY OF OF
TRANSITIONING DOES THIS
INSTITUTION INTO HUMAN HEALTH
SERVICES INSTITUTION WHERE YOUTH
ARE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO THE OUTSIDE OF THEIR CELL
WITHERS THEY CAN ENJOY THOUGH
THE OUTSIDE FREEDOM YOU KNOW
THERE'S A STAFF ATTORNEY MARTY
JEANNIE WHO HAS MODEL HE
REMEMBERS WHEN I WAS IN ITS IN.
THE PRESS THE INSTITUTION AND
HIS WATER WAS.
THEM OUTSIDE GIVEN PLAY GAMES
SPORTS AND THEY'LL BE TIRED A
GOING DINNER.
SHOWER OF READY TO GO TO BED AND
REDUCE THE FIGHTS AND THE MODEL
ALWAYS WORK -- SINCE I'VE BEEN
GOING INSIDE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE YEAH I SEE THE
THE CULTURE THAT NEEDS TO BE
CHANGED.
ABOUT HALF THE STAFF THAT ARE
REALLY CARING AND DOWN TO
SUPPORT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE YOU GOT
OTHER STAFF THAT.
THEY'RE STILL KIND OF STUCK ON
THE PART OF THE PUNISHMENT MODEL
AND THAT PUNISHMENT MORE REALLY
MESSED UP CALIFORNIA IT'S TOO
EXPENSIVE I WANT.
TO QUOTE UNQUOTE OR HIGHLIGHT
WITH MR BILLS ARE 75% OF PEOPLE
WITHIN THREE YEARS RECENTLY.
AS A LOT OF MONEY THAT'S WHAT'S
LOST TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND PLUS
IN I KNOW WE'RE ALL HUMANS AND
WE ALWAYS ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
THIS OUT -- I'LL NEVER POINT
FINGERS ON ANYONE AND STATE YOUR
FALL IT'S YOUR FAULT BUT A LOT
OF FRIENDS TO THAT SYSTEM I LOST.
YOUR TO DRUGS AND AND AND IT'S
NOT FAIR THAT I'M WITH THE ONLY
ONE THAT CAN OR WILL OF ONLY ONE
A FEW THAT CAN GO AND GO TO
UNIVERSITY.
AND THE ONE OF THE OLD OLD OLD
MODELS DON'T WORK.
YOU KNOW AND I LIKE I SAID I
APPRECIATE THE THEY ALSO KNEW
HIM ONLY.
NO THE BUT THEY ALSO NEED TO
KNOW HOW TO CARE ABOUT ARGUING
OUR YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE
IN THESE INSTITUTIONS.
AND I I I'M I'M I'M PROUD THAT
I'M IN A POSITION WHERE I CAN
SEE CHANGE THE HEARTS OF THE
STAFF THAT ARE IN THERE THAT ARE
STRUGGLING YOU KNOW BECAUSE
SOMETIMES WE LEARN THESE
BEHAVIOR THAT.
THEY'RE JST NOT HEALTHY AND AND
THE OLD MODEL DIDN'T WORK BUT I
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE BRAVERY
IN THE CURRENT IS AT THE
GOVERNOR AND THEN YOU ALL HERE
HAVE TODAY BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HUMANS HERE.
ENOUGH THIS RECIDIVISM RATES NOT
WORKING WHAT WOULD YOU CALL THAT.
NOT CALL LASTED FROM THE NEEDS A
LOT OF FIXING TO DO A LOT OF A
LOT OF JUST.
COLLECTIVE THINKING COLLECTIVE
STOCK PRICES -- AND AND LASTLY I
I I I WANT TO JUST REALLY REALLY
STRESS THAT YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
BE ASKING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WHAT
THEY ALSO ME AND I HER CHUCKLE
WHEN ASKED TO MY I'VE BEEN IN
THERE WITH THEM AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT'S A START BUT LIKE.
I SAID THE THE THERE NEEDS TO BE
A MORE OF AN IMPACT LIKE YOU
KNOW.
ASSN THE STAFF LOOK IF YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO CARE ABOUT THE SHOW
PEOPLE EITHER DON'T SYSTEM THERE
THAT.
BUILDING PRISONS ALL THE TIME WE
CAN ARE THERE BUT THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE SHOULD NOT BE DEALING
WITH THE THE STRESS THAT THAT
THEY'RE GOING ON AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
pON BEHALF OF THE ELEVATOR CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS WE DO SUPPORT
THE MOVE A DJ INTO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
THAT SAID WE WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT THE CULTURE OF NORMALCY
THAT MR SUPPLE SO ELOQUENTLY
DESCRIBED.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT CULTURE OF
NORMALCY CAN BE CREATEDIN THE
CURRENT PHYSICAL BUILDINGS THAT
DJ USES AND WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THE MISERY MODEL CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED IN THOSE STRUCTURES.
THEY ARE JUST PRISON LIKE THEY
ARE PRISONS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE VISION
THAT MR SUPPLE PUTS FORWARD OF A
CULTURE OF NORMALCY IN A
THERAPEUTIC APPROACHTO THE WORK
IS.
A GREAT VISION AND TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT THAT WE NEED TO MOVE
TO DIFFERENT PHYSICAL STRUCTURES
CLOSER TO COMMUNITY SMALLER
NUMBER OF YOUTH BEING HELD
TOGETHER.
IN A WAY WHERE THEIR FAMILIES
CAN BE DIRECTLY INVOLVED.
WE ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
YOUTH BEING SENT TO DJ NOW AND
TO NOT.
ACCEPT WITHOUT QUESTIONING THAT
THESE ARE THE WORST OF THE WORST
YOUTH AS I'VE HEARD THEM
DESCRIBED THIS MORNING.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT COUNTY
DISPARITIES IN WHO IS BEING SENT
TO DJJ AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THE USE OF SACRAMENTO ARE WORSE
THAN THE YOUTH OF THEIR
NEIGHBORING COUNTY.
SAN JOAQUIN I THINK WE NEED TO
ASK WHY ARE SOME COUNTIES
SENDING USED TO DJJ IN OTHER
COUNTIES OR NOT.
AND WHAT IS IT WE CAN PROVIDE.
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL TO FIX THAT
PROBLEM SO THAT IN EVERY COUNTY
THERE ARE ALTERNATIVES FOR EVERY
YOUTH THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- MIKE
BELOW SPEAKING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
AND THE SECTION OF CJ KNOWN AS A
JUVENILE COURT JUDGES OF
CALIFORNIA JUST AS THE DJJ
POPULATION IS UNIQUE SO TO R. G.
JUVENILE COURT JUDGES.
THEY TEND TO BE JUDGES WHO DO
NOT CYCLE THROUGH ASSIGNMENTS AS
ROUTINELY AS OTHERS THEY ARE SO
THEY ARE DEDICATED TO JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND TND TO STAY IN
THOSE ASSIGNMENTS A LONG TIME.
WE'VE BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND WE DO
SUPPORT IN CONCEPT THIS CHANGE
YOU'VE USED THE PHRASE IS
CULTURE CHANGE THAT SORT OF
THING IT IS A MOVEMENT FROM.
A CRIMINAL JUSTICE MODEL TO A
REHABILITATIVE MODEL -- OUR
JUDGES DON'T AT ALL -- MINIMIZE
THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE CRIMES
THAT LEAD TO DE DE DE JJ
COMMITMENT.
BUT WE THINK THIS HAS PROMISE
AND WE WANT TO BE AT THE TABLE
AND APPRECIATE THE THAT THE
SPIRIT OF THE MOVE AND WANT TO
WORK ON IT.
THANK YOU.
DONNA DOES NOT EVEN THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW WE ARE ALSO
IN SUPPORT BUT HOPE THAT THAT.
THIS ISN'T JUST THE END OF THE
DISCUSSION BUT AN IMPETUS FOR
GREATER TRANSFORMATION THE
CURRENT LACK OF OVERSIGHT.
CORONATIONS BETWEEN OUR YOUTH
SERVING SYSTEMS MEANS THAT OUR
YOUTH ARE RECEIVING.
POOR SERVICES FOR AN
EXTRAORDINARY PRICE AND AT THE
END OF THE DAY WE BELIEVE THAT.
WE HAVE COMMUNITIES WE HAVE
IMPACTED USE FAMILIES COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
EXPERTISE WE HAVE DOCTORS MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ACROSS THE
STATE.
WHO HAVE INSIDE AND WE WOULD
STRONGLY RECOMMEND CREATING A
FORMALIZED AND TO BE ABLE TO
INCORPORATE?
ADDITIONALLY AS WE SEEM TO ME
BASED ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
BENEFITS OF BEING ABLE TO HAVE
THEM COME IN AND START WORK WITH
THE RE ENTRY.
WE UNDERSTAND THE RE ENTRY
PLANNING NEEDS TO HAPPEN THE
SECOND THAT THIS COMES IN.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY IF YOU
HAVE YOUTH WHO ARE SO FAR AWAY
FROM THEIR FAMILIES SO FAR AWAY
FROM THE COMMUNITIES.
THAT BRIDGE CAN'T BE BUILT IN A
WAY THAT IS TRULY SUPPORTIVE TO
ENSURE THAT THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE A CHANCE TO BECOME.
PART OF THOSE COMMUNITIES
LEADERS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES AND
THEY HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO DO SO.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M SUPER RALPH
FROM THE PACIFIC JUVENILE
DEFENDER CENTER.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS MOVE --
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN A
LONG TIME COMING AND WE TOTALLY.
AGREE WITH THE IDEA THAT THE
CULTURE CHANGE WILL BE IMPORTANT
BUT WE ALSO HOPE THAT IN THIS
BUDGET CYCLE.
THE LEGISLATURE WILL WILL
ENCOURAGE THE GOVERNOR TO DO
SOMETHING MORE WITH THIS -- DJJ
IS JUST A SMALL PART OF THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WE BELIEVE THAT BOTH THAT WHAT'S
BEEN SAID BEFORE THE QUESTIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED ABOUT
WHETHER.
THE SYSTEM SHOULD CONTINUE IN
ITS PRESENT INSTITUTIONAL FORM
THOSE ARE REALLY EXCELLENT
QUESTIONS AND WE HOPE THAT
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS.
SOMETHING MORE WILL BE SET INTO
MOTION TO PROVIDE IN A IN A
STAKEHOLDER FORMAT FOR THOSE
QUESTIONS TO BE FURTHER EXPLORED
FOR COUNTIES CAPACITY TO BE.
RESEARCHED FOR OUGHT TO HEAR
FROM THE COMMUNITY ABOUT WHAT
WOULD WORK BETTER FOR SERVING
THIS POPULATION AND WE ALSO
THINK THAT THE AGENCY IF IT'S
TRULY TO BE. TO TO FULFILL THE
GOVERNOR'S IDEA OF TRANSFORMING
JUVENILE JUSTICE WE NEED TO LOOK
AT THE REST OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE
IN THE SYSTEM WE NEED TO BRING
OVER THE OTHER FUNCTIONS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY AT THE SEC.
PUT THEM INTO THIS AGENCY AND
PROVIDE A POLICY VOICE FOR
JUVENILE JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA --
THE GROUP OF PEOPLE I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH MANY -- THEY'RE
VERY EXPERIENCED ADVOCATES
AROUND THE STATE WE HAVE
PREPARED SOME PROPOSED BUDGET
TRAILER LANGUAGE THAT WOULD DO
ALL OF THOSE THINGS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RAISED THIS
MORNING.
HAVING -- CALLING FOR DATA ON
BETTER OUTCOMES OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO USED IN THE SYSTEM
SO WE HAVE A A BASIS FOR
MEASUREMENT -- A CREATING A TASK
FORCE OR ADVISORY GROUP THAT
WOULD HAVE SOME MORE FORMAL ROLE
IN WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
ON AND ON AND EXPANDING SOMEWHAT
THE PURPOSE OF THE NEW AGENCY
AND SO WE HOPE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WILL LOOK AT THAT
LANGUAGE AND MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MAUREEN WASHBURN
WITH THE CENTER ON JUVENILE AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL -- TO MOVE DJJ OUT OF
THE CORRECTIONS DEPARTMENT AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
BUT WITH CONCERN THAT AT NAME
CHANGE ALONE.
WILL NOT DELIVER BETTER OUTCOMES
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE OR THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
WE RESERVE RECENTLY RELEASED A
REPORT -- LOOKING AT CONDITIONS
IN THE DJJ FACILITIES OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
AND WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT --
THEY REMAIN FUNDAMENTALLY ON
SAFE AND NON REHABILITATIVE.
BECAUSE OF FACTORS THAT ARE
ENDEMIC TO CONGREGATE
INSTITUTIONS THEY'RE LARGE THE
PRISON LIKE AND THEY'RE FAR FROM
YOUNG PEOPLE'S HOMES AND
FAMILIES.
AND THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT YOU
SIMPLY FARE BETTER WHEN THEY'RE
IN SMALLER SETTINGS THAT ARE
CLOSER TO HOME WHERE THEY CAN
MAINTAIN CONTACT WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
AND SO IN ADDITION TO THE MOVE.
WE WOULD HOPE TO SEE A PET IT
AND IT'S BEEN DISCUSSED TODAY
TOWARDS WHAT WE KNOW WORKS
SMALLER COMMUNITY BASED OPTIONS.
THAT ARE CLOSER TO THE COMMUNITY --
AND THERE'S HAS BEEN HAS BEEN
POINTED OUT PLENTY OF SPACE
AVAILABLE LOCALLY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TIFFANY WHITE
WITH A C. R. U. CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL HOWEVER
WE THINK THAT THERE'S FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS AND DISCUSSIONS
THAT NEED TO BE HAD TO ENSURE
THE SUCCESS OF THE TRANSITION.
AND WE WOULD ASK THAT ANY
CONVERSATIONS -- WHETHER IT BE A
STAKEHOLDER CONVERSATION OR TASK
FORCE THAT EMPLOYEES ARE ON HAVE
A SEAT AT THE TABLE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KATIE
DIXON ALMOST POLICY FELLOW WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN.
I AM HERE TODAY AS A SURVIVOR OF
DJJ FACILITIES.
I SPENT FIVE YEARS IN SEVEN
MONTHS INSIDE OF THE CAMERI --
FACILITY DOWN IN VENTURA. EIGHT
IS DEFINITELY A PRISON THERE'S
NO MISTAKING ABOUT IT.
THERE WAS NO THEIR
REHABILITATIVE GOING ON UP IN
THE AIR. FOR ME WHEN PEOPLE ASK
HOW IT WORKS.
WHAT I LOVE TO COMPARE IT TO IS
RYKER'S ISLAND?
WHEN I HEAR ABOUT RYKER'S ISLAND
I THINK HEY THOSE ARE THE THINGS
I WENT THROUGH?
WHEN I WAS A SEE YA THAT'S WHAT
IT WAS KNOWN WHEN I WAS THERE --
I WAS THERE WHEN THE FEDERAL
LAWSUIT STARTING WHEN THEY
TRANSITION FROM THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH AUTHORITY TO DJJ.
THE CONDITIONS ABSOLUTELY
DETERIORATED FURTHER NOTHING
CHANGED -- EXCEPT THAT IT GOT
WORSE WHAT I SAW CHANGE WAS MORE
OF A AN INFLUX OF PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATIONS THAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO FORCE UPON US -- JUST
THAT WAS LIKE THE MAIN CHANGE
THAT I'VE SEEN -- IS FAR AS I
THINK THE THE FOLKS HAD
MENTIONED AS FAR AS LIKE OUT
DATED DATA TO WORK WITH AGAIN.
SOME OF THE FOLKS A CJ CJ HAS A
FANTASTIC -- REPORT THAT THEY
AND THE OLD FEBRUARY TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TITLE ON MET
PROMISES I ENCOURAGE YOU TO GET
A HOLD OF IT IF YOU GUYS WE WE
SPOKE ABOUT THAT.
REPORT AT THE LAST HEARING WE
WERE HERE AT THE LAST HEARING
YOU SAY THE SAME THING THAT YOU
HAD OUTDATED INFORMATION.
YOU STILL HAVEN'T GOT A HOLD OF
AND MAKE PROMISES ALL YOU HAVE
TO DO IS ASK SOMEONE I'M PRETTY
SURE THEY CAN GET YOU A COPY --
YES SO I WANT TO MIRROR WHAT
EVERYONE ELSE SAID AS FAR AS CON
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED
TO BE HAD I REALLY LOVE THE
WOULD -- THE GUY SAID UP THERE
ABOUT THE STAKEHOLDER -- GROUP I
REALLY THINK WE NEED TO GET THAT.
PUT TOGETHER AND I REALLY
BELIEVE WE HAVE TO HAVE.
THE CBO'S AT AT THE TABLE WHEN
YOU GUYS ARE DISCUSSING HIS
MAJOR MOVING A RANGER IN A MAJOR
RESTRUCTURING AND REORGANIZATION
WE CAN GET THIS DONE WITH THE
EXPERTS.
YOU GUYS GOTTA HAVE SOMEONE IN
THERE WITH THE LIVED EXPERIENCE
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S HERE DOING
OR TRYING TO CHANGE IT AROUND
YOU CAN'T DO NOTHING WITH US
WITHOUT US AND WE STAND FIRM BY
DAY.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RENEE MANNER WITH THE
CENTER ON JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE I JUST WANT TO COME UP
HERE TO ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY OUR FELLOW
COMMUNITY MEMBERS -- WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE MOVE FROM
AT DJJ TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES -- BUT
WE DO RECOMMEND THAT MORE BE
DONE IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
THIS TRANSITION PROVIDES
MEANINGFUL REHABILITATION FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THIS NEW
STRUCTURE.
AND IDEALLY WE RECOGNIZE THAT A
LONG TERM PLAN NEEDS TO CONSIDER
COMMUNITY BASED ALTERNATIVES AND
I COMMUNITY FOCUS FOR YOU SEE TO
BE SERVED.
I AT THE COUNTY LEVEL -- BUT IN
THIS TRANSITION TO TO TO OF THE
DJJ TO HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WE WOULD HOPE THAT THE PROCESS
INCLUDE STAKEHOLDERS -- IN THE
COMMUNITY AND OTHER EXPERTS TO
ENSURE THAT THE TRANSITION I IS
SUCCESSFUL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S CLEAR BOUNDARY I
WAS HERE -- I WASN'T SEE WAY
WHEN IT FIRST BEGAN ITS NAME
CHANGE TO DJJ.
AND NOTHING.
REALLY CHANGED IN WITH THIS NAME
CHANGE I DON'T REALLY SEE THE
PROBLEMS THAT I SAW THEY'RE
CHANGING.
IT DOES I HOPE THAT THIS IS THE
FIRST STEP TO DISSOLUTION BACK
DOWN TO A COUNTY LEVEL AND
PERHAPS THE JUVENILES TO FEEL
SILLY THESE THERE COULD.
YOU KNOW GO UP TO TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF AGE AS C. WAY DOES.
THE PROBLEMS THAT I SAW THERE
WERE -- BEFORE I EVEN WHEN THEY
TOLD ME THAT THE SCHOOLS WERE.
POINTLESS AND IN FACT HORRIFIC
AND SO I GOT MY GED BEFORE I
WENT THERE AND I GOT INTO A
BUNCH OF OCCASIONAL PROGRAMS%
WHICH ARE STILL DRAWN TO THIS
DAY.
THEN THE LAST -- YOU KNOW WITH.
THE STAFF THERE'S JUST
RETRAINING THEM ISN'T GOING TO
HELP.
HOW THEY VIEW US I MEAN IT
DOESN'T CHANGE WHO THEY ARE AND
THERE AND SOME OF THEM WERE JUST
NEGATIVE?
AND TO BE JUST A NEGATIVE PERSON
AROUND KIDS IS.
YOU KNOW NOT HELPING THEM AT ALL
AND NO AMOUNT OF TRAINING IS
GOING TO CHANGE THAT.
SO THE STAFF NEEDS TO REALLY BE
REEVALUATED ALL TOGETHER ON WHO
CAN WORK WITH KIDS AND WHO'S
GOING TO BE HELPFUL WHEN THEY
WORK WITH THE CHILDREN.
THE LAST [inaudible]
WHEN I?
LEFT THERE I WENT INTO A HALFWAY
HOUSE AND I WAS ABLE TO FIND
EMPLOYMENT STARTS.
AT THE HELP ME SIGN UP FOR
SCHOOL AND THESE ARE ALL THINGS
THAT I DID BEFORE I WAS ALLOWED
TO GO HOME SO I HAD AS A SET
BASE I WAS AT A JOB WHERE I CAN
MAKE MONEY I GOT AN APARTMENT I
HAD I STARTED SCHOOL SO I COULD.
FURTHER MY EDUCATION AND ALL
THESE THINGS COULD BE DONE ON A
COUNTY LEVEL IF I WAS THAT SAFE
I'D SPENT MY WHOLE TIME THERE MY
LAST SIX MONTHS COULD HAVE BEEN
RESTRUCTURING LIKE HELL TO GET
OUT AND WHERE CAN GO AND WHAT I
CAN DO SO.
THIS IS ON A COUNTY LEVELS WILL
BE MUCH EASIER TO GET INVOLVED
WITH FOR LOW PROGRAMS OR THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR
WHEREVER ELSE YOU.
CHOOSE TO WORK OUT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RUTH
WITH MORE AND I'M HERE TODAY AS
THE GRANDMOTHER OF A YOUNG MAN
THAT WAS SENT -- TO THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM TO SEE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH AUTHORITY.
HE WAS TRIED AS AN ADULT AND I'M
HERE TO TELL YOU THAT THE IMPACT
THAT IT HAD HE'S HAD A REAL
STRUGGLE.
TRYING TO READJUST TO SOCIETY
BECAUSE OF THE PUNITIVE APPROACH.
THAT SIMPLER INSIDE THE CD THERE
WAS CALIFORNIA'S WITH ALREADY.
WHO IS NOW CDC ARE THEY COMBINE?
SO I WOULD SAY TO YOU I WOULD
ASK YOU AS NOT ONLY IS THE GRANT --
BUT IS THE TAXPAYER.
THE FEW WOULD STRONGLY CONSIDER
THIS PROPOSAL IN WHICH IT SEEMS
THAT YOU ARE.
AND IT'S REALLY.
REFRESHING TO SEE THAT IT'S
FINALLY.
BE AND RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE THEY HAVE EMOTIONAL
PROBLEMS IT IS.
THE PUNITIVE METHODS IT'S NOT
WORK THEY NEED.
SOME EMOTIONAL HEALING.
SO I JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS
MYSELF AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
A MINUTE AGO OKAY SELL -- I WORK
WITH COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESEARCHERS JUSTICE AND OAKLAND
ALAMEDA COUNTY -- SOUL I'M ONE
OF THE PRODUCTS I WAS GOING I
GREW UP IN JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
NOT SEE YA NOT DJJ HOURS --
SENTENCED TO ADULT PRISON AT THE
AGE OF SIXTEEN OR AYE SIR TWENTY
YEARS SO I CAME A LOT OF
EXPERIENCES FROM THAT KNOWLEDGE
ON THIS ISSUE -- AND I
APPRECIATE THE STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY GROUP AND I REALLY
ENCOURAGE -- THINKING OUTSIDE
THE BOX I APPRECIATE LOOKING OUT
MODELS AT THEIR OUT OF STATE.
BUT I THINK IN CALIFORNIA HERE
ARE THE CONVERSATIONS WERE
HAVING WE HAVE LEADERSHIP -- TO
CREATE A ROLE MODEL RIGHT TO FIX
CALIFORNIA.
ON A LOT OF THAT REALLY BRINGS
IN TO BRING IN THE PEOPLE AND
THE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE EXPERIENCE
TO DJJ SYSTEM TO SEE WHAT A
SYSTEM.
CORRECTION SYSTEMS AT A YOUNG
AGE -- WE ARE PEOPLE CLOSEST TO
THE PROBLEM AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I BELIEVE IN IS THAT
WE ALSO CLOSEST TO LUCIEN TO THE
SOLUTION.
DOESN'T EXCLUDE EVERYBODY ELSE
BUT I THINK ONE OF THE ISSUES --
THE ALL WE SEEN WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS WE HIRE CONSULTANTS.
THE HAVE ALL THIS EXPERIENCE
WITH SYSTEM RIGHT AND IT'S A
IT'S A GOOD THING RIGHT IT'S A
GOOD THING TO HAVE ALL INPUT.
BUT WHEN WE DO COVER
STAKEHOLDERS I BELIEVE THAT
THOSE ARE ALSO THE REYES CONSOLE
THAT WE CAN HAVE.
ON THESE ISSUES -- PEOPLE THAT
HAVE GONE THROUGH THESE
PROCESSES OF SEE WHY EIGHT OR
WORKING ON POLICY AND ARE HERE
PRESENTTODAY -- BUT I THINK
YOU'RE MOVING FORWARD I WANT TO
REALLY REALLY JUST -- EMPHASIZE
SOMETHING THAT OUR WHO ALWAYS
BLACK IN THE DEFINITION -- THAT
WERE -- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT USE
WE TALK ABOUT ADULTS -- YOU KNOW
YOUNG ADULTS WE HAVE ALL THESE
THINGS LIKE A THIRTEEN YEAR OLD
IS THE CHILD RIGHT AND AT THE
DESK.
WHO WE ARE PROVIDING SERVICES
FOR THOSE WHO WERE -- CONCERNED
ABOUT -- AND IF ANYBODY HERE HAS
CHILDREN BEST -- THIRTEEN THESE
ARE THE SAME AGE AS THE PEOPLE
OUR ANTI SYSTEMS RIGHT SO WE GOT
TO REALLY THINK ABOUT IT TO THAT
ERROR THAT LANDS.
ABOUT WHO THEY ARE AND CRIME AND
PUNISHMENT.
EVEN GETTING AWAY FROM THE
DEFINITION OF CRIME AND
PUNISHMENT.
SO I JUST WANT IS EMPHASIZED THE
HUMANITY.
IN THEM AND THE CHILDHOOD AND
THAT THEY ARE CHILDREN THAT DO
HAVE -- THE CAPACITY NINETY TO
REHABILITATE BUT TO EXCEL RIGHT
I THINK I'VE HEARD THAT LIKE
WHEN I JUST LOOKING.
TO HAVE PEOPLE JUST --
REHABILITATE BUT GET OUT AND
ACTUALLY BE PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS
OF SOCIETY TO HAVE SOMETHING --
TO GIVE GIVE BACK SUCH AS MYSELF
AS AN EXAMPLE -- HAVING SERVED
TWENTY YEARS IN PRISON -- FROM
THE AGE OF SIXTEEN SO I REALLY
SUPPORT THIS MOVE -- I DO
BELIEVE -- THAT IT'S IN THE
RIGHT STEP.
AND TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE ONE
ANOTHER IN THIS DIALOGUE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD -- AND BECAUSE
WE'RE ALL STAKEHOLDERS RIGHT
ACROSS THE COLORS IN THIS ISSUE
SIZE WE WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
AND PRONOUNCE HER SUPPORT.
MATA TERAKHIR CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WHERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND WE'D LIKE TO JOIN
THE CHORUS AS WELL.
OF ENSURING THAT THERE IS A
STRONG STREAK STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS SAYS.
THE PROPOSAL MOVES FORWARD AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SORT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ WITH THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. TO
MOVE DJJ -- IT IS CERTAINLY AN
APPROACH THAT WE RECOGNIZE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL -- DID YOU NOT
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS NOT WITHIN THE
ADULT CORRECTIONS SYSTEM IT IS I
AS A SEPARATE MODEL AND SO WE
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND AND SEE THE
BENEFITS TO THAT AND IN THIS
SHIFT -- PROVISION CHIEFS AND
AND IN CONCERT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND MANY OF THE
CHANGES THAT HAVE HAPPENED OVER
THE YEARS.
ON THAT THAT -- THE FOLKS HERE
BEEN A PART OF WE'VE REALLY SEEN
AN INCREDIBLE -- EVOLUTION IN
OUR JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AS
WAS MENTIONED WITH SIGNIFICANT --
AN HISTORIC DECLINES IN --
RESTORATIONS AND DETENTION RATES --
AND SO WE CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THIS AS KIND OF THE
NEXT PHASE OF THAT WE DO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE.
THE WONDERFUL TRAJECTORY IN
EVOLUTION -- THAT DJJ HAS TAKEN
ON BOTH WITH FERAL AND BEYOND TO
MAKE SOME REALLY SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES AND AND WORKING ON
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES ALL OF
WHICH WE THINK -- THIS PROPOSAL
HERE WILL CONTINUE -- TO ENHANCE
AS WE MOVE FORWARD -- I DO JUST
WANT TO REITERATE THAT -- BASED
ON CHANGES FROM THE LEGISLATURE
SEVERAL YEARS BACK -- COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS NOW WORK
VERY VERY CLOSELY WITH DJJ ON
THE RE ENTRY AND DISCHARGE OF
USE COMING OUT OF A DJJ ONTO
COUNTY PAROLE -- FOR WORKING
WITH YOUTH WE HAVE DONE
SIGNIFICANT WORK IN INVESTED A
LOT OF TIME AND ENERGY AND
WORKING WITH MISTER SUPPLE AND
AND HIS TEAM ON WHAT THAT RE
ENTRY LOOKS LIKE AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
THAT THOSE YOUTH ABOUT SITUATED
COMING BACK TO OUR COMMUNITIES
AND SO RECOGNIZING THAT.
THIS WOULD BE A SHIFT TO A NEW
STATE AGENCY WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THAT PROGRESS IS
MAINTAINED AND BUILT UPON AS
WELL IN TERMS OF THAT CONNECTION
FOR YOU COMING BACK TO THE
COMMUNITIES -- SO AGAIN WE
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL I THINK AS
AS YOU NOTED MADAM CHAIR THERE'S
A LOT OF COMPLEXITIES TO TO
LOOKING AT WORKING WITH ARGUE TO
WE HAVE -- IN IN THE SYSTEM IN
DJJ WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE AND
AND WOULD WANT TO BE A PART OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS -- AND AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE APPROACHING
THIS IN THE MOST THOUGHTFUL WAY
SO WE APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
TODAY LOOK FOR TO BE IN PART OF
IT FURTHER THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT.
ALL RIGHT SO I'M.
BELIEVING THEY ITEM OPEN.
AT THE WE HAD A GOOD DISCUSSION
AND REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATIONS AND THE DISCUSSION
WE HAD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW GO TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN THE STAFF
COMPLAINT.
IN FOR UNIT AND WE HAVE -- JOE
GALVIN WHO'S THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS WE
HAVE -- RAY WESLEY WHO'S OUR
INSPECTOR GENERAL THREE OF ERIC
SWANSON DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
FISCAL SERVICES -- MANAGER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO START WITH THE I
JEEZ FINDINGS OR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO START WITH OUR PROPOSAL
ITSELF REGISTERED YOUR PROPOSAL
OKAY.
THANKS ONCE AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF CDC OURS OFFICE OF FISCAL
SERVICES -- WE ARE REQUESTING.
NINE POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND AND FORTY SEVEN
POSITIONS IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY AN ON GOING. TO
IMPLEMENT A NEW REGIONAL MODEL
FOR REVIEWING INVESTIGATING AND
MAKE COMPLAINTS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT.
AS WELL AS REVISED CDC OURS
GRIEVANCE REVIEW PROCESS.
WITH ME TODAY'S JOE GALVIN WHO
IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS AND HE'S GOING
TO DESCRIBE OUR PROPOSAL.
SO WE'RE PROPOSING TO
RESTRUCTURE THE GRIEVANCE
PROCESS BY MOVING THE OFFICE OF
APPEALS -- ADAM DID DIVISIONS --
INTO THE DIVISION OF
CORRECTIONAL POLICY RESEARCH
INTERNAL OVERSIGHT AT FTA I
VISUAL TO THE DIVISION LITTLE
INSTITUTIONS.
AND MOVE THE STAFF OFFENDER
GRIEVANCE COMPLAINT INQUIRY
PROCESS INTO THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS.
AND BASED ON THE O. I. G.'S
RECOMMENDATIONS ESTABLISH
REGIONAL UNITS PERFORMING CORY'S
SPECIFICALLY IS FOR ASSOCIATED
THE STAFF IS KIND OF COMPLAINTS.
IT WILL BE STAFFED UP WITH IT
SAID A SIMILAR MODEL TO OUR
CURRENT OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS.
WITH -- FOLKS WHO WILL BE
CONDUCTING CORY'S OUTSIDE OF THE
INSTITUTIONAL PROCESS SO THEY
WILL HAVE A NEW CHAIN OF COMMAND.
INTRO FOR ALSO CONDUCTED A FACT
FINDING INAND INCREASE.
AND AUTO GENERATE INVESTIGATIONS
OF WARRANTED.
THE OFFICE OF THE APPEALS AGAIN
WOULD BE INDEPENDENT WILL HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO OVERTURN ANY.
DA GRIEVOUS DECISION.
AT THE INSTITUTIONAL LEVEL LEVEL
AS WELL AS TRAINING DESERVE DA
GRIEVANCES.
AND WITHIN -- THE DIVISION OF
CORRECTION POLICY RESURGENT
INTERNAL OVERSIGHT IS ALSO THE
OFFICE OF ARTS IN COURT
COMPLIANCE.
A NEW POSITION WAS CREATED THEIR
CHIEF RISK OFFICER ENTERPRISE
RISK MANAGEMENT -- AND THEY WILL
SERVE ALONG WITH THE OFFICE OF
ON OF COURSE THE PLANS TO HONOR
THE PROCESS TO DETERMINE THE
FIDELITY WITH THE RAGS.
AND USE PREDICTIVE ANALYTICS
SOFTWARE TO PREVENT -- FALLING
OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE WICKS --
I COULD HAVE HAD IT -- WHERE THE
CAR?
INSPECTOR GENERAL SPOKE FIRST
BUT SINCE WE ARE.
ACTING ON YOUR PROPOSAL I WANTED
YOU TO BUT SINCE WE HAVE HAD.
A J. LACK REQUESTED IN AUDITOR'S
REPORT.
ON THE WHOLE COMPLAINT PROCESS
AND CLEARLY THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL IS VERY INVOLVED IN THAT --
I OF COURSE ONE HERE FROM THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AS TO IT
CONCERNS RELATED TO WHETHER
YOU'RE PROPOSAL ADEQUATELY
ADDRESSES.
THE KINDS OF ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED.
IN THE AUDIT.
AND AT THAT I THINK MANY FOLKS
IN THE LEGISLATURE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT WE DO NOT HAVE AN OF
WE DO NOT HAVE.
THE COMPLAINT PROCESS.
THAT HAS INTEGRITY AS WELL HOW
SIMPLY I WOULD PUT IT.
SO -- OUR INSPECTOR GENERAL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M RE WESLEY I'M
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME HERE TODAY -- WE
HAVE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THE DEPARTMENT'S PLAN
THAT WAS -- PROVIDED TO YOU.
AND I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ACCEPTED OUR MAIN
RECOMMENDATION WHICH IS TO
REMOVE THE INQUIRY PROCESS FROM
THE INSTITUTION.
AND REGIONAL LIES THE PROCESS
UNDER DIFFERENT CHAIN OF COMMAND
I THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT --
UNDER THISPLAN THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR CONDUCTING THE
INCREASE.
THEY'VE ALSO ADOPTED OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR TRAINING FOR
THOSE WHO CONDUCT THE INQUIRIES --
WE FELT THAT -- THE MOTHER WITH
THE TRAINING AT THE INSTITUTION
WAS NON EXISTENT IN CONDUCTING
THE INCREASE WE RECOMMENDED.
SOME POST CERTIFIED TRAINING AND
THE DEPARTMENT HAS ACCEPTED THAT --
I BELIEVE THEY SHOULD CONSIDER A
RECOMMENDATION FOR AUDIO
RECORDING.
OF ALL THE INTERVIEWS THAT ARE
DONE IN THIS PROCESS.
WE OBSERVE THAT NONE OF THE
INCREASE.
WERE THE INTERVIEWS WERE
RECORDED SO ABSENT US BEING
THERE NO ONE WOULD HAVE KNOWN
WHAT HAPPENED IN THOSE
INTERVIEWS -- WE FOUND.
A LOT OF IRREGULARITIES AND HOW
THE INTERVIEWS WERE DONE AND
AGAIN IF WE HADN'T BEEN THERE.
NOBODY WOULD HAVE KNOWN.
OF THE PROPOSAL IS SET FORTH BY
THE DEPARTMENT PROVIDES FOR NO
INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT OF
CRITICAL DECISIONS.
BY THE INSTITUTION HIRING
AUTHORITY OR BY THE A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR.
I BELIEVE INDEPENDENT
TRANSPARENT EXTERNALOVERSIGHT
OF ALL EXPENSE OF THE PROCESS.
IS THE ONLY WAY THAT THE PUBLIC
WILL HAVE FAITH IN THE CHANGES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS MAKING.
APPROPRIATE IMPLEMENTING
REGULATIONS AND POLICIES WILL
ALSO BE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO
THE SUCCESS OF THE NEW PROCESS
WE HAVE NOT.
BEEN ENGAGED BY THE DEPARTMENT
YET ON THEIR PLANS FOR THOSE
IMPLEMENTING.
POLICIES AND REGULATIONS -- I
BELIEVE THAT THE POP THAT THE
PUBLIC NEEDS TO SEE HOW THIS IS
ROLLED OUT FOR IMPLEMENTATION
THE PUBLIC NEEDS TO SEE IF THE
IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS ARE
FAITHFUL. TO THE SOLUTIONS.
OUR OUR FAITHFUL SOLUTIONS TO
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE IDENTIFIED.
I WOULD NOTE THAT AT THIS POINT
WITH REGARD TO THE STAFF
COMPLAIN PROCESS.
THE AG HAS NO FURTHER STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT --
WE CONTINUE TO WE DO CONTINUE TO
HAVE DIALOGUE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT REAL.
LEADERSHIP REGARDING THE PROCESS
IN OUR RECOMMENDATIONS AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD.
AS THIS POSTAL GOES FORWARD TO
HAVING FURTHER DISCUSSIONS.
ON HOW THE DEPARTMENT IMPLEMENTS.
SO SOME OF THE POINTS THAT YOU
RAISED WERE.
DEFINITELY RAISED IN THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT.
ABOUT AN THE LACK OF THE
INDEPENDENCE THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY.
THE THERE WERE A WHOLE VARIETY
OF THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND SIR -- INSPECTOR GENERAL YOU
JUST REFERENCE THAT THE OFFICE
HAS NO STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO
PROVIDE THAT OVERSIGHT.
DID THE OFFICE IN THE PAST HAVE
SUCH STATUTORY AUTHORITY YES --
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN OUR
OFFICE HAD DISCRETIONARY
AUTHORITY TO AUDIT OR MONITOR
ANY ISSUES THAT.
THAT CAME TO OUR ATTENTION THAT
WE THOUGHT NEEDED TO BE LOOKED
AT BUT WAS THE COMPLAINT PROCESS
THE SAME AT THAT POINT WE SO WAS
IT A SIMILAR COMPLAINT PROCESS
WITH INTERNALLY.
TO A C. C. R. BUT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL OFFICE COULD JUST
INVOLVE ITSELF.
IF IT CAME TO THEIR IF THERE
SEEM TO BE A WHATEVER PROBLEM OR
A IN ORDER THE WORD TO USE BUT
YEAH YES -- DO WE HAVE HAD.
AS YOU KNOW OUR STATURE REQUIRES
US TO TO HAVE A A METHOD FOR THE
PUBLIC TO COMPLAIN.
SINCE I COMPLAIN.
OKAY SO OVER THE YEARS WE HAD
GOTTEN COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE THE
STAFF COMPLAINT PROCESS.
AND OUR RECOURSE WAS SIMPLY TO
TELL THE DEPARTMENT WE HAVE THIS
COMPLAINT YOU GUYS ARE TAKE A
LOOK AT IT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
AUTHORITY TO BUT IN THE PAST YOU
COULD HAVE DONE IN THE PAST WHEN
WE GOT THOSE COMPLAINTS WE COULD
HAVE LOOKED AT THEM -- PRIOR --
TO STATUE CHANGE IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN SO LET SOME.
JUST FOR HYPOTHETICAL SAKE.
LET'S SEE -- WELL LET'S GO BACK
TO THAT PASSED.
EVEN WITHOUT AUTHORITY.
DO YOU FEEL THAT THE SO EVEN IF
THAT OF THE WORD EXISTED.
IS THE COMPLAINT PROCESS CHANGES
THAT ARE BEING RECOMMENDED NOW --
ADEQUATE JUST.
FOR A COMPLETE PROCESS SEPARATE
FROM.
THE ABILITY OF AN INDEPENDENT
ENTITY TO ALSO -- INTERVENE.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE MAKING
GOOD PROGRESS IN.
IN FIXING SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
WITH THE STAFF COMPLAINT PROCESS.
STRUCTURALLY I DO I HAVE SOME --
AND WE DISCUSSED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT SOME OF OUR CONCERNS
WITH.
THEIR SPECIAL GRIEVANCES VERSUS
THERE ARE STAFF COMPLAIN
GRIEVANCES.
BECAUSE THERE IS SO MUCH OVERLAP
THAT -- AGAIN I THINK I NEED TO
SEE HOW THEY IMPLEMENT.
THEIR SOLUTION BUT IT DOESN'T
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE TO ME THAT.
THESE SPECIAL GRIEVANCES WOULD
BE CARVED OUT WHEN THEY ARE
ESSENTIALLY STAFF MISCONDUCT
THERE JUST OF A DIFFERENT ILK
THERE -- THE THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT KINDS OF COMPLAINTS
OR THE USE OF FORCE --
COMPLAINTS WHERE -- WERE WERE
PRISONER WOULD.%
WOULD COMPLAIN THAT HE WAS THE
VICTIM OF UNNECESSARY OR
UNREASONABLE FORCE.
IN A CAR THOSE OUT FROM OTHER
STAFF MISCONDUCT SUCH AS HE WAS
DISCOURTEOUS TO ME OR IN A
PROPERLY SEARCH MYSELF I DON'T
SEE THE DIFFERENCE IN IT IT'S
STAFF BEHAVIOR.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
PROPOSAL THAT ADDRESSES THE
STAFF BEHAVIOR HOMOGENEOUS LEE.
HER -- SO MY QUESTION CAESAR'S
JUST WHETHER IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF OF THESE PROPOSED CHANGES FOR
THE STAFF COMPLAINT -- WAS THE
DID YOU -- WAS EITHER THE OFFICE
OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
INVOLVED OR ASKED TO REVIEW.
I THINK -- JOE AND I ARE UNAWARE
OF THE DISCUSSIONS THAT TAKE
PLACE I'VE I HAVE HEARD THEY DID
TAKE PLACE BUT WE WERE NOT
INVOLVED ARE PART PROPOSAL
ITSELF WAS MEANT TO BE SORT OF A
TO TO PUT A GOOD FAITH EFFORT IN.
IN TRYING -- TO MEET THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE REPORT
ITSELF [inaudible]
OKAY OKAY -- CENTER MORE LIKE
DID YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON
THIS.
I'M LOOKING AT MY TRUSTEE IPHONE
I'M NOT FINDING THE STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO SO I APOLOGIZE IF I
IF I MEAN IS ARE A MY APOLOGIES
I USE THE STATE ORDER BECAUSE
I'M STUCK ON THAT'S A VERY GOOD
POINT.
THE STATE AUDITOR DID THE AUDIT
ON THE REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
IT IS THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
THEY DID THE REPORT ON THE
COMPLAINT PROGRAM SO THAT WAS Y
HERE.
I GET TOO MANY REPORTS IN
AGENCIES IN MY FOREHEAD.
BUT VERY GOOD QUESTION -- CATION
BECAUSE WE REALLY APPRECIATE IS
ARE LIKE WHAT IS SKINNER TALKING
ABOUT YEAH SHE WAS -- OFF OKAY.
BUT THERE IS A REPORT BROUGHT
COPIES IF YOU'D LIKE A COPY OF
THE REPORT GREAT OKAY.
SO WHY SHOULD TELL ME.
MISTER WESLEY -- A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE OFFICE WELL IT SEEMS
LIKE IT'S BEEN AROUND FOR LEAST
MORE THAN A DECADE -- YES SO OUR
OFFICE WAS FIRST ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR AND IT WAS
A SUB DIVISION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS -- THE DUTIES
WERE TO PERFORM SOME AUDITS OF
REVIEW POLICY AND PERFORM --
MANAGEMENT REVIEW AUDITS.
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AS A
RESULT OF SOME LEGISLATIVE
HEARINGS REGARDING CONCERNS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT -- THE
OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
WAS MOVED OUTSIDE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
WAS MADE AN INDEPENDENT STATE
AGENCY.
WITH JURISDICTION FOR OVERSIGHT.
OF THE DEPARTMENT.
AT THAT TIME.
A IT WAS AT THAT TIME THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WAS GIVEN
DISCRETION TO CONDUCT AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS THAT WAS ONE OF
THE ISSUES IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT WAS THAT -- THERE WAS SOME
CONCERN THAT THE SECRETARY.
WOULD EXERT UNDUE INFLUENCE ON
THE OFFICE.
AND NOT ALLOW CERTAIN ARTISTS
ARE INVESTIGATIONS TO GO FORWARD.
SO WE WERE GIVEN -- DISCRETION
TO DO THOSE AUDITS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR IN RESPONSE
TO THE FEDERAL COURT IN MADRID
CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT -- THE O.
I. G.'S JURISDICTION WAS
EXPANDED. TO INCLUDE OVERSIGHT
OF THE DEPARTMENT'S INTERNAL
AFFAIRS INVESTIGATION AND
DISCIPLINE PROCESS -- THAT.
THAT STATUTORY SCHEME REMAINED
IN EFFECT UNTIL.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WHEN.
THERE WAS LEGISLATION WHICH
RESTRUCTURED THE FUNCTIONS OF
THE AGENCY THE ORGY BUDGET WAS
CUT BY 45%.
AND OUR STAFFING WAS ALSO
REDUCED BY ABOUT HALF.
OF OUR DISCRETION TO CONDUCT
AUDITS INVESTIGATIONS WAS
ELIMINATED AND OUR STATUTORY
DUTIES WERE REALLY REDUCED TO A
DELINEATED LIST.
OF FUNCTIONS WHICH INCLUDED.
A STATUTORY AUTHORITY FOR
INSPECTIONS OF THE PRISON
MEDICAL SYSTEM.
WE NOW ONLY PERFORM THE DUTIES
DESCRIBED.
IN THE STATUTE AND I DO HAVE A
HANDOUT FOR YOU IF YOU'D LIKE --
FOR THAT'S A SHORT.
OF WHAT WE DO AND IT HAS OUR
DUTIES -- LAID OUT FOR YOU SO
YOU WERE YOUR EMBEDDED BUT
INDEPENDENT.
WE ARE NOT EMBEDDED SO I DO NOT
REPORT TO THE SECRETARY FOR
EXAMPLE OKAY -- I'M IT WANTED BY
THE GOVERNOR FOR AN INDEPENDENT
SIX YEAR TERM THAT IS.
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE -- AND I
CAN BE REMOVED FOR CAUSE BUT BUT
THAT'S IT -- THE I'M COMPLETELY
INDEPENDENT.
OF THE DEPARTMENT AND IN FACT
INDEPENDENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WERE KIND OF LIKE THE
LOOK OF THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
WHERE AN ORPHAN.
SO DON'T REPORT TO THE GOVERNOR
AND ALL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE DON'T REPORT TO THE
COURTS -- WE HAVE THIS KIND OF A
UNIQUE PROCESS WHERE WE ENGAGE
WITH ALTHOUGH STAKEHOLDERS.
BUT BUT THERE'S NO REPORTING
RELATIONSHIP.
AND YOUR SCOPE IS RATHER NARROW
NOW IT IS [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
YOUR FOCUS IS TO TRY AND
CORRECTING CENTER [inaudible]
NOT [inaudible]
FUNCTIONING PROPERLY.
AS WRITE A REPORT AND OF COURSE
YOU GAVE ME A NICE THICK REPORTS
SIDE.
OF TRYING TO READ IT.
ON THE FLIGHTTHE OTHER THE
OTHER DOCUMENT I GAVE YOU IS A
IS A SUMMARY OF THE REPORT SO
IT'S IT'S LIKE HIGHLIGHT.
OF YOUR QUE GOT IT -- AND THIS
IS SORT OF ROCKER QUESTION BUT
AND BEING OTHER MYSELF FOR ME
WOULD YOU.
WHO WOULD YOU LET ME KNOW?
DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'RE BEING
FULFILLED AND AND AND THAT
YOU'RE.
PROVIDING A SERVICE THAT'S
BENEFICIAL O THE TAXPAYERS OF
THE STATE WELL I THINK FOR THOSE
DELINEATED -- ISSUES THAT WERE
THAT WE ARE THAT WE HAVE
JURISDICTION I THINK WE DO WE
PROVIDE -- WE PROVIDED A GOOD
SERVICE I THINK -- WE PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY -- WHAT GETS LOST
HIS THOSE ISSUES THAT ARISE
WHERE THEY DON'T FALL WITHIN OUR
DELINEATED STATUTORY AUTHORITY
SO FOR EXAMPLE -- AS I NOTED
BEFORE WE HAVE OUR STATURE
REQUIRES US TO MAINTAIN.
A EIGHT HUNDRED OF PHONE LINE
AND A WEBSITE IN WAYS FOR THE
PUBLIC AND INMATES TO CONTACT US --
IF THEY HAVE COMPLAINTS WE
RECEIVE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
COMPLAINTS A MONTH.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE.
ARE NOT WITHIN OUR JURISDICTION
TO REALLY GO DO ANYTHING ABOUT
WHAT WE DO WITH THOSE IS --
FIRST OF ALL WE TELL INMATES OF
THEY HAVE COMPLAINTS.
AND THEY HAVE NOT COMPLETED
THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE REMEDIES
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT YOU NEED
TO DO THAT FIRST BECAUSE THERE'S
REALLY NOTHING WE CAN DO UNLESS
THERE'S A FINAL DECISION.
SECONDLY IF THEY HAVE COMPLETED
THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE REMEDIES
AND WE STILL THINK THERE IS AN
ISSUE.
THAT I CAN GOING GAUGE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND SAY LOOK WE GOT
THIS THIS IS NOT RIGHT WE WOULD
LIKE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT IT.
AND THEY CAN TELL US -- YEAH
WE'LL TAKE CARE OF THAT OR THEY
TOLD US IN THE PAST -- THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING WE'RE GOING TO
LOOK AT AND YOUR SCOPE IS BEEN
NARROW YOUR STAFF HAS BEEN
REDUCED.
YOU'RE STILL PROVIDING.
THE APPROPRIATE SERVICES BASED
ON YOUR MANDATE -- AND I I WOULD
ASSUME THEN THAT YOU DON'T WANT
TO EXPAND YOUR SCOPE BECAUSE
THAT WOULD REQUIRE ASKING FOR
MORE EMPLOYEES.
BEFORE SCOPE WERE EXPANDED I
WOULD NEED MORE PEOPLE TO DO THE
WORK -- WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
CALLS THAT YOU GET THAT?
YOU CAN'T ADDRESS THAT GOES.
TO WELL WE RIGHT BACK WE FIRST
OF ALL WE ANSWER EVERYONE OF
THOSE COMPLAINTS WE GOT.
AND WHEN WE GET TO AN IMPASSE
WHERE THERE'S NOTHING FURTHER WE
CAN DO WE SUGGEST TO THEM THAT
THEY CONTACT THEIR THERE
LEGISLATORS -- THAT THEY CONTACT
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE -- WE
RECOMMEND IS A LEGISLATOR DO
HELP ME OUT BEFORE THEY CALL.
WELL I GET THE I. THEM THEN WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT.
AND IT'S HAPPENED SEVERAL TIMES
I GET A CALL FROM THE
LEGISLATORS OFFICE STAFFER
USUALLY.
WHO SAYS HEY WE GOT THIS
CONSTITUENT COMPLAINT WHAT'S
GOING ON I LET THEM KNOW?
AND THEN THEY CAN ENGAGE THE
DEPARTMENT THEY CAN.
THEY CAN DO THE THINGS THAT YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO -- AND
IT'S REALLY OUT OF MY IT'S OUT
OF MY PURVIEW AT THAT POINT IF
SO THEN HAVE YOU SENSE THE NEED
THAT YOU NEED TO EXPAND YOUR
SCOPE AND NEED MORE STAFFING AND
HAVE YOU EVER APPROACH TO
LEGISLATOR TO TRY AND PURSUE
THAT IN A BUDGET BILL OR WE HAVE.
HAD DISCUSSIONS IN THE PAST --
THERE WAS NOT.
OF AN APPETITE TO DO THAT -- I
THINK THE LAST TIME THAT WE
ACTUALLY HAD THOSE DISCUSSIONS
WITH MY PREDECESSOR OF BACK IN
200-013-2000 -- FOURTEEN WHEN
THERE WAS AN ISSUE AT HIGH
DESERT STATE PRISON THE US
SENATE PRO TEM.
REQUESTED.
UNDER OUR STATUTE THEY CAN
REQUEST US TO GO LOOK AT
SOMETHING THEY REQUESTED US. TO
REPORT.
THERE WERE -- THINKS THAT WE
FOUND -- AND THE DEPARTMENT WAS
RESPONSIVE AND WE NOTED THAT --
IT WOULD BE NICE AND WE TALK TO
FOLKS ABOUT IT WOULD BE NICE TO
BE ABLE.
TO TAKE THAT ACTION BEFORE IT
GOT TO THE LEVEL OF THE THIS THE
SENATE -- BUT AT THAT POINT
THERE WAS REALLY NO APPETITE. TO
DO THAT AND WE WHERE A CREATURE
OF OUR STATUTE SO WE DO WHAT
WE'RE WHAT WE'RE REQUIRED TO DO
SO WHERE IS YOUR VETTING.
STAGE THE STATE AUDITOR GETS.
TO PRESENT IN FRONT OF WHAT WE
CALL J. LACK THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE.
AUDIT COMMITTEE DO YOU HAVE A
SIMILAR.
THE SO THEN YOU JUST PREPARE
REPORT AND WHERE DOES IT GO.
WELL WE SO WHEN WE REQUESTED.
TWO OF TO DO A REVIEW IT'S
CALLED WE PREPARE THE REPORT AND
WE PROVIDE IT TO THE TO THE
ENTITY THAT HAS REQUESTED.
THE THE REVIEW AND THEN WE
POSTED IT'S A PUBLIC REPORT SO
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO IS PUBLIC
SO WE POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE.
AND WE CAN ENGAGE WE WE DO
ENGAGE WITH STAKEHOLDERS SO --
THE DEPARTMENT OF COURSE HAS
LOTS OF CONTACT WE HAVE ONGOING
CONTACT WITH THE DEPARTMENT --
WE HAVE ONGOING CONTACT WITH THE
PRISON LAW OFFICE THEY'RE VERY
ACTIVE -- THE RECEIVER'S OFFICE
OF ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
DEAL IN THE ISSUES THAT WE LOOK
AT WE WE STAY ENGAGED THE THE
DIFFERENCE IS THAT.
WE ARE MORE REACTIVE THAN WE ARE
A PROACTIVE SO -- IF -- IF I SAW
SOMETHING THAT I THOUGHT.
WAS REALLY SERIOUS AND NEED TO
BE LOOKED AT I WOULD GO TO THE
SENATE PRO TEM'S OFFICE OR THE
SPEAKER THE ASSEMBLY OR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
OF BUT OFTEN TIMES THE ISSUES
THE BUBBLE UP.
OUR OUTSIDE OUR PURVIEW THE WE
DON'T EVEN HAVE VISIBILITY ON
THEM BECAUSE OF I DON'T HAVE THE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO EVEN LOOK
AT HAV YOU LOOK BACK.
ON YOUR REVIEWS AND QUANTIFIED
THEM THAT THE FOLLOWING.
REPORTS RESULTED IN THE
FOLLOWING.
MODIFICATIONS CHANGES OR
WHATEVER TO MANAGEMENT OR TO
POLICIES PROCEDURES WHICH
GENERATED A COST SAVINGS OF AXE.
WE DO THAT -- ONE OF OUR
MANDATES IS TO YEARLY TO AN
ANNUAL REPORT THAT SUMMARIZES.
THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE AND IN
THE PAST YEAR AND PROVIDE THAT
KIND OF INFORMATION -- I THINK
MY PREDECESSOR GONE AWAY FROM
THAT A LITTLE BIT -- BUT WE HAVE.
OF WE RE DEDICATED TO THAT AND
WE JUST PUBLISHED IN FACT OUR OF
IN A REPORT WHICH TALKED ABOUT
ALL OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
IN THIS YEAR.
ARE YOU SAVING THE STATE
MULTIPLES OF YOUR DEPARTMENT
COSTS BY BELIEVE SO YES SO.
I THINK  IT IS A GOOD EXAMPLE
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WE DID
THIS REPORT.
WAS BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT AND
THE PRISON LAW OFFICE HAD COME
THE LAGER LAGERS HEADS OVER --
THIS STAFF COMPLAINT PROCESS.
AND I WAS INVITED INTO A
CONVERSATION WITH -- THE
SECRETARY TO TIMES COCHRAN AND
DON SPECTER OF THE PLO THEY WERE
MEETING THEY ASKED ME TO COME
OVER.
AND DON WAS.
GETTING READY TO FILE A CLASS
ACTION LAWSUIT ON THE APPEALS
PROCESS.
AND SCOTT ASKED ME TO TAKE A
LOOK AT IT WOULD WE BE WILLING
IF THEY INVITED US IN BECAUSE I
DON'T HAVE ANY JURISDICTION TO
DO THAT WOULD WE BE WILLING TO
GO TAKE A LOOK AT IT AND GIVE
THE DEPARTMENT AN INDEPENDENT
LOOK AT WHAT WAS GOING ON SO.
WE AGREED TO DO THAT.
I THINK AS A RESULT OF THAT PLO
BACKED OFF OF THEIR PLANNED
LAWSUIT AND JUST IN THAT ONE
INSTANCE ALONE.
THE ATTORNEYS FEES PROBABLY
EXCEED WHAT OUR BUDGET IS.
SO THEN -- IT IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THE SECRETARY AND YOU
SHOULD HAVE A BETTER
RELATIONSHIP.
IF I WERE THE SECRETARY.
YOU BE LIKE A MANAGEMENT.
TOOL I COULD USE THAT TERM
SOMEONE THAT'S GOING TO HELP ME
MAKE THE DEPARTMENT BETTER WHY
WHY ISN'T THERE.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO GET THE
IMPRESSION THAT WE HAVE A BAD
RELATIONSHIP PARTED SAY THAT I I
WOULD SAY IF I WERE I'D.
I'D BE WORKING WITH YOU TO SAY
HEY WOOD.
WE WERE CAN I WORK AND I DIRECT
USE SO THAT I CAN IMPROVE MY
DEPARTMENT.
WE MEET.
ONCE A MONTH REGULARLY AND THEN
AND THEN I ALSO HAVE PROBABLY
WEEKLY PHONE CALLS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT BUT THEIR FOCUS IS
NOT ON HAVING US DO THINGS BUT
MORE -- ARE YOU SEEING THINGS
GOING TO GET US IN TROUBLE.
AND AND SO SOME THINGS WE CAN
HELP HIM OUT WITH SOME THINGS WE
CAN'T.
AND AND SO MADAM CHAIR -- WE HAD
THE JOY OF BUT WHEN I BECAME A
SUPERVISOR FOR THE COUNTY WE HAD --
JUST SOME ISSUES AT THE JAIL I
MEAN I WALKED IN THE LAWSUIT
CLOSE SESSION I WALKED INTO A AN
INMATE THAT WAS MURDERED BY
INMATES WILD.
SH THE DEPUTIES JUST SORT OF
WATCH TV AND YOU KNOW WAS.
IT WAS REALLY A GREAT EXPERIENCE
NOT -- BUT WE DEVELOPED AN
OFFICE OF INDEPENDENT REVIEWS OR
EUROPE NATIONALS ARE KIND OF
CLOSE.
WE WERE MODELED AFTER THE OFFICE
OF INDEPENDENT REVIEW IN LOS
ANGELES CHAIR WITH MICHAEL G.
WITH WITH MICHEL CHEN ARE GOING
CHEN OCTOBER YEAH SO WE HAD THE
SAME.
SORT OF APPROACH.
THEIR ORIGINAL MODEL BEFORE WE
STRIPPED THAT WAS THE ORIGINAL
MODEL BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE
STRIPPED MUCH THE AUTHORITY OF
THE IT OKAY.
THANKS SO I I'M I'M LEARNING BUT
I'VE GOT SOME.
HISTORICAL CONTEXT THE DOCTOR TO
WORK WITH.
THE INDIVIDUAL WE HIRED SUPER I
REALLY ENJOYED WORKING WITH HIM --
BUT SINCE I'VE LEFT -- SOME
THINGS CAME UP THAT WERE
DISCOVERED.
THAT SOMEHOW THE O. I. R. HADN'T
DISCOVERED FIRST AND SO I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOUR
SECRETARY IS SAYING.
HAVE YOU FOUND SOMETHING THAT
WOULD CAUSE NONE OF US LIKE
SURPRISES RECORD SO SO YOU'RE
SORT OF LIKE THAT.
SINCE YOU KNOW FRONT LINE SAY
OKAY YOU IDENTIFY LET'S GET IN
FRONT OF IT BEFORE IT HAPPENS SO --
APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWERING MY
QUESTIONS MISTER WESLEY IN.
I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU IF
THERE'S MORE WE CAN DO.
TO ASSIST YOU TO MAKE THE
DEPARTMENT BETTER THAT THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S HOW WE SHOULD
BEGIN SPITTLE DIME TO MAKE A
QUARTERS MY MOTHER WOULD ALWAYS
SAY.
SO I CAN BE OF ASSISTANCE IN
THAT REGARD PLEASE LET ME KNOW
THANK YOU AND WE'RE IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR YOU'D LIKE
FURTHER BRIEFING FROM US WOULD
BE HAPPY TO COME OVER AND AND
AND PROVIDE THAT FOR YOU.
WELL I JUST PAUL JR IS A THIS IS
A MASSIVELY BIG STATE AND I'M.
HERE FOR MY FOURTH YEAR AND I'M
STILL LEARNING EVERY DAY WHICH
IS ON WHICH IS GREAT BUT IT'S
KIND OF SCARY TO THE LEARNING
CURVE JUST KEEPS.
GOING SO FORGIVE ME FOR NOT
KNOWING EVERYTHING RIGHT AWAY
AND FOR ALLOWING ME TO ASK A LOT
OF THESE.
BASIC QUESTION -- I'M GRATEFUL
FOR THE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU M.
SENATOR AND THEY THEY WERE VERY
GOOD QUESTIONS AND WHEN I AND
APOLOGIES TO EVERYONE THAT I
CITED THEIR OWN REPORT BUT I
READ THIS REPORT.
IN IN READING IT SO I WAS IN THE
LEGISLATURE NOT WIN IN THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL WAS
ESTABLISHED BUT IN.
TWENTY ELEVEN WHEN THE TOWERS
WERE MODIFIED.
AND AT THAT POINT.
I WAS IN ON BUDGET COMMITTEE N.
ARE PROBABLY DIDN'T ASK A LOT OF
QUESTIONS AS TO YOU KNOW WHY WE
ARE DOING SO AND TO WHAT BENEFIT
THAT WOULD.
AND IN THE YEARS PAST.
AS I HAVE.
IF WE THINK ABOUT THE AUDITOR.
DID THE STATE AND THE O. I. G.
EIGHT WHICH WERE ESTABLISHED FOR
SEMI SIMILAR PURPOSES NOT
EXACTLY THE SAME.
BUT SEMI SIMILAR.
ORIGINALLY THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL HAD SOME
COMPARABLE AUTHORITIES TO THE
STATE AUDITOR IN TERMS OF BEING
ABLE.
TO GET ACCESS TO INFORMATION.
YOU KNOW WE WE EXPECT
[inaudible]
TERM.
WE DON'T EXPECT IT'S EVEN IN OUR
STATUTE THAT IF THE STATE
AUDITOR'S AUDITING YOU YOU GOT
TURN EVERYTHING OVER.
AND NOW.
IT'S NOT MY I SHOULD SAY MY
IMPRESSION IS THAT OUR OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL IN OUR
DEPARTMENT HAVE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP.
BUT IF WE THINK THAT THE PURPOSE
OF IT WAS TO GIVE TO CREATE AN
ENTITY THAT REALLY HAD THE IN.
INDEPENDENCE TO DO THAT KIND OF
REVIEW FOR US BECAUSE WE WERE.
JUST LIKE WHY WE HAVE A STATE
AUDITOR.
IS NONE OF US ARE PERFECT AND IT
ISN'T EVEN AN ASSUMPTION THAT
ANY AGENCY IS TRYING TO HIDE
ANYTHING IT'S MORE THAT.
WE WE BECOME PART OF THE CULTURE
OF OUR OF OUR OPERATIONS IN IT'S
SOMETIMES HARDER FOR US TO SEE
WHEN THERE ARE FLAWS.
AND SO FOR ME WHEN I READ THIS
REPORT.
I THUGHT WHOA.
THIS THE NOT JUST THAT SOME OF
THE COMPLAINT PROCESS SEES WERE
REALLY IN ADEQUATE.
BUT THAT.
WE DO WE NO LONGER HAD A
SITUATION.
WHERE OUR OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL?
COULD GET THE INFORMATION HAT
IT NEEDED.
OR COMPEL CERTAIN TYPE OF
CHANGES AND I THOUGHT YOU KNOW
WE SHOULD REVISIT THAT WE SHOULD
REALLY LOOK AT IT NOWTHE BCP
BEFORE US.
DOES NOT INCLUDE RESTORING SOME
OF THE AUTHORITY THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S OFFICE
ORIGINALLY HAD BUT FOR EXAMPLE
THE ORIGINAL STATUTE INCLUDED A
MANDATE.
THAT THE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL COULD INDEPENDENTLY CAN
CHECK NOT QUITE IN FAMILIES
STILL HAVE TO HAVE SOME APPROVAL
BUT AUDITS AND INVESTIGATIONS.
AND WAS OUR REQUIREMENT THAT THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
CONDUCT FACILITY OPERATION
REVIEWS SO THERE WERE VERY S.
BUT THE WARRANTIES THAT THE
OFFICE USED TO HAVE.
IN BY BEING THAT IT WOULD BE
VERY WELL WORTH OUR WHILE.
TO CONSIDER WHICH ONES WE SHOULD
BE THINKING OF TO RESTORE.
SO THAT WE HAVE THE TYPE OF
INDEPENDENCE.
THAT WE WOULD WANT.
AND SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT I AM
VERY INTERESTED IN.
IN -- IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
I'M RECOMMENDING THAT WE HOLD
THE ITEM OPEN SO THAT WE CAN
TALK THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT.
THOSE POSSIBILITIES.
AND ALSO SO WE CAN SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL TWEAKING
TO THE RECOMMENDED -- COMPLAINT
REVIEW CHANGES OUR COMPLAINT
PROCESS CHANGES.
IN THERE ARE I DID SEE THAT
THERE DEFINITELY IMPROVEMENTS IN
TERMS OF WHAT CDC ARE IS
RECOMMENDING -- BUT I'VE.
BUT INDEPENDENTLY I HAD NOTED.
THAT THERE WERE.
IN THE FLOW CHART.
THE ISSUE OF SEPARATE PROCESS
SEES FOR SPECIAL GRIEVANCES.
SEEM -- TO I WASN'T SURE REALLY
THE BENEFIT OF THAT.
AND THERE WERE JUST SOME
QUESTIONS LIKE THAT WHICH BEFORE
I'D EVEN ASK THEM.
THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL RAISE SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES SO I THINK IT'S WORTH IT
FOR US TO LOOK AT THAT A LITTLE
MORE AND ALSO LOOK AT WHETHER WE
WANT.
TO RESTORE A FEW OF THESE --
MANDATES THAT WERE IN THE
ORIGINAL STATUTE [inaudible]
LA OF THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE
DO HAVE COMMENTS ON THIS
PROPOSAL -- KAELIN O'NEILL AT
THE LA OKAY AT WE WE RAISE TWO
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL THE
FIRST IS WHAT THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
THAT'S BEING REQUESTED.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE PROPOSAL
WOULD REDUCE WORKLOAD FOR PRISON
BASED STAFF THAT ARE CURRENTLY
TASKED WITH.
DOING ENQUIRIES INTO STAFF
COMPLAINTS AND BY SHIFTING THAT
WORKLOAD TO THESE NEW REGIONAL
TEAMS UNDER THE OFFICE OF THE
TURN INTERNAL AFFAIRS -- THE
PROPOSAL WOULD -- WORK AT REDUCE
AS I SAID WORKLOAD FOR THOSE
PRISON MAY STAFF AND WHAT WE
THINK WHEN I SHOP IN THE FORM OF
REDUCED.
OVERTIME SPENDING AND SO WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE --
REDUCE THE REQUESTED FUNDING
AMOUNT AND IF THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION WE'D BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ESTIMATE A REASONABLE SAVINGS
AMOUNT.
OUR SECOND AREA OF CONCERN WHICH
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED TO SOME
DEGREE IS THE LACK OF DETAIL
ABOUT THE ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN
TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT.
OF THE NEW INCREASE PROCESS AND
OUR AIR OUR CONCERNS FELL INTO
THREE AREAS EXPERTISE
INDEPENDENCE AND TRANSPARENCY.
ON THE ISSUE OF EXPERT EXPERTISE.
THE KEY QUESTION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IS WHAT
TYPE OF OVERSIGHT WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE PROVIDED OVER THIS PROCESS.
AND DOES THE ENTITY OR ENTITIES
BEING TASKED WITH THAT HAVE THE
NECESSARY EXPERTISE TO PROVIDE
THAT TYPE OF OVERSIGHT -- FOR
EXAMPLE THE DEPARTMENT IS
PROPOSING TO HAVE THE OFFICE OF
AUDIT AND AUDITS IN COURT
COMPLIANCE PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF
THE NEW PROCESS.
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
OVERSIGHT WOULD TAKE THE FORM
PRIMARILY OF DATA ANALYTICS
WHICH THE STAFF IN THAT OFFICE
MAY HAVE THE EXPERTISE TO
PROVIDE HOWEVER
GAINES.
AYE THOSE DUTIES WERE ASSIGNED
TO A GENERAL -- SERGEANTS AND
LIEUTENANTS WITHIN THE
INSTITUTION KIND OF AS AND OTHER
DUTIES ASSIGNED THERE WEREN'T
SPECIFIC TEAM SET OUT FOR THIS.
SO THE CHANGES IN REDUCTION ON
THE IT'LL INSTITUTIONS THAT
WOULD LIKELY BE VERY MARGINAL
AND IT'S AN AS THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL NOTED A LOT OF THOSE
COMPLAINTS WERE HANDLED IN
ADEQUATELY ANSWERED.
IDENTIFYING A TIMER SAVINGS
ASSOCIATED WITH MOVING THOSE
COMPLAINTS OUT OF THE
INSTITUTIONS IS IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT.
ON THAT ONE NIGHT I CAN IN.
SO IN GENERAL I'M ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR SAVINGS SAVINGS IN THE WAYS
TO ABSORB BUT I CAN IMAGINE IF
WE IF WE WANT AN IMPROVED.
COMPLAINT PROCESS WITH -- I MEAN
NOW WE HAD SITUATIONS WHERE THE
COMPLAINTS ARE BEING
INVESTIGATED.
BY IT AS STAFF MEMBER WHO.
WHO REPORTED TO THE PERSON WHO?
HAD IT WOULD THE COMPLAINT WAS
ISSUED AGAINST I MEAN WHAT KIND
OF THAT IS. TO MEAN THAT JUST.
DOES NOT WORK SO.
BY THE BY CAN SEE WHERE THERE
MAY BE RESOURCES REQUIRED IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE A AN
APPROPRIATE COMPLAINT PROCESS
BUT I CERTAINLY THINK SOME OF
THE OTHER.
ISSUES THAT ELIO RACED -- ARE
HAVE MERIT.
I'M CENTER MORE LOCKED.
THANK YOU SURE I I'D LIKE TO GO
THROUGH THE ORG CHART MR.
GALVIN WHAT IS YOUR TITLE AGAIN
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS.
SO I I DON'T SEE IN MY MATERIAL
AT AN OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
I SEE AN OFFICE OF AUDITS IN
COURT COMPLIANCE I SEE A
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS --
I SEE AN OFFICE OF APPEALS I SEE
AN A DIVISION OF CORRECTIONAL
POLICY RESEARCH.
AND INTERNAL OVERSIGHT -- MY
MEDICINE SO WE FALL UNDER THAT
THE VISION OF INTERNAL OVERSIGHT.
WITHIN THAT DIVISION OUR
PROGRAMS ARE THE OFFICE OF THE
FEELS THE ALSO THE POLICY COR
COMPLIANCE.
THE OFFICE OF RESEARCH.
OKAY AND SO HOW DOES THE OFFICE
OF INSPECTOR GENERAL FIT INTO
THAT ORG CHART OR DOES IT NOT.
SO THEY ARE SEPARATE AGENCY
HOWEVER -- WHEN THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS OPENS
INVESTIGATION ACTUALLY GET
INVESTING A REQUEST?
THE AG IS INVOLVED IN THAT PROP
PROCESS.
ESSENTIALLY THE TERM ISSUES FOR
QUICK OF A GRAVE SO THEY ARE
INVOLVED IN THE REVIEW OF
REQUEST FOR INVESTIGATIONS.
THEY CAN THEY PROVIDE --
RECOMMENDATIONS INPUT TO OUR OUR
UNITS NAY AND BAD.
THE ATTORNEYS WITH OUR
INVESTIGATIVETEAMS ON
INVESTIGATIONS THE MEET THE
CRITERIA THAT THEY SET
[inaudible]
AND I'M I'M I'M TRYING TO GRASP
THE LA OWES RECOMMENDATION A
REVIEW HERE SO -- ARE WE STATING
THAT THERE'S MAYBE [inaudible]
DUPLICATION OR ARE YOU ASKING
ABOUT THAT THE QUESTION THE
CONCERN WE RAISE ON THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT AROUND THE POTENTIAL
SAVINGS.
YOU MENTIONED THREE RECORD.
SURE AND I ONLY HAVE -- TWO
WRITTEN MATERIAL SO.
SIR THERE ARE TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT FLOW FROM
TWO CONCERNS THE SEPARATE SIDE
OF SEPARATE CAN THE SECOND
EXCUSE ME SECOND CONCERN.
ABOUT OVERSIGHT HAD THREE AREAS
WITHIN IT.
THAT WE FELT.
IT LACKED DETAIL -- IN THE
PROPOSAL EXPERTISE INDEPENDENCE
AND TRANSPARENCY.
I'D HAVE I'D BE HAPPY TO REVIEW
ANY OF THAT IF YOU'D LIKE OFTEN
DO YOU AGREE WITH HER OVER SAID
HER READ HER OBSERVATIONS
RECOMMENDATION WELL SO.
WHEN IT WHEN WHEN A COMPLAINT
RISES TO AN OPEN FULL INTERNAL
AFFAIRS INVESTIGATION THE -- AG
CAN ATTACH THEMSELVES THEY THEY
HAVE OVERSIGHT WITH OUR
INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS.
THE INQUIRY PROCESS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS SORT OF A PRE
FORMAL INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS.
IT HAPPENS AT THE INSTITUTIONAL
LEVEL NOW.
I THINK THE DEPARTMENT SHE'D
ABOUT NINETY THOUSAND GRIEVANCES
LAST YEAR NOT THAT ALMOST
SEVEN THOUSAND OUR STAFF FOR SIX
TO SEVEN THOUSAND OR STAFF
COMPLAINING CORY'S SO THAT ISN'T
THAT IS A CONDITIONAL INQUIRY TO
DETERMINE.
IF THERE'S ENOUGH TO REQUEST A
FORMAL INVESTIGATION FOR FOR CAN
ANSWER THE ISSUES IN THE
GRIEVANCE AND PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO THE HIRING
AUTHORITY THE WARDENS -- TO MAKE
A DECISION REGARDING THE
COMPLAINTS.
AND SO MISTER WESLEY.
HOW DID YOU HAVE A LIKE A
RESPONSE TO THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS?
WELL THE I CAN'T ADDRESS THE
DOLLAR.
PEACE OF MIND WE HI I'D HAVE TO
AGREE WITH THE OUR OFFICE
FINANCE THE OF THESE.
THESE INCREASE THAT HAD THAT WE
WENT AND LOOKED AT WORK AD HOC.
THEY WERE THEY JUST GRAB
SOMEBODY OFF THE YARD AND SAID
YOU NEED I NEED THIS DONE IN
THIRTY DAYS.
SO THERE WAS NO TIME KEEPING
THERE WAS NO -- NO REFERENCE.
TO OF HOW MUCH EFFORT WAS PUT
INTO IT -- AND AS THEY SAID THEY
WERE DONE SO POORLY THAT I'M NOT
SURE THEY'RE OF MUCH VALUE ON
GIVING YOU SOME IDEA OF HOW LONG
THEY TAKE OR HOW MUCH MANPOWER
THEY TAKE [inaudible]
ARE THESE.
COMPLAIN THESE INVESTIGATIONS
ARE THEY NOW SUBJECT TO THE
PUBLIC RECORDS REQUEST ACT OF
BASED ON THE BILL THAT SENATOR
SKINNER HAD APPROVED LAST YEAR.
NO NO -- BECAUSE I DON'T DEAL
WITH THE SAME SUBJECT MATTER HAS
THE SENATORS BILL OKAY IF THEY
WERE.
THE UNDER VARIOUS.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT A COMPLAINT
COULD [inaudible]
BUT IT.
IT WOULD BE RARE.
IN TERMS OF THE NARROWNESS OF SB.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE BUT THE
COMPLAINTS DEAL WITH STAFFING.
BIG WOULD SUSPECT RIGHT THEY
DEAL WITH THINGS SUCH AS THIS
OFFICER -- SEARCH MY CELL AND
TOOK MY PERSONAL PROPERTY.
AND FOR NO REASON.
OR THIS OFFICER WAS --
DISCOURTEOUS TO ME CALLED ME
NAMES YOU KNOW THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS SO THAT'S A LOT OF THOSE
COMPLAINTS.
A LOT OF ROOM A LOT OF THOSE
COMPLAINTS OF A LARGE NUMBER
THOSE COMPLAINTS IN FACT OUR USE
OF FORCE RELATED SO.
NGUYEN FORCES USED WITHIN THE
PRISON SYSTEM -- THE INMATE HAS
THE HAS THE RIGHT.
TO A RACE AN ISSUE AS TO WHETHER
IT WAS APPROPRIATE.
AND THAT'S DONE.
BY THE STAFF COMPLAINT PROCESS
BUT IT'S SORT OF INTERMINGLED
WITH THE USE OF FORCE REVIEW
PROCESS -- SO THERE'S A FAIR
NUMBER OF THOSE -- THESE
[inaudible]
OUR TYPICALLY ISSUES THAT -- IT
MAKES REYES BECAUSE THEY FEEL
THEY'RE NOT BEING TREATED
PROPERLY [inaudible]
SO.
A DOZEN YEARS AGO HOW MANY
LAWSUITS WERE FILED BY.
INMATES.
THE TO THE STATE.
FOR ISSUES LIKE THIS AND ASKED
[inaudible]
FOR MONETARY DAMAGES.
I DON'T KNOW THE NUMBER BUT I
KNOW THAT THOSE LAWSUITS
CONTINUE TO TODAY -- I WAS
SEEING A DECLINE DON'T I DON'T
BELIEVE SO A REMINDER DURING A
BILL [inaudible]
BY NOT.
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT THE
OFFICE OF LEGAL AFFAIRS AT
CORRECTIONS -- PROVIDES
OVERSIGHT TO THEY'RE THE ONES
WHO.
DEFENDED APARTMENT ON THOSE
THINGS AND AGAIN THAT'S OUTSIDE
OF OUR JURISDICTION. FOR
MONITORING THE DEPARTMENT.
BUT WOULD IT BE.
A PERFORMANCE MEASUREMENT FOR
YOU TO BE ABLE TO SAVE BECAUSE
ALL OF US ARE WORKING TOGETHER.
TO ADDRESS COMPLAINTS IN A
HOPEFULLY I'M A PROPER MANNER
PROFESSIONAL MANNER THAT WE
WON'T HAVE LAWSUITS AND HERE'S
HOW MUCH WE'VE SAVED BECAUSE WE
HAD.
YOU KNOW HUNDRED LAWSUITS IN
YEAR ONE AND WE'RE DOWN TO TEN
IN YEAR TEN I ABSOLUTELY AGREE
THAT'S THAT WOULD BE A A BENEFIT
OF PROVIDING OVERSIGHT TO THIS
PROCESS [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU MANAGER I'M.
I'M GLAD THIS IS OPEN AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET SOME MORE.
TO REAL TO REVIEW AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR WE'RE HOLDING IT
OPEN FOR APPRECIATE ALL OF
DISCUSSION MANNER -- INPUT BOTH
FROM THE DEPARTMENT THE OFFICE
OF INSPECTOR GENERAL OF COURSE
LA -- AND DEPARTMENT FINANCE SO.
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE --
SKEWS ME PUBLIC COMMENT SORRY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
OKAY WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE
FIFTEEN WHICH IS THE PENAL CODE
REVIEW.
AND FOSTER CALLUM FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES FOR
THINNING ON THAT -- COULDN'T
COME TO PERMANENT FINANCE I'M
REPRESENTING THE ADMINISTRATION
ON THE PENAL CODE REVIEW
COMMITTEE PROPOSAL.
AND THE CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE
HAS DRAMATICALLY INCREASED IN
SIZE FROM ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND WORDS IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE TO ONE POINT
TWO MILLION.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN GOING
TO GET WORSE KNOW THAT ASSEMBLY
COULD A FIFTY BILLS BECAUSE
THERE ARE MORE THAN FIVE
THOUSAND SEPARATE CRIMINAL
PROVISIONS SPECIFYING CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR PENALTIES FOR
CONVICTIONS ADDITIONAL
ENHANCEMENTS AND CREDIT EARNING
ONCE INCARCERATED.
CONSEQUENTLY THE ADMINISTRATION
IS REQUESTING FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT A NEW
COMMITTEE.
WILL BE ESTABLISHED UNDER THE
LAW REVISION COMMISSION TO STUDY
AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
REVISE THIS COMPLEX STATUTORY
STRUCTURE.
THE NEW COMMITTEE WILL HAVE
SEPARATE POWERS TO MAKE POLICIES
AND TAKE THAT ACTION SEPARATE
FROM THE COMMISSION INTERVIEW
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR ON
REVISIONS TO THE PENAL CODE.
THE COMMITTEE WILL BEGIN AN
EFFORT TO SIMPLIFY AND
RATIONALIZE CRIMINAL LONG
CRIMINAL PROCEDURES ESTABLISH
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION
THAT AID REHABILITATION AND
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY.
IMPROVE PAROLE AND PROBATION
SYSTEMS AND ADJUST THE LENGTH OF
SENDS BASED ON CERTAIN
CONSIDERATIONS.
THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES FUNDING
FOR TWO ATTORNEY POSITIONS AND
ADMINISTRATIVE POSITION
ASSOCIATED COST WE ARE ALSO
PROPOSING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO ESTABLISH THE COMMITTEE.
AND THE PROPOSED ACTIVITIES
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
IT'S HARD ENOUGH FOR US TO READ
REPORTS LET ALONE THE ANYWAY --
A I DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH REVIEWING THAT IN
CREATING AN ENTITY TO PREVIEW IT
MY ONE ISSUE WOULD BE THE
COMPOSITION YOU RECOMMEND OR
RATHER THE PROPOSAL.
SAYS ONE SENATE MEMBER ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND FIVE
APPOINTEES FROM THE GOVERNOR.
A COURSE -- AS LEGISLATORS --
YOU KNOW THAT THE A LITTLE BIT
[inaudible]
S. Q. -- BUT CAN A JUSTIFICATION
BESIDES THAT YOU MAY WANT TO
HAVE IT S. Q..
I I SEE IT WOULD REALLY THE-COMMITTEES MODELED ON A SMALLER
SCALE AFTER THE EXISTING LAW
REVISION COMMISSION WHICH IS ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONE SENATOR AND
SEVEN GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE IS.
OUT OF THE VOTE ON THAT -- IT'S
MODELED AFTER THAT -- I DO THINK
THAT HAVING AN ACTUAL
LEGISLATIVE MEMBER ON THE
COMMITTEE VERSUS JUST AN
APPOINTEE FROM EACH OF THE
HOUSES PROBABLY OR OR PROVIDES A
LEVEL OF ELEVATION OR
SIGNIFICANCE TO THAT POSITION
THAT JUST A REGULAR APPOINTEE
DOESN'T YOU KNOW HOW.
WE ARE DOING VOTE ON SOMETHING
THAT ALLOWED THE GOVERNOR TO
HAVE SEVEN INTO SOLELY TO BUT
SENATOR MOORLACH.
MADAM CHAIR -- HI I'M.
I GET ONE INTERVIEW REVIEW
EVERYTHING -- BUT THIS.
I GUESS A COUPLE QUESTIONS ONE
IS IS THAT MEAN THAT THIS
COMMITTEE COMES ROCKER
COMMISSION COMES BACK AND SAYS
HERE'S ALL THE MODIFICATIONS WE
WANT TO MAKE TO THE PENAL CODE
WE GET THIS MASSIVE
RECOMMENDATION FOR BILLS AT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
YEAH I DON'T HAVE A DEEPER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE EXISTING
PROCESS BUT YES GENERALLY WE
WOULD WE THE COMMITTEE WOULD
COME BACK WITH A RECOMMENDATION.
AND THEN ITWOULD BE UPON THE
LEGISLATURE WHETHER TO TAKE
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS UP AND
MAKE THOSE CHANGES TO THEIR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
AND THE SECOND QUESTION IS WHY
WOULD WE NEED TO ESTABLISH A
COMMITTEE CAME AND AND AND PAY
FOR ALL THAT NGUYEN MAYBE IT
COULD BE DONE BY.
PRIVATE SECTOR THINK TANK OR THE
JUDICIARY DID JUDICIAL COUNCIL
OR OR SOMEONE ELSE IF THERE IS
YOU KNOW WHY WHY ARE WE TAKING
IT UPON OURSELVES.
I THINK THE IDEA IS THAT -- THE
COMMISSION EXIST TODAY AND THEY
TùTAKE A DEEPER LOOK INTO THE
VARIOUS PARTS OF OUR STATUTORY
STRUCTURE.
THEY'RE NOT REALLY SET UP IN A
WAY TO LOOK AT THE PENAL CODE.
AND SO WE THINK JUST ADDING
RESOURCES FOR SOMETHING THAT
ALREADY HAS AN EXISTING
OPERATION -- ADMINISTRATIVE
STRUCTURE OR PROCESS SO WE CAN
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING -- MAKES
MORE SENSE THAN LOOKING FOR
OTHER ENTITIES OUTSIDE -- IF
THOSE ENTITIES EXISTED TODAY I
THINK WE KNOW WITH THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WOULD BE BEFORE --
THE GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAKE -- YOU KNOW MAKE
DECISIONS ON AND SO WE THINK
HAVING A FOCUSED EFFORT.
THE MODEL THAT ALREADY EXISTS --
MAKES SENSE.
THANK YOU MANAGER CERTAINLY.
AND OF COURSE THE THE WAY THE
PROPOSALS WRITTEN.
IT DOESN'T SEEM -- TO ORATION
SAY DOESN'T SEE IT.
THERE THE FIVE APPOINTEES SOME
COMMISSIONS IT DESIGNATES THERE
WOULD BE.
CERTAIN APPOINTEES WOULD BE.
SAY FROM AN ACADEMIC SENATOR
CERTAIN APPOINTEES WOULD BE FROM
AND YOU KNOW COMMUNITY BASED AND
I'M JUST GIVING NOT THAT THIS IS
ANALOGOUS BUT IN THIS CASE IT
JUST SAYS FIVE APPOINTEES
WITHOUT.
A SPECIFICATION OF PERHAPS WITH
THEIR BACKGROUND WOULD BE.
AND DID THE ADMINISTRATION
ALREADY HAVE A PERSPECTIVE ON OR
WHY IT.
WANTED TO LEAVE IT OPEN ENDED
YEAH I THINK LEAVING IT OPEN AND
IT WAS KIND TO ALLOW THEM TO USE
THEIR NORMAL DELIVERED A PROCESS
TO FIND THOSE WHO HAD THE BEST
QUALIFICATIONS TO JUST PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL.
PARTICIPATION TO THE COMMITTEE
SO YOU KNOW -- IT COULD BE A CBO
IT COULD BE AN ACADEMIC IT COULD
BE YOU KNOW LAW ENFORCEMENT IT
JUST IT REALLY DEPENDS ON THAT
INDIVIDUAL HAVING A DEEP ENOUGH
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PENAL CODE.
AND TO REALLY PROVIDE HOW YOU
AND I THINK THAT -- YOU KNOW
ADDING CONSTRAINTS ABOUT THAT
SELECTION CRITERIA -- YOU KNOW
COULD MAKE THAT MORE DIFFICULT.
ALL RIGHT SO I'M -- LEAVING IT
OPEN DESIGN IMAGINING THAT THERE
WILL BE SOME INPUT ON THIS
APPOINTMENT -- AND ON THE IF IF
IT WERE TO MOVE FORWARD THEN
WHAT SIX COMMISSION WOULD
COMPRISE OF ANDERSON -- BUT AT
LEAST I DO APPRECIATE THAT IT
WOULD BE A SUBSET OF AN EXISTING
COMMISSION SO IT DOESN'T REQUIRE
ALL.
OF THE FINDING OF A NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THOUGH IT CERTAINLY IS
LEGITIMATE TO LOOK AT WHETHER
BECAUSE IT IS PART OF AN
EXISTING ONE WHETHER -- IT NEEDS
THIS LEVEL OF GENERAL FUND.
YEAH I THINK -- THE EXISTING
COMMISSION STAFF IS SMALL IT'S
FIVE AND A HALF POSITIONS --
WE'RE REQUESTING THREE TO THE
MURDER ANY IS THAT WILL SUPPORT
THE COMMIT COMMITTEE DIRECTLY IN
ADMINISTRATIVE SUFFICIENT.
POSITION OF A SUPPORT THE
COMMITTEE AND THE COMMISSION
OVERALL.
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND CHIEF
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
COMMISSION WILL SUPPORT BOTH THE
COMMISSION.
THE COMMITTEE THEY'RE BOTH
ATTORNEY POSITIONS AS WELL -- SO.
THEY HAVE ALREADY A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF WORK IN THEIR OWN
PROCESS BUT I THINK I'M AT LEAST
PROVIDING THOSE LEADERSHIP.
POSITIONS -- IN MAKING THOSE
AVAILABLE WILL HELP AGAIN --
STAND THIS UP MORE QUICKLY.
BUT WE DIDN'T REALLY THERE
DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE ANY KIND OF
EXISTING -- RESOURCE
AVAILABILITY TO STAFF A NEW
COMMITTEE WITHIN THE COMMISSION.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU -- PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THAT ITEM.
ALL RIGHT WILL MOVE TO ISSUE
SIXTEEN THE SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY.
AS YOU ASSEMBLYMAN HAND THE
GAVEL JUST FOR A MOMENT TO MY
VICE CHAIR.
JUST TO RYAN WELCOME BACK.
THANK YOU.
SO I THINK WE'RE HERE TO DISCUSS --
JUST TO CONFIRM ISSUE SIXTEEN
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY.
AND WE HAVE A HAND OUT WE SHARED
WITH US STAFF PREVIOUSLY.
OKAY TO SHARE THAT WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
AND LINDA SWAG IS HERE FROM THE
C. JUST AND SHE CAN GIVE US AN
OVERVIEW OF THE PROJECT -- AND
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION WITH THIS
IS ABOUT TO CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT
IS CURRENTLY ASKING FOR
SEVENTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND.
AND THIRTY SEVEN PER PERMANENT
POSITIONS IN NINETEEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND THIRTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY THREE TO PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES THAT WILL IMPLEMENT --
THROUGH -- FOR SB THREE EIGHTY
FOUR THAT WAS PASSED -- AT HIS
TWO YEARS AGO THE WITH.
THAT AFTERNOON THANK YOU.
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY.
THE BILL OF THE OVERVIEW OF THE
NEW LAW IF WE TRANSITION
CALIFORNIA FROM A LIFETIME
REGISTRATION BUSINESS MODEL TO A
TIER BASED MODEL BY JANUARY
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND WHEN I'M
TALKING ABOUT TRANSITIONING
CALIFORNIA THAT INCLUDES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
OF ALL THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
BUSINESS PARTNERS INCLUDING THE
COURTS D. A.'S PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS AT COUNTY
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES AND
LOCAL REGISTERING AGENCIES.
AND THIS MODEL HAS BEEN IN PLACE
FOR OVER SEVENTY FIVE YEARS.
AND IT REQUIRES US TO DO MANY
THINGS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AS A STATE SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY TO SUPPORT ALL OF OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE BUSINESS
PARTNERS -- SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE WILL HAVE TO DO IS
ENHANCE AND MODIFY AND MAINTAIN.
EXISTING SYSTEMS AND INTERFACES
THAT SUPPORT REGISTRATION AND
NOTIFICATION IN CALIFORNIA.
IT WILL ALSO REQUIRE US TO
COLLECT NEW DATA ON ON GOING
BASIS INCLUDING CUSTODY -- DATA
PETITION DATA.
AND NON CALIFORNIA CRIMINAL
HISTORY.
IT WILL ALSO REQUIRE US TO
COLLECT MISSING DATA INCLUDING --
DISPOSITION AND RISK ASSESSMENT
DATA IN A STANDARDIZED FORMAT.
AND IT WILL NOT ONLY REQUIRES TO
DO THAT BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
ESTABLISH AND MAINTAIN NEW UNITS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THERE IS A LOT OF DESPAIR
DATABASES BETWEEN -- LOOK
FEDERAL AND STATE DATABASES AND
SO A LOT OF THIS WORK IS GOING
TO BE A MANUAL WORKLOAD SO WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO HAVE A NEW TEARING
AND TERMINATION UNITS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WE WILL ALSO HAVE TO PROVIDE
THEM SYSTEM ACCESS BY A LOT OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE BUSINESS
PARTNERS IN CALIFORNIA THAT DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS -- TO THE DOJ
DATABASES THAT SUPPORT
REGISTRATION NOTIFICATION
INCLUDING CHORDS PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS COUNTY CUSTODIAL
FACILITIES AND SOME OF THE
SMALLER REGISTERING AGENCIES AT
THE COUNTY AND THAT LOCAL LEVEL.
SO IN ORDER TO DO THIS -- MOST
FOLKS WOULD THINK THAT WE'RE
GOING TO SINCE WE'RE GOING TO A
TIER BASED SYSTEM WILL BE
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF SEX
OFFENDERS AND THAT IS TRUE.
EVENTUALLY WE WILL REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY
IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT IT WHAT IT DOESN'T DO AS IT
DOESN'T REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
REGISTRANTS THAT COME INTO THE
SYSTEM THE REGISTRATION SYSTEM
SO EVERY YEAR ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND NEW REGISTRANTS COME
INTO THE SYSTEM.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND REGISTRANTS
IN THE DATABASE AND WE HAVE FIVE
THOUSAND NEW ONES COME IN EITHER
THROUGH A CALIFORNIA CONVICTION
OR A NON CALIFORNIA CONVICTION
AND THEY MOVED HERE FROM OUT OF
STATE.
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ENSURE
IS THAT WE HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION TO THIS TO YOUR FACE
SYSTEM FROM A SYSTEM THAT'S BEEN
IN PLACE FOR SEVENTY FIVE YEARS
BUT NOT ONLY TO HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION.
BUT TO MAINTAIN THAT TRANSITION
THIS IS CHANGING CALIFORNIA'S
BUSINESS MODEL FOR REGISTRATION
AND WE WANT.
TO SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT IT.
WITH THE MAKING SURE WE HAVE ALL
THE DATA WHEN WE DO THIS AND
THAT WE DON'T INCUR ANY
LIABILITY TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT WE DO IT ACCURATELY AND
THAT WE DON'T -- IMPACT PUBLIC
SAFETY SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO THIS CORRECTLY.
AND IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE WILL
HAVE TO HAVE RESOURCES BOTH FOR
THE TRANSITION AND THE ONGOING
MAINTENANCE.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND FOR ALL THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PARTNERS THAT RELY ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AS A STATE
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY WE ARE
MANDATED AS THE KEEPER OF THE
RECORDS FOR THIS DATA.
AND WE HAVE TO KEEP OUR
TECHNOLOGIES -- AVAILABLE AND AT
THE OPTIMAL LEVEL AND PROVIDE
ACCESS TO ALL THE ADDITIONAL --
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SO THEY
CAN FULFILL THEIR ROLE IN THIS
TRANSITION TO THE NEW TERM BASED
SYSTEM AS WELL [inaudible]
WHAT'S MY I'M.
THIS OBVIOUSLY COULD HAVE BEEN A
VOTE ONLY.
MY ISSUE WAS THAT LAST YEAR.
WHEN WE ADOPTED THE BUDGET?
WE PROVIDED A MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR WELL WE ACTED ON THE BUDGET
PRIOR.
TO AB THREE ONE ONE AIDES
PASSAGE.
WE DISCUSSED IT WE WERE
COGNIZANT OF THAT BILLS
[inaudible]
I MEAN.
WITH THIS CUSTOM.
RIGHT I'M SORRY SIR SO.
JUMP TO THE HIGH JUMP TO THE
NEXT PAGE ANYWAY -- WE DID
PROVIDE FUNDING [inaudible]
IN OUR IN THE BUDGET. FOR FROM
I'VE.
LAST YEAR OF TEN MILLION WHICH
YOU MAY HAVE ADDRESS WHILE I WAS
OUT BUT THE POINT BEING THAT.
WELL IT'S CERTAINLY
UNDERSTANDABLE THAT THE ONE TIME
ONLY MIGHT NOT BE ADEQUATE.
IN THAT THERE'S VARIOUS THINGS
THAT NEED TO BE PUT INTO PLACE
[inaudible]
OVER TIME.
THERE WILL BE LESS REGISTRANTS.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS TO
MONITOR BECAUSE OF THIS TIERED
SYSTEM.
AND IN THE PAST WE HAD A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL SO PEOPLE WERE
PERMANENTLY [inaudible]
AND THE REQUEST. FOR THIRTY
SEVEN ADDITIONAL PERMANENT
POSITIONS.
ALONG WITH -- WELL I DON'T SEE
IT IN THE SUBSEQUENT YEARS
NECESSARILY ADDITIONAL PERMANENT
POSITIONS -- BUT OUR THE FIRST
FUNDING WE PROVIDED HAD SOME
POSITIONS SO FOR ME IT'S JUST
[inaudible]
IT'S I DON'T SEE THE
JUSTIFICATION.
FOR THIRTY SEVEN NEW F. T. E.
WHEN WE HAVE ALWAYS HAD A SEX
REGISTRY.
WE DON'T NECESSARILY SEE MORE
PEOPLE BEING PUT ON THE SEX
REGISTRY SO THIS IS DIFFERENT
THAN THE APPS WERE WE DEFINITELY
HAVE MORE PEOPLE BEING PUT IN ON
THE PROHIBITED PERSONS LIST.
WE DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE MORE
PEOPLE AND IN FACT BY OUR
STATUTE CHANGE WE WILL BE HAVING.
FEWER TO MONITOR OVER TIME.
SO -- THAT'S WHY I'M
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE APPROVAL
OF THE BCP.
IF I COULD ADDRESS THAT SO.
IT WILL REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
REGISTRANTS ON THE REGISTRY
EVENTUALLY.
BUT WHAT IT DOESN'T REDUCE IT
DOESN'T REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
REGISTRANTS THAT COME INTO THE
REGISTRY WE'VE BEEN --
CONSISTENT OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS WITH APPROXIMATELY FIVE
THOUSAND REGISTRANTS BOTH
CALIFORNIA CONVICTION AND NON
CALIFORNIA CONVICTIONS THAT COME
INTO THE REGISTRY.
CURRENTLY THE MODEL THAT WE USE
IN THE REGISTRY BECAUSE EVERYONE
IS THAT ONE SIZE ALL IT'S THE
SINGLE HIGHEST OFFENSE AND
SOMEONE WE HAVE NEW REGISTRANTS
COME IN WITH THE TEACHER PAY
SYSTEM WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
LOOK AT THEIR TOTAL CRIMINAL
HISTORY.
THAT INCLUDES OUT OF STATE
CRIMINAL HISTORY AS WELL AS A
TIRE WOULD REQUIRE YOU TO DO
THAT ONCE.
COLLEGES CUT YOU OFF BUT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT EVERY YEAR.
BUT IT.
TOO WE WOULD BE DOING THAT FIVE
THOUSAND YES BUT YOU HAVE TO
PROCESS FIVE THOUSAND RIGHT NOW
AS YOU JUST INDICATED AND YOU
HAD TO PROCESS FIVE THOUSAND THE
PREVIOUS YEAR IN THE PREVIOUS
YEAR IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR SO YES
IT WAS A ONE SIZE FITS ALL IN
THAT.
PROCESSING OF THAT FIVE THOUSAND
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE.
AND AND NOT ONLY THAT THERE'S A
NEW WITH THERE IS NEW WORKLOADS
IT'S THE TERRAIN THAT PUTTING
THESE PEOPLE INTO THE TEARS AS A
WORKLOAD A NEW UNIT IS GOING TO
HAVE TO BE ESTABLISHED.
WE HAVE TO PROCESS THOSE FIVE
THOUSAND WE ALSO ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO PROCESS THE PETITIONS
FOR TERMINATIONS ONCE THE COURT
GRANTS THE PETITION FOR
TERMINATION.
THAN THAT INFORMATION IS GOING
TO BE SENT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WILL GO IN AND UPDATE
ALL THE SYSTEMS AND NOTIFY THE
INDIVIDUALS AND NOTIFY THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
AN ARCHIVE THAT INFORMATION SO
THERE ARE TWO NEW WORKLOADS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WE
ALSO HAVE TO HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT TRANSITION TO THIS
AND SO.
WHEN THEY'RE LOOKING TO SEE IF
SOMEBODY QUALIFIES FOR
TERMINATIONS THEY'RE GOING TO BE
REACHING OUT TO US AND ASKING US
FOR INFORMATION AND CORRECTIONS
TO RECORDS?
IN ORDER TO MAKE THEIR
DETERMINATION SO THERE'S NEW
WORKLOADS THERE'S NEW
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR NOT ONLY
DOJ BUT ALSO FOR ALL THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN THIS AND SO.
WE CAN WE CAN PUT THIS ON TO A
FACT AND WE CAN TRANSITION BUT
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
IT GOING FORWARD.
NOT ONLY JUST THE PROGRAM
POSITIONS BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
HAVE.
SOME A COUPLE OF OUR POSITIONS
ARE FOR RESEARCH AND WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE -- DATA DRIVEN
EVIDENCE BEST PRACTICES AND
THAT'S PART OF THIS THIS IS WELL
HAVING THOSE RESEARCHERS WE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO CONDUCT AUDITS ON
REGISTERING AGENCIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE DOING WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING
CORRECTLY.
WE HAVE A LEGAL REVIEW THIS
THESE IF WE MAKE THE WRONG
DECISION ON PUTTING SOMEONE IN A
TEAR IT COULD BE PUBLIC SAFETY
OR A CIVIL LIABILITY ISSUE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WE
HAVE LEGAL POSITIONS.
THAT ARE MAKING SURE THE ANALYST
ARE CORRECTLY ANALYZING AND
PUTTING THE FOLKS IN THE CORRECT
HERE.
SO THERE ARE A LOT A NEW WORK
FLOWS THAT ARE DISTRIBUTED
STATEWIDE ON THE DOJ AS WELL AS
THE OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENTITIES.
AND IT IT'S TURKEY IT'S THIRTY
EIGHT TOTAL POSITIONS THAT'S THE
TWENTY FIVE THE FIRST YEAR AND
THEN THE ADDITIONAL POSITION SO
IT'S NOT AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
FIVE AND THIRTY EIGHT IT'S
THIRTY EIGHT TOTAL. TO
TRANSITION THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO NEW THAT THIS NEW
BUSINESS MODEL.
SIR MORE LUCK FROM MADAM CHAIR
WAS. ONE OF TWO REPUBLICANS HAVE
VOTED FOR SB -- THREE EIGHTY
FOUR BECAUSE A A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL - LIFETIME SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRATION WAS BRUTAL. TO A
LOT OF INDIVIDUALS.
AND GOING BACK TO HISTORICAL
CONTEXT -- I HAD WHEN I WAS A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR AT A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY THAT.
WANTED TO PROHIBIT.
INDIVIDUALS ON THIS LIST FROM
GOING TO PUBLIC PARKS.
BUT A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE.
GEN FATHER'S BEEN COULD NOT GO
TO THE PARK WITH THEIR KIDS.
OR TO THE BEACH OR YOU KNOW
WHATEVER -- WIN MAYBE THEY WERE
GUILTY OF URINATING IN PUBLIC.
YOU KNOW A VERY MINOR OFFENSE
BUT GOT THIS [inaudible]
THIS [inaudible]
SCARLET LETTER [inaudible]
SO.
I HAVE A NINE TO TO THE DETAILS
BUT WHAT I WOULD SEE THAT IS A
FATHER WHO
KNOWS A URINATED IN PUBLIC FOR
WHATEVER REASON DRUNKARD -- THAT
WOULD BE TEAR.
ONE YOU KNOW IT'S JUST KIND OF A
MINOR OFFENSE THAT'S GIVEN TEN
YEARS AND THEN IT'S OFF.
AND THEN THERE'S OTHER
[inaudible]
DEGRADATIONS -- SO DO YOU HAVE
CATEGORIES WE DO THEIR TIER
THREE TIERS TIER ONE IS TEN
YEARS TO YOUR TWO IS TWENTY
YEARS AND FIVE THREE AS LIFE.
AND WHAT WE CAN SEE NOW JUST
LOOKING AT THE DATA THAT WE HAVE
BECAUSE WE DO NOT HAVE ALL THE
DATA AVAILABLE TO US NOW AND HOW
WE COLLECT AT ALL.
IS THAT ABOUT HALF WILL REMAIN
AS LIFETIME -- TWENTY FOUR BUT
15% WILL BE INTERIOR -- TO AND
THE REMAINING WILL BE IN TIER.
ONE AND THAT AND THAT'S TAKING
YOU.
A LOT OF TIME TO GO CASE BY CASE
YES SO WE WILL BE MANUALLY
REVIEWING EACH OF THE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND RECORDS
THAT WE HAVE WE WILL BE RUNNING
FEDERAL CRIMINAL HISTORY RIGHT
NOW WE ONLY USE STATE CRIMINAL
HISTORY.
SO WE'LL BE LOOKING AT FEDERAL
CRIMINAL HISTORY STATE CRIMINAL
HISTORY AND OTHER DATA AND
THERE'S A LOT OF OPEN ARREST.
AND WE HAVE A DATA GAP IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO WE WILL HAVE
TO CLOSE ALL THOSE OPEN
ARRESTING GO OUT THERE AND GET
THAT MISSING DISPOSITION
INFORMATION.
AND THEN WE WILL DO IT YOUR
ASSESSMENT WE WILL PUT THEM IN A
TEAR -- AND THEN WE WILL PUT
THAT INFORMATION INTO OUR STATE
DATABASE AND MAKE IT AVAILABLE
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THEN ON
SEVEN ONE OF TWENTY ONE WHEN --
THE LAW GOES INTO EFFECT THAT
ELIGIBLE REGISTRANTS WILL BE
ABLE TO PETITION THE COURTS FOR
TERMINATION.
THAN THOSE THAT ARE GRANTED
TERMINATION THAT INFORMATION
WILL COME TO THE DOJ AND
ELECTRONIC FORMAT.
THROUGH THESE NEW INTERFACES
THAT WE ARE BUILDING AND
MAINTAINING WITH ALL THE COURTS
AND THE THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS IN THE JAILS BECAUSE
ONE OF THE OTHER COMPONENTS OF
THIS BILL THAT.
ADDED TO THE COMPLEXITY OF IT IS
ANY TIME THAT YOU WERE SPENDING
CUSTODY THAT TIME IS TOLD. FOR
THE PERIOD OF YOUR REGISTRATION
SO IF YOU HAVE A FIFTEEN YEAR.
TENURE REGISTRATION PERIOD YOUR
TIER ONE AND YOU'VE BEEN IN
PRISON FOR FIVE YEARS AND THAT
TIME DOES NOT COUNT AND SO RIGHT
NOW WE DON'T COLLECT THAT
INFORMATION.
AND IT'S GOING TO BE VERY ARE TO
US FOR US TO GO OUT AND GET THAT
INFORMATION FROM FIFTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SYSTEMS
COUNTY JAILS.
AND HELP THEM PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO US AND SO WE'RE
BUILDING THE TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT THEM
TO PROVIDE US IS DATA AND WE ARE
ALSO BUILDING THE ANALYTICAL AND
LEGAL RESOURCES THAT WILL HELP
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THE
COURTS THE D. A.'S.
AND US TO IMPLEMENT THE SO FOR
HOW IT HAPPENS ONCE THEY CAN
PETITION THE COURT.
AND IT MORE PEOPLE WILL PETITION
THEN ARE ELIGIBLE BECAUSE
NOTHING PREVENTS THEM -- TO
PETITION AS YOU SAID IT'S A
SCARLET LETTER AND MOST PEOPLE
IF THEY THINK THEY CAN HAVE A
CHANCE TO GET OFF OF THE
REGISTRY THEY'LL PETITION SO
THAT.
ADDITIONAL WORK ON ON THE COURTS
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO HELP
THEM WITH WITH A PETITION THE
COURT IF THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL THAT
DATA COMES TO US AND THEN WE
WILL.
TAKE THEM OUT OF THE STATE'S
SYSTEM TAKE THEM OUT OF THE
NATIONAL SYSTEM TAKE THEM OFF
THE PUBLIC MEGAN'S LAW WEBSITE.
LET EVERYONE KNOW THAT THEY HAVE --
BEEN TERMINATED FROM THE
REGISTRY AND THEN OF COURSE
ARCHIVE THAT INFORMATION FOR
LATER I'M PURPOSES.
THAT IT IT APPEARS TO BE A ONE
AND DONE AND IT'S OVER AND YOU
CAN MOVE ON BUT IT'S NOT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE AN INFRASTRUCTURE
TO MAINTAIN THIS.
AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE YOU KNOW
THE TECHNOLOGY FOR THE COMPUTING
THE STORAGE THE SECURITY.
AND THE DISASTER RECOVERY THEN
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE PROGRAM
SUPPORT FOR THESE NEW UNITS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE CONDUCTING THE
ASSESSMENTS AS WELL AS THE
PETITIONING FOR THE ON GOING
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
LONG TIME FOR PEOPLE. TO
PETITION AND IF THEY GET DENIED
THEY CAN RE PETITION IN BETWEEN
ONE AND FIVE YEARS SO WE'RE
GONNA HAVE ALL THESE
REPOSITIONING SO THIS IS.
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK INVOLVED
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO THIS NEW
BUSINESS MODEL WITHOUT INCURRING
ANY LIABILITY FROM LAWSUITS IF
WE DON'T DO IT RIGHT OR WE TAKE
A LONG TIME TO DO IT.
ARE WE INADVERTENTLY PUT
SOMEBODY IN THE WRONG TEAR AND
THEY GET OFF AND THEN THEY DO
SOMETHING THAT NO ONE WANTS THIS
TO HAPPEN.
RIGHT AND SO WHEN THIS BILL WENT
THROUGH LAST YEAR.
I A WIN THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
CORRECTED TWICE PROBABLY.
WHAT KIND OF ESTIMATES DID YOU
GIVE FOR COSTS?
YES MEN SIR I SIMILAR TO WHAT
WE'VE SEEN THE LAST TWO YEARS IN
THE B. C. P. SORRY SORRY SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS OVER A PERIOD OF
SEVERAL YEARS FOR THE PROJECT --
AND THERE'S TWO DOCUMENTS THAT
WE BROUGHT TODAY AND AND YOU MAY
WANT TO AS I KNOW THIS CAMINO
OPEN ITEMS WE MAY WANT TO HAVE
SOME ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION BUT
ONE IS THE THE PERSONNEL NEEDED
AT THE DIFFERENT PHASES OF THE
PROJECT.
AND THEN THE OTHER ONE IS THE
CURRENT SYSTEM TODAY THE TASKS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT AND THAT
PROCESS AND WHAT THE NEW SYSTEM
LOOKS LIKE SO YOU CROSSWALK FROM.
WHAT IS THE CURRENT SYSTEM TO
THE NEW?
MODEL AND IT SHOWS YOU ALL THOSE
NEW TASKS AND IT IS BROKEN DOWN
MY THE REGISTRY SUPPORT STAFF
THE I. T. SUPPORT AND AND
MINISTRY TO IT AND SO ANYTHING
THAT YOU SEE ON THE RIGHT IN.
READ IS IS NEW WHAT'S ON THE
LEFT IS WHAT WE DO.
PURSUANT TO OUR MANDATES TODAY
AND THEN ANYTHING ON THE RIGHT
THAT IS NEW WITH -- THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THREE EIGHTY
FOUR AND THIS DOCUMENT HERE ALSO
IS A DIAGRAM OF OUR EXISTING
REGISTRY.
THEN THE ADDITION OF THE STAFF
THAT ARE NEEDED TO DO OF ALL THE
MANUAL WORK.
AND THEN THE REDUCTION AND WHAT
WE WILL.
BE AT THE END OF THE PROJECT TO
HELP MAINTAIN THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION GOING FOR IT.
IN A AND EARNED FOR THOSE SAID
MAYBE APPLY FOR LOWER TIER DO
THEY PAY A FEE.
WELL I DON'T BELIEVE SO YEAH BUT
THE THEY WILL PETITION THE COURT.
RIGHT SO THAT WHILE FILING
CHAPTER FILING FEES AS WELL TO
BE BUT OTHER THAN THAT THERE'S
NO.
COST TO THEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VENTURE.
CERTAINLY SENATOR MORE LIKE SO.
THE REGISTRY HAD. FIVE AND I
WANT TO BE ABLE.
TO MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND THIS
CORRECTLY PRIOR TO THE ENACTING.
OF THIS. THREE TIERS IT HAD
SIXTY SIX POSITIONS TO MAINTAIN
THE REGISTRY THAT'S CORRECT.
AND THEN WE ADDED TWENTY FIVE
LAST YEAR WE DID.
OKAY.
IN THOSE TWENTY FIVE RUN GOING.
ON ALL RIGHT SO.
TWENTY THREE WITH -- OMITTED.
THEY WERE PROMINENT TWENTY THREE
OF THE TWENTY FIVE ARE PERMANENT
POSITIONS THEY WERE PRIMARILY
THE I. T. POSITIONS SO ARE OUR
MODEL IS A TWO DOOR.
OUR MODEL IS TO BUILD THE
TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE FIRST
AND THEN DO THE MANUAL WORK SO
WE CAN HAVE A PLACE.
TO HOLD THAT DATA [inaudible]
OF NO T<c.cyan> HAVE DONE SHOW THAT</c>
THEY WERE ALL I. T. BUT THAT'S
OKAY WE'LL LEAVE IT.
BUT ANYWAY WE SIXTY SIX AND YOU
OUT OF THE TWENTY THREE WHICH
BRINGS IT UP [inaudible]
TO SEVENTY NINE AND YOU'RE RIGHT.
I'M FORGET NOW TO ADD I'M
INTERRUPTING YOU KNOW HUGH YOU
SHOULD INTERRUPT ME WHEN I ADD
WRONG.
IN YOUR ITS APPS IT IS A BUDGET
IT IS A BUDGET COMMITTEE AFTER
ALL -- AND NOW WE YOUR WARNING
AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY SEVEN
POSITIONS NO NO -- WORK WE'RE
NOT ASKING FOR AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY SEVENS AT THE END OF THE
DAY IT WILL BE A TOTAL OF THIRTY
EIGHT PERMANENT ONGOING
POSITIONS.
POSITIONS ARE GONNA COME MAN AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA GET THE LIMITED
TERM AND THEN THEY'RE GONNA COME
OFF AND AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
WILL HAVE THIRTY EIGHT
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS.
ON TOP OF THE EIGHTY NINE WE
JUST DISCUSSED.
NOW ON TOP OF THE SIXTY SIX
MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY SORRY I'M
HOPING TO HELP PROVIDE SOME
CLARIFICATION I'M A GEN WHICH
PART IN A FINANCE -- I THINK
THERE WAS PROBABLY
MISCOMMUNICATION WHEN THIS VCP
WAS DEVELOPED ON THE ACTUAL
NUMBER ALL NUMBER OF PERMANENT
POSITIONS THAT ARE NEEDED SO
STOCK THE DEFRAY IT SAYS THIRTY
SEVEN BUT I THINK IT TO YOU YEAH
I THINK THE NUMBER PROBABLY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN TAUGHT.
PROBABLY TWELVE I THINK WOULD
THAT WOULD BE THE RIGHT NUMBER
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BRING US UP
FROM THE TWENTY FIVE FROM BEFORE.
ADD TWELVE AND IT WOULD BE --
THIRTY SEVEN ANYWAYS.
WE CAN WORK OUT THE DETAILS
LATER BUT I DO THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT I'D I THINK THAT THERE WAS
PROBABLY JUST MISCOMMUNICATION
ON THE ACTUAL NUMBER.
TOTAL ONGOING SHOULD BE RESET
FOR USTO VOTE ON AND SO I MEAN
I THINK.
WHILE I MADE A LITTLE BAD.
YEAH YOU'RE RIGHT THERE I'M
STILL WORKING FROM A B. C. P.
THAT TELLS ME THAT MANY NEW
POSITIONS AND I'M SORRY BUT
AFTER THE POSITIONS WE ALREADY
ADDED.
THERE'S NO WAY TO JUSTIFY THAT
MANY ADDITIONAL POSITIONS TO
PROCESS THE SAME AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE EVERY YEAR EVEN THOUGH WE
ARE PROCESSING ON FOR A
DIFFERENT TO YOUR SYSTEM -- SO
I'M HAPPY TO HAVE THE
CLARIFICATION BUT WHAT I WOULD
PREFER.
APPRECIATE IS A CORRECTED BCP SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO SPEND THIS
AMOUNT OF TIME. EIGHT THREE LIKE
TO KNOW MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY I
DON'T THINK THE COSTS OF THE
POPOSAL WILL CHANGE THOUGH I
THINK IT'S REALLY A MATTER OF
THE PRESENT ABOVE THE POSITIONS
I THINK THIS IS -- IF YOU LOOK
AT THE B. C. P. I THINK IT EVEN
TALKS ABOUT A A HIGHER NEEDS
THAN -- THIRTY SEVEN TO ACTUALLY
DO THE WORK PLUS THERE'S A BIG
COMPONENT RELATED TO I. T. I
THINK ULTIMATELY ON GOING IT
WOULD BE THIRTY SEVEN BUT AGAIN
THIS IS ONLY A THREE YEAR
PROPOSAL WE WILL COME BACK FOR
ONGOING RESOURCES -- ONCE WE'VE --
ONCE DOJ IN CT HAVE FINISHED
THAT WHOLE PROCESS WITH THE I.
T. PROJECT -- AND THEN WE CAN
LOOK AT WHILE ONGOING WORKLOAD
IS AND WHAT THE MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS OF THE SYSTEM WOULD
BE.
WHEN YOU DO THAT?
YOU SHOULD LOOK AT WHAT WE
ALREADY APPROVED LAST YEAR AND
THAT THEY WERE I. T. POSITIONS
SO I DON'T THINK YOU HAVE ANY
DISAGREEMENT.
THAT.
THERE NEEDS TO BE IMPROVED I T.
AND THERE'S A NEW DEMAND ON THE
I. T. BUT TO FURTHER. FOR A
FURTHER EXPENDITURE.
IS.
THE HARD STILL FOR ME TO IMAGINE
BECAUSE OF AGAIN WE'RE STILL
TALKING ABOUT PROCESSING THE
SAME NUMBER OF PEOPLE AND YOU
ALREADY HAD A CORE OF STAFF THAT
PROCESS THOSE PEOPLE SO YES NOW
WE'VE COMPLICATED THE PROCESSING.
SO I'M GONNA EXCEPT THAT DUE TO
THE COMPLICATE.
COMPLICATION OF THE PROCESSING
THAT WE BATTED IT WOULD REQUIRE
SOME ADDITIONAL MORE.
BUT THE CLOSEST BUT THE THE THE
NUMBER MORE THAT'S BEEN
ADVOCATED STILL SEEMS ON JUST
FILE BOTH TO ME.
ANYWAY.
AND THEN YOU HAVE RECORD BCP
RISE SO WILL AND THAT'S WHY
PROVIDED A DOCUMENT WITH THE
SIDE BY SIDE SO YOU COULD SEE
THE CURRENT SYSTEM OF WHAT OF
WHAT THAT WAS BEFORE THE LAW
CHANGED AND YOU CAN SEE THE NEW
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE PART OF THE
NEW SYSTEM.
SO THE NEW BUSINESS MODEL GOING
FORWARD -- WHICH WE FEEL FOR
SUPPORT AND OF COURSE IT COULD
BE AND WE HAD EXPERIENCES
ALREADY WHEN WE WERE.
HAVING OUR DISCUSSION WITH CDC
ARE ABOUT THE POSITIONS THEY
WERE ASKING FOR FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE WHEN WE REALIZED THAT.
IT WASN'T THE POSITIONS THEY
WERE ASKING FOR WE'RE NOT REALLY
ENTIRELY.
TO IMPLEMENT FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
BUT BECAUSE THEY HAD OTHER
IMPROVEMENTS THAT CD ZERO IS
TRYING TO MAKE.
TO VARIOUS OF THEIR PROCESSING
OF RECORDS AND SO IF IN FACT
WHAT IS BEING ASKED HERE.
IS VERY SOME PREVENTS THAT MIGHT
HAVE HAPPENED INDEPENDENT OF THE
BILL.
THEN I WANT TO SEE THAT
DISTINGUISHED IN THE B. C. P.
BECAUSE TO BE ASKED. TO EVALUATE
THIS BASED PURELY ON WHAT THE
STATUTORY CHANGE REQUIRES IS
SOMETHING VERY DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT YOU A DEPARTMENT MAY
LEGITIMATELY WANT TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS. TO WITH THE WAY IT
PROCESSES IT PROCESS SEES.
ALSO A RECORDS FOR NOW BECAUSE
IT'S SIMILAR.
IN BUT DISTINGUISHES BECAUSE
IT'S NOT RIGHT NOW DISTINGUISHED
IN THE BCP.
THANK YOU MANAGER [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
WE HAVE IN OUR PROPOSAL YES.
A PUBLIC COMMENT ON THAT
[inaudible]
ONE LAST ITEM.
OKAY ISSUES THAT.
EVIDENCE KIDS -- THE BUDGET
INCLUDES A ONE TIME ALLOCATION.
OF A HUNDRED AND NINETY FOUR
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND IN
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO GEO J. TO
IMPLEMENT AB -- THREE ONE ONE
EIGHT WHICH REQUIRES ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES MEDICAL
FACILITIES AND CRIME LABS -- ANY
OTHER PHILIP FACILITIES AT
RETAIN -- STORE PRESERVE SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE KITS TO CONDUCT
AN AUDIT OF ALL UNTESTED SEXUAL
ASSAULT KITS.
IN A POSITION TO REPORT THEIR
DATA TO THE DOJ.
SO I HAVE VERY MILLER HERE FROM
THE LABS -- TO ANSWERING
QUESTIONS -- BEFORE WE ASK
QUESTIONS I THINK FOR ME IT'S A
SIMILAR CIRCUMSTANCE AS THE
DIFFERENT THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS A
LOT LESS -- THIS SILLY HUNTER
NINETY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS A
GENERAL FUND BUT AGAIN WHEN I
READ.
THE LANGUAGE OF THE BUDGET ACT
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT GAVE ONE
MILLION.
THE LANGUAGE THAT SHALL BE
AVAILABLE FOR THE COMPILATION OF
INFORMATION ON THE NUMBER OF
UNTESTED SEXUALASSAULT KITS
STATEWIDE SO THAT THE THAT'S THE
REPORT WE HAVE HERE -- IT ALSO
SAYS SHALL BE AVAILABLE TO
GRANTS FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES
AND SHALL BE AVAILABLE FOR
SUPPORTER LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
NOW DEPENDING ON HOW SOMEONE
MIGHT READ THAT AND THINK WELL
ARE THESE AND AND AND CERTAINLY --
AS THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT.
WHERE WE APPROVE THIS LANGUAGE
IT WAS CERTAINLY AND A HAND IN
HAND RIGHT?
AND IT DIDN'T DISTINGUISH IT
DIDN'T QUITE PUT OUT THIS MUCH
WILL BE USED FOR THIS THIS MUCH
ABUSE FOR THAT BUT IT CERTAINLY
WAS. O COMPILE THE INFORMATION
THAT'S THE FIRST ON THE UNTESTED
SEXUAL SOCKETS TEST STATEWIDE.
SO.
WHY DO YOU NEED MORE MONEY TO DO
THE THING WE GAVE YOU A MILLION
DOLLARS FOR LAST YEAR?
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR PERRY
MILLER WITH THE GIRLFRIEND SIX
SERVICES -- SO YES -- REALLY
APPRECIATE THE THE MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION AND WE DID PUT
THAT MONEY OUT THERE FOR THE
LOCALS TO USE -- TO DO AN AUDIT
OF THEIR SEXUAL SOCKET WORK I'M
SORRY SAY THAT AGAIN DO THE
REPORT.
WELL THE REPORT IS PENDING
BECAUSE THE AUDIT ISN'T SUPPOSED
TO BE COMPLETED UNTIL JULY FIRST
OF THIS YEAR.
WITH THE REPORT DUE -- THE JULY
THE FOLLOWING YEAR.
RIGHT OKAY BUT THE MILLION SAYS
I MEAN WHAT.
BY ONE GIVE YOU THE ANSWER BUT
ARE YOU TELLING US THAT THE
MILLION WAS INADEQUATE IT SAYS
SHALL BE AVAILABLE FOR THE
COMPILATION OF INFORMATION ON
THE NUMBER OF SEXUAL ASSAULT KIT
STATEWIDE.
SO THAT IS.
THE INFORMATION THAT WE WANT
THAT'S THREE FORTY WOULD GIVE US
ABSOLUTELY AND AND I AM NOT
SAYING THE MILLION DOLLARS IS
ADEQUATE THE WRIST THERE WERE NO
PERSONNEL THEY CAME WITH THAT
MILLION DOLLARS IT WAS JUST A
MILLION DOLLARS TO COMPILE.
GIVE OUT -- AND MAKE SURE THAT
YOU GET AN ACCURATE COUNTING
UNTESTED SEXUAL ASSAULT KITS.
SO WHY DO WE NEED A HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR THOUSAND IT'S JUST A
LIMITED TERM -- PERSON TO
ACTUALLY MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
GET THE REPORT COMPILED WITH ALL
OF THE DATA THAT'S COMING IN
FROM THE LOCALS.
AND IF THAT IS -- A LIMITED TERM --
ALLOCATION THAT THIS BODY
DECIDES CAN COME OUT OF THAT
MILLION DOLLARS THEN.
THAT'S FINE WITH ME.
WELL IT'S JUST THAT IT IS THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET ACT.
AND NOW CERTAINLY IT'S IT'S IT'S
COMPLETELY CONCEIVABLE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT FELT IT WAS
INADEQUATE AT THE TIME BUT I
DON'T REMEMBER IN THE DISCUSSION.
THAT SPECIFIC ASPECT RACE THAT
YOU KNOW THIS REALLY ISN'T GOING
TO BE ADEQUATE FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO COMPILE THE REPORT.
ON YOUR OWN THAT CERTAINLY HEY
IT CAN HAPPEN BUT IT.
WAS NOT DISCUSSED AND IT WAS
PART OF THE ALLOCATION WE GET A
SO AT THE TIME I THINK THE THE
PURPOSE OF THE ALLOCATION WAS TO
DISTRIBUTE IT TO THE THE LOCALS
RIGHT TO GET ACCOUNT AND SO I
DON'T THINK THERE WAS ANY
CONVERSATION AT THAT POINT TIME
ABOUT.
HAVING -- ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF
DOING A REPORT OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT SO EXCEPT THE LINK WHICH
UNDERSTOOD AND I THINK THERE WAS
A IN ITS TIMING.
LINE IN THE BUDGET ACT IT'S IN
THE BILL HAT.
RATE THE VERY FIRST LINE.
THE COMPILATION OF INFORMATION
[inaudible]
UNDERSTOOD OKAY [inaudible]
ANYWAY.
EITHER THE LA OR DIFFERENT
FINANCE.
SENATOR MORE LOOK.
SOBRE HOLD IT OPEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU.
COMMON SIDE OF THIS CONCLUDES
THE BUDGET.
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY AND THE JUDICIARY